So, es ist Juni und wir offenbaren, wir haben beide noch nie Golf gespielt.
Nein.
Wir haben also kein Handicap. Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Das Handicap meint, wie viele Schläge du brauchst, um die gesamten 18 Loch hinter dich zu bringen.
Das heißt, es gibt eine gewisse Zahl von Schlägen, dann kommst du bis auf ein Handicap von null.
Das ist jetzt quasi dann, dass man sagt, es sind...
Home Run. Ist das dann der Home Run?
Nein, nein, nein, man braucht ja schon, also man kommt ja nicht mit einem Schlag
von Loch zu Loch, das kann ja nicht gehen.
Also es gibt einen standardisierten, weil ich dachte Handicap ist so eine Ansage
allgemein über verschiedene Spielflächen.
Nein, es gibt Leute, die durchaus auch semi-professionell sind oder die sehr engagiert sind,
die dann ein Handicap haben können von 5 oder ich glaube Trump behauptet er
hat 6 oder ich glaube Biden sagte dann auch sowas wie 6 oder 8.
Es gibt viele, die dann sich damit begnügen Handicap von 25 zu haben.
Das heißt, die brauchen 25 mehr Schläge als jetzt so ein Tiger Woods oder sowas.
Aber auch die sind dann nicht bei null, die sind bei 1, 2, 3.
Darum geht es. Aber mehr kann ich dir schon zu Golf gar nicht sagen.
Wir können uns also jetzt schnell um Kopf und Kragen reden.
Es ist nur interessant, dass dies als, ja, genau, wir haben ja genug Material da.
Wir sind heute Morgen früh aufgestanden, um die Debatte noch schnell zu sehen.
Du hast dankenswerterweise Clips geschnitten.
Ich kann dir genau sagen, wie es war. Ich lag im Keller, denn ich habe aus Temperaturgründen
einfach der Bequemlichkeit halber im Keller geschlafen.
Ich habe meine erste Corona-Woche hinter mir.
Ich war so noch leicht, man hört es mich näselnd.
Und dann habe ich die Debatte im Keller geguckt und dann bin ich hoch zu meinen
Kindern, die von mir das wollen, was Kinder so wollen.
Eine Brotbüchse und Kram und Sonnencreme und so. Und ich dachte,
endlich wieder normale Leute.
Ich habe schon in der Stunde, die ich im Keller mit Trump und Biden verbracht
habe, vergessen, was es mit der Welt eigentlich auf sich hat.
Was eigentlich wichtig ist. Wie man eigentlich miteinander spricht.
Es ist ein solch desaströses Duell gewesen, dass ich entsetzt darüber war,
was ich heute Morgen sehen musste.
Ich habe dann sogar gedacht, ach ich schaue jetzt nochmal kurz in das alte Duell
rein, also das sie beim ersten Mal aufgeführt haben.
Und sie sind noch ein junger Männermann.
Und selbst da war ja Biden schon nicht der Allerfitteste, aber der Vergleich
jetzt noch einmal ist enorm und zeigt einfach, dass man es hier mit einem sehr
gebrechlichen Mann zu tun hat,
der nicht mehr in der Lage ist, klug zu argumentieren, der nicht mehr in der
Lage ist, den Präsidenten zu performen und um Performance geht es.
Und wir sehen einen Trump, der sich gar nicht viel Mühe macht,
weil das eigentlich ein Selbstläufer zu sein scheint.
Trump beantwortet ja eigentlich jede Frage, die man ihm stellt,
damit, dass er sagt, es sind zu viele Migranten.
Biden hat die alle reingelassen. Er ist der schlimmste Präsident aller Zeiten.
Das ist ja seine Standardaussage, die ja leicht variiert, dann über 90 Minuten.
Genau, wir hören jetzt rein und hören dann Bidens Antwort ist,
nein du bist der Schlechteste aller Zeit.
Es nimmt sich da nicht viel, es war ein bisschen erschreckend.
Also wir hören uns das an, denn der Gruselfaktor, wir haben es jetzt gesehen,
wir sehen es auch hier auf dem Bildschirm, wir müssen es ein bisschen dimmen.
Also es zu sehen, wenn man es sieht, glaube ich, ist allen klar,
der Drops ist gelutscht, es wird nichts.
Also mit Biden ist kein Start mehr zu machen. Mit Trump natürlich auch nicht.
Aber die Hoffnung, die man überhaupt noch hatte, wenn man das Duell geschaut
hat, war ja, dass Biden vielleicht doch ein bisschen lebhafter noch ist,
als man dachte. Was auch nochmal zu dem Hinweis führt.
Denn ab heute werden ja viele diese Gespräche führen.
Es ist nicht das Alter, sondern es ist die Gebrechlichkeit bei Biden.
Man muss da ganz scharf und deutlich sein, denn wir wollen hier kein Ageism
machen oder sowas, sondern Biden ist einfach in einem Zustand,
nur drei Jahre älter als Trump, aber gefühlt 30 Jahre. Also da liegen wirklich Welten dazwischen.
Und da bitte detailliert und genau sein.
Es ist die Gebrechlichkeit, denn, lasst es euch sagen von demjenigen,
der ganz viel über das Alter diskutiert mit Leuten, bei Gebrechlichkeit gibt es kaum Widerworte.
Wenn du mit Alter anfängst, stehen die Omas, Publikum auf und sagen,
sie haben noch nicht so viel Hass auf der Bühne gesehen. Ja, also da Vorsicht.
Okay, wir schauen uns ein paar Clips an. Wir beginnen natürlich mit Eingangsstatements.
Allein um mal zu hören, inhaltlich, okay, das ist schon ganz okay, aber die Performance.
Es wird alles in Ordnung sein. Die Wirtschaft ist zerbrochen.
Es gab keine Jobs. Die Unabhängigkeit steigerte zu 15%. Das war schrecklich.
Und so mussten wir versuchen, alles wieder zusammenzubringen.
Und das ist genau das, was wir begannen zu tun.
Wir hatten gehofft, dass er von den Sehgewohnheiten abweicht und wir einen etwas
lebendigeren kriegen. Haben wir nicht.
Alles monoton. Das geht ja die ganze Debatte über so durch. Es gibt ja keine
Höhen und Tiefen. Er macht ja nichts mehr.
Er ist kein Leben. Und seit Donald Reagan wissen wir, was zählt. Es ist der Auftritt.
Die Performance. Naja, und wenn das überhaupt jemand weiß, dann die Amerikaner.
Dann die, genau. Von Trump zum Staat bekommen wir das, was unsere Sehgewohnheiten erwarten.
Erstaunlich fand ich, dass relativ zügig deutlich wurde, so inhaltlich können
die sich jetzt widersprechen und liegen einfach unter unterschiedlichen Sphären.
Aber der eine wird dem anderen nicht in den fundamentalen Eckdaten der Politik
ausreden, hier doch anders zu sein, sondern nein, nein, wir wollen wirklich gegen die Ausländer.
Und ja, ja, die Reichen sind wirklich zu reich. Nein, nein, die Reichen sind wirklich zu arm und so.
Also die sind da ganz deutlich, man weiß genau, was man kriegt.
Hier zum Beispiel, wir hören jetzt, wie Biden Trump vorwirft,
er hätte ja mit zur Misere beigetragen, indem er die größten Tax Cuts aller
Zeiten gemacht hat, die größten Steuererleichterungen aller Zeiten.
Und Trump nimmt es nicht als Vorwurf an, sondern lächelnd und nickt dabei in
die Kamera. Also die Botschaften ans Publikum sind klar.
In American History, 2 Trillionen Dollars. He raised a deficit larger than any
President has in any one term.
He's the only President other than Herbert Hoover who's lost more jobs than
he had when he began, since Herbert Hoover.
Ja, Trump steht daneben. Ja, den letzten Punkt, den rede ich ihm gleich wieder
aus, aber das mit den Textcuts, genau, das ist meine Werbebotschaft eigentlich.
Danke, dass du sie mir auch nochmal den Leuten unterbringst.
Trumps Covid-Performance wird hier nochmal aufgegriffen, denn die Frage ist,
jetzt, wo wir drei, vier Jahre nach der Corona-Pandemie liegen und wir gar nicht
mehr so genau wissen, wie war das nochmal genau?
Gab es einen zweiten Lockdown? Wann war der eigentlich?
Hatten wir die Schulen nochmal zu oder nicht? Also die größten Aufreger ihrer
Zeit sind heute so, ja, keine Ahnung.
In der Hinsicht hat man Trump gesagt, mach Vorwärtsverteidigung. Da bist du eh gut.
Hau denen allen das um die Ohren. Lass die gar nicht erst Themen aufgreifen,
die sie dir angeblich vorhalten, sondern setz sofort den Ton und so mach das auch.
Das ist der größte Unterschied, den wir je gesehen haben, gerade vor Covid.
Und sogar nach Covid. Es war so stark, dass wir durch Covid viel besser als in jedem anderen Land.
Also gar nicht mehr sich jetzt entschuldigen, nochmal gucken,
man hätte vielleicht dies und das tun können.
Nein, er beharrt darauf, dass seine Präsidentschaft die größte aller Zeiten war.
Genau, Covid ist allenfalls eine Zäsur, die halt wie über die Welt hereingebrochen
ist, so während die ganze Inflation allein Biden schuld ist.
Das hat sonst die Welt nicht betroffen.
Covid ist halt einfach so eine
Zäsur und ansonsten war das die allerbeste Präsidentschaft aller Zeiten.
Start paying down debt, we're ready to start using the liquid gold right under
our feet, the oil and gas right under our feet, we were going to have something
that nobody else has had, we got hit with Covid, we did a lot to fix it,
I gave him an unbelievable situation.
Ja. Ich hab dir das beste Land aller Zeiten überlassen, also ich weiß noch,
wie das hier in Deutschland reportiert wurde,
als Corona kam und dann in Amerika diese Woche schon wieder zwei Millionen mehr
Arbeitslose und die nächste Woche schon wieder zwei Millionen mehr arbeitslos.
Am Ende waren 30 Millionen Leute arbeitslos.
Alles war durcheinander. Und das ist für ihn, nö, das war das beste Land aller Zeiten.
Viele Corona-Toten.
Trump wird vergessen. Biden hätte es einfach nur in Ruhe lassen sollen.
So, jetzt können wir natürlich überlegen, wie kann man dem etwas entgegensetzen.
Argumentativ ist das nicht machbar, weil Trump sich überhaupt nicht darauf einlässt.
Also das ist so, wenn du jetzt was zu AI erklärst und ich sage daraufhin,
Stefan ist der schlechteste Podcaster der Welt und alle wissen es zu Hause.
Everyone agrees.
Und damit wissen wir, Dass wir nicht miteinander darüber reden können.
Und wie geht man jetzt damit um? Die einzige Möglichkeit ist ja jetzt auch nur
Performance zu machen und zu sagen, ich, der Präsident Biden,
habe die großartigste Leistung vollbracht.
Ich habe dafür gesorgt, dass und dann muss man die Dinge nicht so wie er das
macht, so ganz, ja, schulbuchhaft aufzählen.
Er nennt ja immer drei Punkte, ist dann immer verwunderlich,
dass er wirklich alle drei auch noch nennen kann.
Gelingt nicht immer.
Gelingt nicht immer, ja. Aber er muss dann eigentlich den Präsidenten spielen
und muss zeigen, dass er derjenige ist, der es noch besser performt.
Es geht bei diesen Duellen ja, wie wir hier schon an diesen winzigen Clips sehen,
überhaupt nicht um inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung.
Das zeigt sich besonders, wenn wir jetzt noch die Fragen einblenden würden.
Also Trump wird irgendwas gefragt, ob er mit Putin verhandeln würde und...
Biden kommt erst nochmal, Trump kommt erst nochmal zwei Minuten auf die Textcuts zu sprechen.
Also Trump beantwortet, ich hab dazu auch viele Clips, die aber aus Zeitgründen nicht gucken.
Trump bekommt eine Frage, zum Beispiel, ich kann ja mal lesen,
was ich so rauskriege, also Klimakrise.
Oder sehr viele Menschen bezahlen noch mehr Geld für Kinderbetreuung als fürs Wohnen.
Und Trump beantwortet keine einzelnen dieser Fragen, sondern er sagt immer,
ich will nochmal drauf zurückkommen, was Biden eben sagte.
Weil diese Stimmung lag ja immer noch in der Luft. Diese Frage dazwischen sagt
halt substantiv irgendwie mäßig, ne?
So große Dramen, aber nicht große Emotionalverfang.
Und dann werden solche gigantischen Themen einfach ausgeblendet.
Und das, was du jetzt meintest, ja, also Bidens Aufgabe ist hier wirklich tricky.
Ich referiere mal ein bisschen, was ich so bei Hacks on Tap,
also da sind ja David Axelrod, also der große Wahlkampfleiter.
Und election Magier David Axelrod und ihm gegenüber Mike Murphy,
der so ganz viele die den republikanischen Präsidenten betreute und jetzt eben
durch Trump da so ein bisschen in das Gegenlager wechselt.
Und die meinten, für Biden wäre es die größte Herausforderung gewesen,
den Leuten zu sagen, es läuft viel besser, als es laufen könnte.
Also wir haben Wirtschaftswachstum von 4% oder so in Amerika.
Wir haben diesen Inflation Reduction Act, der sehr viel Industrie nach Amerika holt.
Und so, also das betonen, wie man die Welt outperformt, während man gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig ganz viel Verständnis dafür zeigt, dass es für die Leute so teuer
ist wie noch nie und sie sich für die großen Metathemen eigentlich nicht interessieren.
Und diese Herausforderung, das auf diese, sagen wir mal, 30 Sekunden,
weil wir gucken hier Clips, so wie die ganze Welt diese Debatte guckt.
Das sind TikTok-Schnipsel, das sind irgendwelche YouTube-Videos,
Twitter-kleine Dinger, die die nächsten Wochen auftauchen.
Niemand guckt die ganze Debatte am Stück.
Also ja, klar, es gucken so ein paar Millionen zu, aber das Linksohr,
Rechtesohr bleiben tut das, was dann sozusagen im Kondensat da mündet.
Und diese Botschaft zu vermitteln, wäre sowieso schon eine krasse Herausforderung gewesen.
Also auf der einen Seite dieses, ich habe es schon ganz schön gut gemacht und
ich weiß, für euch ist es trotzdem blöd, aber es war eine große Krise und so weiter.
Und eigentlich kaum zu machen.
Naja, er müsste zeigen, dass er ja einen Masterplan hat.
Ich bin nicht so begeistert von diesem Plan. Wir werden ja heute noch ein bisschen
über China vielleicht sprechen und die E-Mobilität.
Aber im Ganzen ist ja dieser Inflation Reduction Act Ein protektionistischer Akt,
der die heimische Industrie stärken will,
allerdings auch unter der Prämisse, dass man sie in Teilen abschwächt,
um dann aber so ein großes Problem oder was man als Problem ansieht zu lösen, nämlich China.
Man will China schwächen, muss sich dadurch aber möglicherweise auch ein bisschen selbst schwächen.
Das müsste er verkaufen können und ja, das geht nur über Umwege.
Er müsste also eine sehr direkte Ansprache finden. Ich glaube allerdings,
dass es fast nicht möglich ist mehr, wenn du jemanden gegenüberstehen hast wie Trump,
der einfach auf keine einzige Frage mehr eingeht, der sich einfach mit diesen
Dingen nicht mehr auseinandersetzt und im Zweifelsfall immer antwortet.
Biden hat Millionen Menschen hierhin geholt, die kommen alle über die Grenzen,
die kommen aus Nervenheilanstalten und Gefängnissen hier rüber und machen sich
hier breit und nirgends ist es mehr sicher.
Wenn man das fortwährend sagt, ist also mit Trump keine Debatte mehr möglich,
also kann er nur noch eine Debatte entweder mit den Moderatoren führen oder
mit den Zuschauern direkt zu Hause.
Dafür müsste man aber in der Lage sein, die Zuschauer direkt anzusprechen und
das tut Biden gar nicht mehr.
Biden redet das so für sich, zeigt noch vielleicht das Interesse seinen Demokraten
unter Beweis zu stellen, dass er doch noch einigermaßen formulieren kann.
Das ist aber nicht gelungen.
Also ich habe noch dann heute 15 Minuten CNN so eine Runde mir angesehen,
in der nur Leute saßen, die Biden toll finden und die Demokraten sich alles
für die Demokraten wünschen würden.
Und da war eine solche Enttäuschung, ja fast Tränen in den Augen hatten die
Leute, die da gesprochen haben, dass man dachte, okay, diese Geschichte ist
für Biden sehr schlecht ausgegangen.
Sehr schlecht ausgegangen. Wir können ja mal, dieses Thema wurde von Precht,
als er jetzt bei Junge Naiv war.
Sehr deutlich markiert, ohne dass der Chat oder Thilo oder irgendwer darauf eingestiegen ist.
Im Buch wurde es auch nicht so deutlich, aber Prechter hat es an einem Wort
festgemacht, Subkutan. Was bedeutet das?
Subkutan, habe ich jetzt per Plexi-D gefragt, ist ein Fachbegriff aus der Medizin oder so.
Es geht um eine anatomische Ortsangabe. steht da, ist unter der Haut.
Es ist nicht sichtbar, aber es prägt den Gesundheitszustand.
Jetzt kann man wegen Symptomen zum Arzt gehen und dann sagt er,
mach mal hier, Creme da und so weiter und vielleicht Make-up.
Aber nein, man müsste eigentlich an die subkultaren Ursachen eines Problems.
Und das Problem, was Precht ja schildert, ist ja auf die Frage,
woher kommt der Rechtsruck?
Es gibt subkultaren, auch über die AfD-Wählerschaft hinaus, das Gefühl,
dass man nicht Nicht mehr als Deutschland oder Europa oder der Westen so wichtig ist.
Der Bedeutungsverlust der eigenen Nation und Europas.
Make America Great Again ist exakt das Versprechen, dass dies aufgreift und
sagt, mit uns aber nicht, wir werden schon dafür sorgen.
Also diese, was subkutan deshalb, weil es ja nicht so ist, dass wenn ich jetzt
auf der Straße einen AfD-Wähler fragen würde, warum hast du die gewählt, dann sagt der.
Genau, der kann das nicht sagen.
Dann sagt er nicht, ja sehen Sie, die geopolitische Situation ist ja folgende,
natürlich antwortet er es nicht, sondern er wird höchstens auf jemanden zeigen,
da sind wieder Ausländer, aber er kann nicht in die höhere Analyse hineingehen,
ist aber ganz in dieser Weltanschauung eigentlich drin, ohne dass er es auf den Punkt bringen kann.
Genau.
Und Trump hat das bis heute, dieses Talent, genau diese Subkultane aufzugreifen
und auf den Punkt zu bringen,
der führt ja auch überhaupt gar nichts geopolitisch aus, außer zu sagen,
make America great again und mir hätte es diesen Ukraine-Krieg nie gegeben.
Genau. Die Frage ist, wer von den beiden kann die Stimmung gut treffen,
bei der sich Menschen, die ansonsten nicht in der Lage sind,
inhaltlich über ihr Schicksal sich zu äußern, sich verstanden fühlen. Ja.
So, und jetzt hören wir mal diesen Clip, wie gut das Trump gelingt.
Zerstören. So, inhaltlich ist das nicht der Rede wert. Ja. Das ist völlig klar.
Aber auf dieser, wir müssen hier ins Subkutane, unter der Haut,
den diesen Nerv treffen.
Wir werden nicht mehr respektiert. Wir sind ein drittes Weltland.
Und jetzt macht er auch noch die Grenzen auf und schickt die ganzen Verbrecher hier rein.
Trump hat später noch eine Erklärung dafür. Das sollen mal seine Wähler sein. Deswegen macht er das.
Also die Verschwörungstheorien werden gestrickt. Aber mittendrin in diesem Clip
war noch so ein sehr wirkmächtiges.
Und das würde ich ihn auch gerne mal fragen.
Stellvertretend für das Publikum. Herr Biden, warum richten Sie uns so zugrunde?
Und das sind diese Sachen, die bei uns natürlich, wir übersehen sie,
wenn wir sie so in der Debatte hören.
Aber es gibt Leute, die sehen das vom Fernsehen und sind da Feuer und Flamme.
Manchmal wird das ja sehr explizit, denn du erinnerst dich, dass der CEO der
deutschen Börse, Theodor Weimar, eine Rede hielt und sagte, Deutschland wird
nicht mehr ernst genommen.
Deutschland wird wie ein Entwicklungsland inzwischen wahrgenommen.
Wirtschaftlich läuft nichts mehr und das Migrationsproblem kriegt niemand in den Griff.
Also eine sehr ähnliche Rede als die verglichen jetzt mit der deutschen Börse. Und was ist die Folge?
Es wird von allen Rechten und Konservativen geteilt und damit wird verbunden,
seht ihr, der Abstieg ist keine
Illusion, der von der deutschen Börse sagt das auch, wir sind am Ende.
Also dieses subkutane Sprechen haben wir da von einem aus der Wirtschaft erlebt
und das ist dann nur etwas, was man politisch aufgreifen muss und bei Trump
geht das dann natürlich Hand in Hand.
Er zeigt sich auch immer noch als Unternehmer dadurch, dass er sagt,
ich habe ganz viele Leute während meiner Amtszeit gefeuert.
Biden hat noch nie jemanden gefeuert.
Ja, das ist, ich habe es leider auch ausgelagert, aber vielleicht gucken wir
das später nochmal irgendwann.
Trump kriegt immer wieder diesen Vorwurf, du hast unsere Truppen als Loser bezeichnet.
Und dann sagt Trump, nein, das habe ich ja gar nicht und wenn ich einen als
Loser bezeichne, dann nur deinen Sohn und sowas, solche Sachen.
Und kommt dann aber mit diesem Punkt, Afghanistan war so eine Schande für unser
Land, ich hätte alle verantwortlichen Militär gefeuert.
Also Trump ist da auf der inhaltlichen Ebene völlig verantwortlich.
Inkonsistent und rantet gegen die Hälfte der Militärs, die jetzt gerade da im Amt sind.
Also es ist völlig verrückt. Wir haben ja typischerweise, wenn jetzt hier so
eine subkutane wir treffen mal den
Nerv unter der Haut Angelegenheit stattfindet, dann sagen wir ja immer,
das ist doch nur ein Gefühl, wir müssen doch jetzt hier mal die Sozialpolitik,
die armen Leute und so weiter.
Können wir ja auch aus Europa, wir haben so ein bisschen den doppelten Macron.
Außenpolitisch greift da so also dieses subkutane Europas Bedeutungsverlust
auf und versucht da die große europäische Verlangs- und Verteidigungsfähigkeit
aufzubauen, während er im Land die Rentenpolitik und die Sozialpolitik und Reichensteuer
gibt es schon mal gar nicht und so.
Also da völlig so, dass wir alle sagen, nee, das geht ja gar nicht.
So, also Trump hat jetzt dieses Angebot gemacht.
Außenpolitisch sind wir hier ein Niemand. Niemand respektiert uns mehr.
Kein Wunder, dass hier alle Kriege über unsere Köpfe hinweg machen.
Wir werden nicht mehr respektiert. Jetzt versucht Joe Biden,
das auf linker Ebene mit, ja gut, dann mache ich mal Anmerkungen zur Sozialpolitik, zu kontern.
Und wir hören uns mal im Vergleich zu dem Singensang eben und wie der verfängt,
versuchen wir jetzt auf uns wirken zu lassen, wie diese Anmerkungen zur Sozialpolitik hier wirken.
Making sure that we're able to make every single solitary person eligible for
what I've been able to do with the
COVID, excuse me, with dealing with everything we have to do with COVID.
Look, if we finally beat Medicare. Thank you, President Biden. President Trump?
He was right. He did beat Medicare. He beat it to death. And he's destroying Medicare.
Because all of these people are coming in. They're putting them on Medicare.
They're putting them on Social Security. They're going to destroy Social Security.
This man is going to single-handedly destroy Social Security.
These millions and millions of people coming in, they're trying to put them on Social Security.
Es ist unglaublich, das zu sehen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich der Clip, der dafür sorgen wird, ich will nicht dafür
sorgen, aber möglicherweise denken die Demokraten doch nochmal über einen anderen Kandidaten nach.
Esra Klein hat es ja in seinem Podcast aufgeschlüsselt, wie wirkmächtig die
Partei bei ihrer eigenen Convention ist.
Dass die Vorwahlen, also fanden ja auch für Biden statt, so ein bisschen unter
dem Radar, ohne Gegenkandidat, dass man die Vorwahlen durchaus ignorieren kann.
Man hätte dann natürlich das Problem wie damals bei Clinton,
als es hieß, naja, macht die Partei ja immer. Aber diesmal könnte die Notwendigkeit,
aber ob das für das allgemeine Publikum noch verständlich zu transportieren ist.
Ist es zu kurzfristig vielleicht, um das noch zu machen.
Vor allem die ganze Partei müsste sich auf einen Gegenkandidaten einigen,
ohne dass es da nochmal Streit gibt.
Ohne dass man ein Verfahren vorher hatte, das Publikum nochmal mitentscheiden zu lassen.
Und dann hast du Wittchen oder wie sie heißt und Newsom, die vielleicht dann beide wollten und.
Also die einzige Möglichkeit wäre, dass Biden jetzt selbst ein Einsehen hat
und sagt, ich höre jetzt auf.
Aber das glaube ich nicht, dass das passiert. Das hätte er viel früher erkennen
müssen, das hätte sein Umfeld erkennen müssen. Und es geht ja hier,
wie gesagt, nicht, weil das dann immer so ein bisschen dargestellt wird,
ja, jetzt wird das gesucht.
Es geht nicht darum, dass man mal irgendwann den Faden verliert oder dass einem
ein Wort nicht einfällt und dass man mal ein bisschen aus dem Fahrwasser gerät.
Aber man kann einfach an der gesamten Performance und an dem,
was gesprochen wird, erkennen, dass hier jemand alle Kraft zusammennehmen muss,
um überhaupt noch durch diese Debatte durchzukommen.
Und wir sehen zugleich einen Schwätzer wie Trump da, der einfach daneben steht,
er weiß, es gibt einen Splitscreen.
Wir sehen rechts den stammelnden Biden, wir sehen links Trump,
der schaut, der schaut zu Biden rüber, muss euch da gleich helfen, was ist mit dem los.
Und genau diese Bildsprache ist es, die so wirkmächtig ist, dass jetzt noch
100 gute Argumente kommen könnten, die kommen ja nicht, aber die könnten kommen
und es würde nicht helfen.
Und das ist hier 13. Minute, da sind die Leute noch aufmerksam.
Das ist ja nicht wie beim Fußball, dass alle nur die letzten 10 Minuten gucken.
Hier ist ja genau umgedreht.
Das gesamte Konzept USA beruht auf Stärke.
Das ist ein reines Stärke-Konzept. Die ganze Weltpolitik, wissen wir jetzt von
den strukturellen Realisten, ist ein Machtgeschachere und da geht es darum zu
zeigen, dass man stark ist.
Dies zeigt, wir haben es mit einem schwachen Präsidenten zu tun.
Selbstverständlich hat er gute Leute im Hintergrund, aber das ist das, was am Ende verfängt.
Die er auch nicht zeigt. Das ist eine ganz große Kritik.
Ja, die zeigt er gar nicht. Man sieht ja gar keine jungen Leute.
Das war ja bei Obama doch auch noch anders.
Obama hatte auch das sehr auf sich zentriert, aber trotzdem hat man noch andere wahrgenommen.
Er hat ja ein junges Kabinett, Pete Buttigieg, der ja auch mit ihm schon auf
der Debattenbühne stand damals.
Nirgendwo zu sehen. Entsprechend einfach ist es für Trump hier rhetorisch einfach
so Cash-In-Momente zu machen.
Ja, und man sieht dann auch hier wieder im Splitscreen Bidens Gesicht, das sich...
Guckt auf den Boden, gibt sich geschlagen.
Ja, wie kann das sein?
Tepper fragt jetzt mal Biden nach seiner wichtigsten sozialpolitischen Maßnahme.
Es sind wirklich nur wenige Sekunden, die man hier mal kurz,
ja, das ist schon ganz gut, das so zu sagen. Wir wissen alle,
ein amerikanischer Präsident meint es nie so.
Außerdem, was wollen sie noch für den Sozialstaat tun? Biden gelingt eine kleine Pointe.
So,
jetzt hat Biden hier gesagt, die wichtigste sozialpolitische Maßnahme ist,
Trump zu bekämpfen und zu besiegen.
Er darf nicht Präsident werden, denn er würde den Sozialstaat abschaffen. Jetzt kontert Trump.
So, zum einen greift er auf, wofür er mal kritisiert wird, das kennt man ja
so als Moodle bei ihm, dass er dann immer den anderen vorwirft,
eigentlich solltet ihr alle ins Gefängnis, ihr wollt mich ins Gefängnis stecken
und ich soll ein Lügner sein, ihr seid doch alle Lügner, also Biden ist ein großer Lügner,
denn Social Security,
Ja,
der Sozialstaat wird zerstört, weil Migranten kommen und in New York in Luxushotels leben.
Bereitgestellt von Joe Biden, der sich später als Wähler braucht.
Nur auch hier wieder das Bild, Splitscreen, wir sehen beiden,
wie er konstant auf den Boden guckt, beziehungsweise er hat ja,
das habe ich dann ein paar Mal gesehen,
doch ein paar Seiten dort liegen, Manuskript, sie dürfen ja eigentlich nicht
viel damit reinnehmen, aber so ein paar Stichpunkte, irgendwas ist da,
er hebt da auch mal irgendwas hoch, während er dann nicht dran ist.
Ist, das geht alles nicht und das weiß eigentlich ein Biden,
das wusste ein Biden vor zehn Jahren,
dass man in die Kamera die ganze Zeit blickt, dass man mämisch signalisiert,
dass man nicht einverstanden ist, dass man sich über den Einwand lustig macht,
was auch immer, dass so es funktioniert, das weiß jeder fast intuitiv.
Zumindest jeder, der schon einmal im Fernsehen aufgetreten ist.
Das Problem ist, Biden weiß das ja auch, aber er kann es halt nicht und das
sieht man daran, er kann es nicht, er ist zu gebrechlich dafür.
Und das heißt aber, doch, dass wir jetzt dieses Duell, wir bemühen uns noch
ein bisschen, inhaltlich fassen, aber eigentlich beobachten wir hier nur noch Bilder und Ausdrücke.
Wir machen jetzt also das, was.
Die KIs noch nicht so gut können, also das Bilder so auslesen, welche Emotionen,
ja, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt gleich was dazu sage, aber das ist gerade
quasi das neue Feld, das jetzt ganz groß wird,
also welche Infos kann man über Kameras gewinnen, wenn man Kameras einsetzt,
also die Sicht, die aufgeschriebene Welt ist eingespeist bei ChatGPT und sonst wo,
aber die sichtbare Welt, All das, was mimisch ausgedrückt werden kann,
das ist etwas, was wir jetzt hier noch in erster Linie machen.
Wir gucken uns das an, denn Inhalte werden eh keine sinnvollen verhandelt und
daraufhin werden jetzt Wahlentscheidungen getroffen.
Ich frage mich ja schon, wenn man jetzt, wir haben ja viel über Demokratie in
den letzten Salons gesprochen, das nochmal sich so vergegenwärtigt,
welche Art von Wahl findet eigentlich statt?
Es ist am Ende doch das, was alle einstudiert bekommen,
wenn sie Deutschland sucht den Superstar oder Supertalent sehen,
irgendeine Performance und am Ende sagen Nena oder Dieter Bohlen,
da habe ich aber Gänsehaut bekommen und das war's.
Also wir können das, was du jetzt sagtest, mal testweise an einem Clip.
Es ist ganz interessant, weil wir gucken das ja gerade, also wir sehen die beiden
auch, wir schreiben es ja für euch.
Ihr hört das ja nur, selbst wenn ihr den Podcast schaut, ihr hört das ja nur.
Jetzt ist es aber so, nicht nur wird die Debatte geschaut, in dem sehr viele
Leute ganz kurze TikTok-Schnipsel und so sehen, sondern die Bildsprache wird
natürlich auch transportiert, ganz häufig, wo kein Ton mitgeliefert wird.
Öffentlicher Raum, Bildschirm, wir hängen rum, Wartezimmer, irgendwas.
So, man sieht diese beiden. Und wir hören jetzt einen Clip von Trump und jeder
fragt sich, wäre ich in der Lage, diesen Clip genau so zu verstehen,
wie ich ihn gehört habe, wenn ich ihn nur sehen würde, aber nicht hören.
Ist es darstellbar, dass Trump über Mimik, Gestik, Haptik dieselbe Botschaft
jetzt transportiert, die wir nur hören?
Und ich glaube, wir haben alle das Bild vor Augen und wissen eigentlich,
warum es funktioniert, warum 70 Millionen Wähler sagen, ja, ja, den werde ich wählen.
Ich werde es euch zeigen. Und sie haben mich als einen der Besten gewählt.
Und wenn ich noch vier Jahre bin, werde ich der Beste sein. Ich denke,
ich werde der Beste sein.
Das funktioniert einfach auch ohne Ton. Da guckt man das Bild und Trump sagt, ich bin der Beste.
Und die Leute, ich will den Besten. Und dann, ja, dann wähl doch mich.
Okay, so, das ist dann der Kurzschluss, der da kommt.
Biden wird jetzt explizit zu seinem Alltag gefragt.
Ja, das kann man natürlich sagen. Er ist jünger, aber inkompetenter.
Oder weniger kompetent. Aber wenn man so klingt dabei, hat man eine Bild-Tonschere.
Dann klappt es nicht so richtig.
Was ist überhaupt mit der Stimme da los? Das ist ja immer schlechter.
Er war besonders schwach. Oder es ist ein normaler Zustand. Jonathan Stewart
hat ja gefragt, wenn ihr immer behauptet, er hat den Laden im Griff,
dann zeigt uns doch mal die Bilder davon.
Wir sehen ihn immer nur gebrechlich. Und jetzt hier haben wir wieder nur gebrechlich gesehen.
Ja, es war doch jetzt auch nochmal in den öffentlich-rechtlichen auf einer Seite,
ich kann es jetzt nicht sicher sagen, ZDF oder ARD, wo nochmal aufgeschrieben
wurde in einem langen Artikel, dass das rechte Narrative sind,
dass Biden gebrechlich ist.
Das war Tagesschau gestern.
Ein Tagesschau war das und dann denke ich mir, gut, es mag sein,
dass die Rechten hin und wieder auch Videos so schneiden, dass er besonders
geprächtig wirkt oder was aus dem Kontext zerren.
Aber generell wird niemand nach diesem oder nach den anderen Auftritten,
die beiden jetzt in den letzten Monaten hatten, sagen, dass das ein Mann ist,
dem man das Präsidentssein zutraut.
Jetzt verhandeln Sie nochmal die ganz harten Themen. Wir haben sie ja schon
zu Beginn angesprochen.
Gewonnen, nicht mal Senior-Championship. Zwei normale Club-Championships.
Um das zu tun, musst du ziemlich klug sein und den Ball einen langen Weg schießen.
Und ich mache das. Er tut das nicht. Er kann keinen Ball 50 Jahre schießen.
Er hat mich zu einem Golf-Match gefordert, er kann keinen Ball 50 Jahre schießen.
Dann dachte ich, wenn man jetzt so zwei Ortsbürgermeister in einem Duell erleben
würde. Die würden sich ja nicht schlechter anstellen.
Bei Ortsbürgermeistern habe ich ja, also ich denke ja immer,
die Themen, die die hier verhandeln, wenn du das auf eine Ebene tiefer sagst,
würde dich jeder aus dem Saal schicken und sagen, du bist bescheuert.
Ich habe das schon mal angesprochen, in welcher Leichtfertigkeit Merz,
Dobrindt und so weiter immer vor der Kamera stehen und völlig verfassungswidrige
Sachen einfach fordern,
während du selber in deiner Vereinstätigkeit bei jeder kleinen Satzungsänderung
dir wirklich viele Gedanken machst, das vorher besprichst mit den Leuten,
bevor das überhaupt mal Tagesordnungsthema relevant wird.
Und die stehen einfach da und kloppen da die wirklich 1a verfassungswidrigen
Bürgergeldsachen hier, Migration, Grenze und so weiter einfach durch.
Das ist unglaublich. Ich meine, wir gucken hier auf eine Schule,
hier sitzen 1400 Schüler, die werden alle über kurz oder lang ihren Schulabschluss schreiben.
Da kannst du sowas, wie die beiden hier machen, nicht bringen.
Nicht eine Sekunde davon kannst du in so einer mündlichen Prüfung abliefern.
Die zeigen dir einen Vogel und schicken dich nach Hause.
Und die stehen hier da und machen 90 Minuten Also wir hören uns jetzt mal die,
was wird hier gerade verhandelt in diesem nächsten Clip.
By the way, I told you before, I'm happy to play golf if you carry your own bag.
Think you can do it? That's the biggest lie that he's a six handicap of all.
I was an eight handicap. Eight?
I've seen you swing, I know you swing. Let's not act like children.
President Trump, we're going to get married. Let's not act like children.
Und jetzt sagt schon Trump, let's not act like children. Denn Biden beantwortet
diese Handicap-Frage oder greift sie auf in einer Ernsthaftigkeit,
als gäbe es jetzt den Nahostweg zu beenden.
Es ist so absurd und deswegen muss ich das nochmal klarstellen,
dass ich nicht meinte, dass Ortsbürgermeister auf diesem Niveau diskutieren,
sondern die müssen ja fachlich sich auseinandersetzen. Die müssen ja wissen,
kann man da eine Umgehungsstraße bauen oder nicht.
Aber ich würde sagen, von der reinen Performance, ja, wie wirkt man vor einer
Kamera, würde ich sagen, kann das jeder, der noch nie vor einer Kamera stand,
mindestens genauso gut wie das, was Biden jetzt da abliefert.
Ja, also ich kann es nicht in Worte fassen, wie ich das finde, was wir hier sehen.
An jedem Gartenzaun wäre es unmöglich, wenn da einfach ein 83-Jähriger steht
und sagt, du bist fett, kannst ja nicht mal dein Golfding selber tragen und
guck dich doch mal an. Ja.
Und der andere fragt dann, was hast du denn für ein Handicap?
Ja, da fragt man nicht, genau, da fragt man nicht zurück und so,
sondern das ist dann einfach nur gut alter Mann und so, ne? Das ist hier eine
Präsidentendebatte in Amerika.
Also ich finde dafür keine Worte. Trump, natürlich.
Ja, also er wird eigentlich von Biden zurückgerufen, nachdem Biden alles in den Sand gesetzt hat.
Muss er kommen. Ich muss jetzt Amerika retten, denn, und das ist so absurd,
auf der einen Seite dieses,
wer schafft es noch, seinen eigenen Golfdings zu tragen, wer ist wie fett und
gaukelt aber vor, eigentlich ein bisschen leichter zu sein, schau ihn dir doch
an und so und dann aber die Themen.
Ich frage mich, wie es ist, wenn du zum Bewerbungsgespräch gehst und sagst,
ich habe Ihren Chef gestern im Fernsehen gesehen, deswegen bewerbe ich mich hier.
Ich müsste gar nicht hier sein, aber Ihr Unternehmen, haben Sie Ihren Chef im
Fernsehen gesehen? Das ist ja unglaublich.
Das muss jetzt mal besser gemacht werden. Nehmen Sie mal mich.
Ich bin der Beste, den Sie je eingestellt haben. Ich werde hier Chef werden.
So ungefähr wäre das, ja? Ob Sie so als Zögling da rein? Es ist alles gruselig.
Aber hier sind wir wieder beim Subkutanen. Die Amerikaner wollen keinen Krieg.
Menschen wollen in der Regel keinen Krieg.
Und er sagt, dieser Präsident führt die Nation in den dritten Weltkrieg und
das müssen wir verhindern. Das wirkt.
Absolut. Also dazu werden wir gleich nochmal, wir gehen mal diesen Rundown durch.
Du erinnerst mich an einen Clip, den wir gleich unbedingt noch spielen müssen.
Wird Trump die Niederlage, wenn sie ihn denn ereilt, nach Wahlergebnis akzeptieren?
Die Frage war, ob du die Ergebnisse dieser Wahl akzeptieren wirst, egal wer gewinnt.
Just to finish what he said, if I might. Russia.
Ja, das ist wieder dieses typische. Ach, Sie haben mir eine Frage gestellt,
auch so eine wichtige Frage. Das ist mir egal. Ich schließe nochmal kurz.
Ich habe noch ein anderes Thema. Russia.
So, aber er kriegt die Frage natürlich dann nochmal.
This man is a criminal. This man, you're lucky. You're lucky. I did nothing wrong.
We'd have a system that was rigged and disgusting. I did nothing wrong.
Ja, er will sie immer noch nicht beantworten. Er braucht noch eine dritte Nachfrage.
Aber ja, das System ist kaputt und er hat ja nichts Falsches gemacht.
Und jetzt steht er ja wieder zu einer regulären Wahl. Das wird ja schon irgendwie hinhauen.
Also, nimmt er jetzt die Wahl an oder nicht, wenn er verliert?
President Trump, the question was, will you accept the results of the election?
Regardless of who wins, yes or no, please?
If it's a fair and legal and good election, absolutely.
Also nein.
Diesen Clip werden wir noch ein paar Mal hören. Ja. Denn das öffnet natürlich wieder Tür und Tor.
Biden hat, finde ich, schon einen ganz guten allerletzten Moment gehabt,
bevor dann die Ausgangsstatements kamen.
Mal verloren hast. Ja, du bist ein Whiner, irgendwas ist bei dir kaputt gegangen,
als du das letzte Mal verloren hast. Es sind doch Rache-Gelüste.
Zum Thema Rache äußern sie sich sehr viel. Trump sagt halt einfach,
meine Rache wird mein Erfolg sein.
Na gut, bisschen theatralisch. Bevor wir nochmal drei Clips zur Abtreibung schauen,
hören wir nochmal zwei Clips aus Amerika und die Welt.
Das sind also Clips, die sind heute nicht allzu entscheidend.
In einem Fall aber doch, da wir es häufiger angesprochen haben.
Biden, hören wir hier mal, wie stotternd er Trump vorwirft. Aber du hast doch
zu Putin gesagt, mach was du willst.
Wenn die hier nicht zahlen, dann steh ich mal aus der NATO aus und so.
Trump feiert sich nochmal dafür. Aber ich habe die doch voll krass erpresst.
Ich darf das eigentlich gar nicht sagen, aber in so einer geheimen Sitzung habe
ich denen gesagt, wenn ihr hier nichts bezahlt, verteidigt euch nicht gegen
Putin. Und dann haben die plötzlich alle gezahlt und so.
Also das hat ihm ja das erste Amtsenthebungsverfahren eingebracht,
weil er das nämlich Selenskyj am Telefon so gegenüber gesagt hat.
Also wenn du hier nicht zahlst, die 400 Millionen und so, dann,
nee, so. Also, wenn du mir nicht beistehst bei einem CNN-Interview und mich lobhudelst,
dann zahle ich dir die 400 Millionen Militärhilfe gegen Putin nicht.
Und das war noch vor dem Krieg.
Gut, also hier zwei Clips, wie Biden es komplett verstolpert,
hier Vorwürfe zu machen.
This guy told Trump, do whatever you want and do whatever you want.
And that's exactly what Trump did to Putin, encourage him, do whatever you want.
Also einfach alle Substantive durcheinander gebracht. Er hat der Ukraine,
Trump gesagt, mach doch was du willst, Putin.
Also muss man erstmal, das erfordert so viel Mitdenken bei den Leuten,
damit sie überhaupt verstehen, was er hier sagt.
Solche müssen ja eigentlich wirklich wie eine gesungene Phrasierung sitzen,
ansonsten wirken die gar nicht.
Sie waren es, die dafür gesorgt haben.
Genau, das muss auch geübt werden und so weiter, also so funktioniert das gar nicht.
Und dann reagiert Trump wie folgt zum Thema Ukraine-Krieg.
Ich habe Ich werde den Krieg zwischen Putin und Zelenskyy als Präsident der
Europäischen Union vor dem Aufruf am 20.
Januar beschlossen haben. Ich werde den Krieg beschlossen haben.
Leute werden so unnötig und so dumm getötet.
Ich werde ihn beschlossen haben und ich werde ihn schnell beschlossen haben,
bevor ich aufrufen werde.
Gesagt, am Tag 1 wird er das machen. Jetzt sagt Trump noch vorher.
Er hat den jetzt inzwischen im November als Wahl, im Januar als Amtseid,
in der Zeit will er den Ukraine-Krieg lösen. Und ich glaube, dass es geht.
Die große Ansage des President-Elect, er fährt dahin, macht einen Deal,
sagt den Europäern, das ist der Fall, Alarm unterschrieben, verteidigt euch
selber, wenn ihr weiter Krieg machen wollt, macht, aber ohne uns. Ja.
Und er wird der große Friedenspräsident für ungefähr drei Milliarden Menschen
auf der Welt sein, die sich übrigens jetzt gerade sagen,
ach ihr habt diesen Assange freigelassen, jaja, was war nochmal das große Thema
des Assange, dass er euch vorgehalten hat, Collateral Murder,
dass aggressive Angriffskriege falsch sind. Ja.
Und selbst nach einer Million Toten im Krieg gegen Irak habt ihr das immer noch nicht eingesehen.
Also diese Ursünde, dass Angriffskriege jetzt wieder gehen, nachdem wir eigentlich
das Ende der Geschichte ausgerufen hatten und so.
Der Brecht auch nochmal betont, wie wichtig das eigentlich ist.
Das ist alles subkultan steckt das hier drin.
Ja, ich meine, wir bekommen jetzt nochmal von allen Seiten, von den deutschen
Medien, von den Podcastern gesagt, dass es jetzt auf keinen Fall Verhandlungen
geben darf und wir auf keinen Fall auf Putin eingehen müssen.
Ich will es mal auf einer anderen Ebene nochmal betrachten, nämlich,
was wir ja gerade sehen, ist, dass durch AI alles merkwürdig ins Wanken gerät
und plötzlich müssen sich erbitterte Feinde mal zusammensetzen,
um einen Deal auszuhandeln.
Apple und Meta meinst du?
Apple und Meta. Undenkbar wäre das vor einer Weile gewesen, dass die eine sinnvolle
Verhandlung führen können, aber die haben ja ein gemeinsames Interesse und dieses
heißt Profit und da muss man sehen, wie man sich ins Benehmen setzt.
Und jetzt will ich nicht sagen, Nationen sind genau wie Konzerne,
aber es zeigt ja, dass man Deals schließen kann und ja,
Deals sind meistens so aufgebaut, dass sie für beide Seiten nicht das Beste
rausholen, sondern dass man sich auf ein kleineres Übel, gemeinsames Übel einigen
kann und dennoch ganz gut dabei rauskommt.
Und ich halte das durchaus für möglich, dass Trump etwas verhandelt.
Die Sache ist ja auch, er wird es so machen, dass er das alleine macht und dann
im Prinzip in Berlin und Paris nur noch bekannt gibt, dass er das jetzt so geregelt hat.
Ja, so wie jeder alles nur noch bekannt gibt. Der französische Präsident hat
seiner Regierung nicht gesagt, dass er das Parlament auflöst,
er hat es der Öffentlichkeit gesagt.
Christian Drosten, wir werden dieses Buch lesen, betont wieder und wieder,
dass er den Politikern immer nur sagte, was er in seinem Podcast schon gesagt hat.
Also es gibt eine Bekanntgabe von Informationen und darüber hinaus findet nicht sehr viel statt.
Das einzige, was wir jetzt vermuten können ist, Trump wird irgendwelche Leute
oder irgendwelche Leute werden sich selber beauftragt haben und Trump wird es
dann abnicken, dass man da Vorverhandlungen führt.
Aber für Putin ist das der einzige Weg, aus dem Krieg im Amt zu bleiben.
Dass Trump da so ein Deal macht. Also die Kräfte, von denen wir jetzt sagen
können, die sind wirklich stark.
Das wird hier und unserer Semantik, die nun mit den subkultaren Gegebenheiten
nichts zu tun haben, wir werden hier immer wieder verarscht irgendwie.
Das übliche Podcast-Gespräch, wenn wir Deutschlandfunk-Journalisten zuhören
oder Politikern, die uns einen Talkshow oder irgendwas erzählen,
ist nicht das, wie 80% der Welt darüber denken, was hier passiert.
Und zwar bei beiden Kriegen, Ukraine und Gaza. Da ist die deutsche Position
einfach sehr eigen und sehr abgewendet von dem, was ansonsten diskutiert wird.
Und dieses Versprechen jetzt für die Leute, die ohnehin wenig Perspektive in
den USA haben, wir werden nicht in einen dritten Weltkrieg gehen,
ist schon etwas, was die Leute dazu bringen kann, Trump zu wählen.
Ja, Trump hatte damals 60 Marschflugkörper auf Syrien abgeschossen,
nachdem es da wieder Giftgaseinsätze gab und das haben ihm seine Wähler wirklich übel genommen.
Und das haben die damals auch registriert, die Republikaner,
dass sie wirklich unter keinen Umständen einen Auslandseinsatz des Militärs
wollen, also einen kriegerischen Auslandseinsatz.
Sicherheitstechnisch verfeiern die das natürlich überall, wenn der Flugzeugträger
aufmarschiert und so, nur halt keine schießende Auseinandersetzung.
Gut, wir gucken noch in ein kleines Thema Abtreibung drei Clips,
denn das ist erstens stellvertretend für die Debatte allgemein.
Es wurden ja doch ein paar Themen verhandelt, die wir jetzt aus Zeitgründen
natürlich nicht alle durchschauen und die auch für die Amerikaner sehr viel
interessanter sind als für uns.
Aber dieses Abtreibungsthema ist ja besonders interessant, weil da ja mindestens
mal der Hälfte der Bevölkerung als Frauen oder Töchterhabend oder Mütter,
die betroffen waren oder wie auch immer,
jeder kennt jemanden, gesagt wird, die Republikaner sind im Grunde unwählbar.
Die haben sich damit so ein Eigentor geschossen, dass sie Roe vs.
Wade nach 50 Jahren, wir regeln immer Abtreibungen über Datenschutz und so,
ihr müsst niemandem Bescheid sagen, es bleibt unter euch, was ihr mit dem Arzt
vereinbart, ermöglicht hatten.
Und wie das hier diskutiert wird, ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Denn Trump, wieder mit seiner alten Leier, wenn mir vorgeworfen wird,
ich bin der Radikale, drehe ich das einfach um.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ein Kind mit einem Baby verabredet wurde.
Also er macht jetzt das Bild auf, in Amerika kann man sich nach der biologischen
Geburt noch entscheiden, ein Kind abzutreiben und dann lassen es die Ärzte einfach liegen.
Ja.
Das gibt es nicht mal in Hollywood-Filmen, das gibt es nirgendwo.
Aber da ist man dann einfach bei geblieben.
Also das Maß, in dem hier einfach all-in gegangen wird bei einer Argumentation,
einfach nur ums Performance deliveren zu können, ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Biden versucht nochmal gegenzuhalten.
Ja, das ist zwecklos.
Ja, das ist einfach haarsträubend. Das war die Debatte.
Wir haben hier den künftigen amerikanischen Präsidenten gesehen.
Mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ja.
Es spricht immer weniger dafür, dass hier...
Ich kann mir jedenfalls kein Szenario vorstellen.
Ja und die Alternative ist ein Kreis, der dann hoffentlich so ein bisschen vorgeführt
wird, dass man hin und wieder so ein paar Clips hat,
über die dürfen dann alle lachen, aber die Entscheidungen werden von irgendjemand
anders getroffen im Weißen Haus und Biden muss dann hin und wieder stolperfrei
irgendwo raufgehen und was sagen.
Es ist ja im Grunde das Schicksal beider. Trump hat jetzt dieses riesige Heritage
Foundation Programm da, was Trump da irgendwie untergejubelt werden soll.
Von dem hat Trump ja auch keine Ahnung. Also dann haben die einfach unter der
Hand 50.000 Leute ausgetauscht im Regierungsapparat, die machen dann irgendwas.
Also im Grunde wird ein Deep State installiert, der einfach nur die Chance wettert,
wenn dann jetzt, weil sie sehen auch, wenn Trump jetzt nicht gewählt wird,
dann ist die republikanische Partei gerade in keinem Zustand,
nächsten Kandidaten aufzustellen.
Weil so eine Jahrhundertfigur wie Trump, der einfach medial gestellt ist,
der da eine Freude dran hat und dem wirklich alles scheißegal ist.
Also das braucht auch eine gewisse biologisch-psychische Konstellation im Gehirn.
Die findet man nicht so einfach.
Das ist sozusagen dieses Rodger Breschmann-Argument, mit denen stimmt irgendwas
nicht, wirklich auf die Spitze getrieben. So einen haben die da nicht.
Also das ist jetzt deren Chance, das zu machen. Also machen die das jetzt auch.
Nur das hat mit Trump auch nichts zu tun. So wie die nächste Präsidentschaft
von Biden mit Biden als Person auch nichts zu tun hätte.
Also das sind beides jetzt, nachdem wir sich hier über ihr Golfen reden,
eigentlich droht hier auf beiden Seiten so eine institutionelle Blackbox-Regentschaft.
Dann ist das so, das müssen wir jetzt einfach sagen, das sind so Maskottchen.
Also ist das eigentlich wie bei der EM, gibt es noch ein Maskottchen,
das spielt aber nicht selbst Fußball, das sieht man und sagt man, ah, das ist der Goleo.
Es gibt ganz viele Maskottchen bei der EM. Also hier hat man jetzt zwei Herren
gesehen, die ja nun wirklich kurz vorm Lallen und so weiter und ihren eigenen Sing-Sang mitbringen.
Hast du mal Fußballberichtertattung gesehen, wenn Schweinsteiger danach Spiele bespricht?
Nein.
Also das ist ja auch kaum zu ertragen. Der lallt ja auch vor sich hin,
als hätte er wirklich da noch, als wäre er so leicht angetrunken.
Also da gibt es sich gar keine Mühe beim Sprechen, sondern es ist einfach so ein...
Also es gibt ganz viele Maskottchen überall. Überall. Gerade in EM-Zeiten.
Das ist im Grunde nur Maskottchenarbeit, die hier stattfindet.
Ja, vielleicht ist das dann so eine neue Phase, in die wir eintreten.
Es gibt dann gute und schlechte Maskottchen und dann gibt es irgendwas dahinter,
was technokratisch entweder gut funktioniert oder dysfunktional ist.
Absolut.
Naja, man kann natürlich auch sagen, wenn wir jetzt über diese Präsidentschaft
sprechen und uns selbst so auf diese Kandidaten fokussieren,
dann machen wir den Fehler zu erkennen, dass ein Staat sehr viel mehr ist.
Und wir sehen das ja auch jetzt bei der Europawahl, über die wir heute kaum sprechen werden.
Lass mich noch eine Anmerkung zur Europawahl machen. U25-Wahl in Frankfurt. Grüne.
Ja, bevor wir dazu kommen, ja, ich weiß jetzt, was du gleich sagst.
Ich will das nur sagen, wir haben zugleich eine Kommissionspräsidentin Ursula
von der Leyen, die auch irgendwo als Maskottchen jetzt sich auserkoren wurde,
die setzt man jetzt dahin, aber das hat ja auch nichts mit Wählerwillen oder sonst was zu tun.
Nicht so viel mit Wählerwillen, aber ich glaube schon, dass das Kabinett von
Ursula von der Leyen noch sehr von ihr handverlesen ist und so. Anders als hier.
Okay.
Also das scheint mir noch ein bisschen...
Aber es scheint ja eine Kluft zu geben zwischen Leuten, die wir sehen und Leuten, die es machen.
Also wir haben ja einen Europawahlkampf gehabt, wo Leute auf Wahlplakaten groß
waren, wie zum Beispiel Olaf Scholz oder Sarah Wagenknecht, die ja nicht dahin gewählt werden können.
Und zugleich haben wir bei der CDU, ist bei der letzten Wahl so gehabt,
dass nirgends Ursula von der Leyen auftauchte, sie plötzlich aus dem Hut gezaubert
wurde, weil man die jetzt lieber hatte.
Ja, aber da denke ich mir auch, es ist auch mit Wählerentscheid gewesen zu sagen, Europa ist so gebaut,
wie Europa gebaut ist und wir machen in Deutschland auch keine Kanzlerwahl,
sondern wir wählen ein Parlament und das Parlament wählt danach aus seinen Kreisen
einen Kanzler, der allerdings kann als Minister jeden ernennen.
Also Gerhard Schröder hatte damals diesen in keiner Partei, in keinem Parlament
seienden Wirtschaftsminister, einfach aus der Energiewirtschaft rekrutiert und das ist dann halt so.
Das ist da an der Spitze direkt, aber dafür ist ja die Europäische Kommission
auch nicht wirklich eine Regierung. Sie hat halt diese Initiativrechte,
die genauso gut auch beim Parlament liegen könnten.
Das allerdings ist ja auch jetzt mittlerweile bei jeder Legislatur immer ein
Thema, dass das irgendwann kommt, dass das EU-Parlament einfach selber,
das EU-Parlament darf heute schon die Kommission auffordern,
eine Initiative vorzulegen. Also es rückt da immer weiter ran.
Wenn man sich das historisch anschaut, wird das, was wir hier gerade kritisieren,
immer weiter ausgemerzt.
Früher war es so, das Europäische Parlament hatte gar nichts zu sagen und die
Kommission wurde aus dem Hut gezaubert.
Dann kamen irgendwann die Vetorechte, jetzt müssen alle Einzelnen am Europaparlament antreten.
Also in der Hinsicht würde ich sagen, es ist ein System im Wandel und im Entstehen.
Du wolltest noch was zu Frankfurt sagen.
Ja, Frankfurt. Also Europawahl U25 in Frankfurt, war ja mal Rechtsruck und so weiter. Weiter.
Grüne 16%, Volt 14%, Linke 13%. Dann kommt das die CDU mit 10%,
dann die FDP mit 8%, dann die SPD mit 7%, AfD 6%.
Also urbane Zentren funktionieren, selbst wenn diese U25 hier wirklich mit zu
den Ärmsten in Deutschland gehören.
Also wir haben es hier nicht mit luxuriösen Verhältnissen wie auf dem ostdeutschen
Lande zu tun, wo sie alle AfD wählen,
wo einfach unendlicher Wohnraum für 3,80 Euro angemietet werden kann und so,
sondern wenn ökonomische Argumente für den Rechtsdruck, dann muss man das nochmal hart überprüfen.
Genauso wie im Ruhrgebiet, das ja ärmer ist als der Osten.
Strukturell und abstrahiert betrachtet und da wird auch nicht so viel AfD gewählt.
Aber man konnte schon sehen, dass wenn Armut und niedriger Bildungsabstoß miteinander
gekoppelt sind, dass bis auf ein paar urbane Zentren, aber da ist ja eh immer
alles ein bisschen anders,
dass dann die AfD sonst hoch im Kurs liegt.
Man sollte da die subkultanen Sachen nochmal...
Ich würde sagen, es gibt den Zusammenhang schon, es gibt den nur nicht überall.
Und es ist auch eine andere Armut, ob du jetzt im Osten auf dem Land bist,
eine Ausbildung gemacht hast, keinen richtigen Job findest oder nur einen Job
findest, der dir ewig Mindestlohn verspricht und nicht mehr.
Oder ob du in Frankfurt für 750 Euro ein WG-Zimmer anbieten musst,
aber Soziologie und BWL studierst und danach vielleicht Unternehmensberater
wirst oder was auch immer.
Das heißt, diese Armut ist schlimm, die man dort erlebt,
aber da scheint noch so etwas wie ein Ausweg vorhanden zu sein,
während die Ausweglosigkeit zum Beispiel im Osten oder auch in Teilen des Ruhrgebiets
oder auch im ländlichen Raum von Rheinland-Pfalz eine andere ist und da kann
man dann tatsächlich diese enge Verbindung sehen zwischen AfD und Wählern,
die aus dieser Perspektivlosigkeit dazu entscheiden.
Da kann man ja die Begriffsunterscheidung mal schärfen. In Frankfurt gibt es
finanzielle Armut, im Osten ist sie soziale Armut.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Oder kulturelle Armut. Aber hier ist es zum Glück nur temporäre und finanzielle
Armut in der Hoffnung, dass junge Leute dann auch in die Welt hinein starten.
Gut, du hast unseren Kanzler geguckt.
Na, so schnell machen wir das noch nicht. Wir wollen erst ganz kurz auf den Salon hinweisen.
Wir haben jetzt gerade schon kurz Europa angeschnitten. Dann schauen wir uns
doch mal an, wie Europa funktioniert oder nicht.
Nämlich wollen wir das Buch Brüssel sehen und sterben, wie ich im Europaparlament
meinen Glauben an fast alles verloren habe,
von Nico Semsrott lesen und das wird aber nicht das einzige Buch sein,
sondern Nico Semsrott hat noch einen Bruder, Arne Semsrott und der hat ein Buch geschrieben,
das heißt Machtübernahme, was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremisten regieren,
eine Anleitung zum Widerstand.
Und das ist eine ganz interessante Perspektive, die wir dann mit diesen beiden
Büchern einnehmen, nämlich wir blicken sowohl auf Europa und diesen technokratischen
Apparat und den Parlamentarismus, den Semsrott,
so klingt es ja schon im Titel, arg kritisieren wird.
Und zugleich haben wir dann mit seinem Bruder die Idee.
Dass man über Institutionen, über andere gesellschaftspolitische Mechanismen
dafür sorgen könnte, dass der Rechtsextremismus aufgehalten wird oder abgebremst wird.
Wir werden also diese beiden Perspektiven uns ansehen und das dann auch verbinden
mit den Ergebnissen der Europawahl und den anderen Rechtsrucken,
die noch so kommen und auch der Frage,
wie denn es eigentlich um die Demokratie direkt bestellt ist.
Wir haben das ja jetzt immer sehr theoretisch verhandelt, zum Beispiel mit Veit
Selk und wollen dann uns es einmal in der Praxis ansehen und auch mal schauen,
ob nicht diese Kritik an Brüssel mit all den Privilegien eine ist, die zu kurz greift.
Denn ich will jetzt nicht die Privilegien der Politiker verteidigen,
ich würde nur sagen, dass wir vielleicht auf eine andere Ebene müssen,
aber dafür müssen wir erst die beiden Bücher lesen.
Dieses Nico-Semsrott-Buch hat auch einen guten Einstieg, passend zu den beiden
Herren, die wir gerade geschaut haben.
Denn er sagt am Anfang, die Lügen haben die Politik kaputt gemacht,
deswegen will ich sie gar nicht anlügen. Sie haben hier ein Buch von mir in der Hand.
Das habe ich weder geschrieben noch nicht mal gelesen. Dafür bin ich viel zu
depressiv. Ich habe einfach Leuten alle meine Notizen gegeben und die haben
daraus ein Buch gemacht.
Das ist mal ein sehr guter Einstieg in so ein Politikerbuch.
Wir sind also gespannt. Man kann den Salon und auch den Live-Salon,
den wir letzten Monat in Frankfurt haben, alles nachhören, wenn man uns abonniert.
Das ist am allereinfachsten über Steady, das empfehlen wir.
Dort sind auch alle alten Salons vorhanden. Am besten geht man auf die Seite
neue20er.de. Da ist ein goldener Button, dann kommt man zum Salon.
Man kann ab 2,50 Euro, wir sind also sehr günstig im Gesamtprogramm von Steady,
kann man den Salon dann… Wir sind die günstigsten. Ach, tatsächlich.
Man kann ja nicht mehr, wenn man dort ein neues Projekt hat mit unter 3 Euro. Stimmt.
Kann man also dann den Salon abonnieren, kann dann auch die alten Salons hören
und wer mehr geben will, hat auch da die Möglichkeit, ein höheres Abo abzuschließen.
Man kann außerdem, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist und es bequem mag und man auch in
Kauf nehmen will, dass man 50 Cent mehr zahlt, über Apple den Salon abonnieren.
Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann das über Patreon tun. Und wir wollen noch darauf
hinweisen, dass wir am 24.
August in Frankfurt live zu erleben sind. Es gibt noch ein paar Karten,
es wird dann sehr groß sein, 800 Leute passen in diesen Saal rein.
Wir freuen uns dann, das ist dann der Sommersalon. Wer da Karten haben will,
wir werden in die Beschreibung den Link setzen zu dieser Veranstaltung.
Und jetzt lass mich noch eine halbe Minute Eigenwerbung machen,
denn ich habe ein Buch geschrieben für dich und die Deinen, denn du hast ja drei Kinder.
Ich werde es Ihnen vorlesen.
Du brauchst mindestens drei Bücher dann. Ja, ich habe mit Ole zusammen ein Kinderbuch geschrieben.
Es heißt Die kleinen Holzdiebe und das Rätsel des Juggernaut.
Ja, wer ist denn ein Juggernaut? Oder bleibt das ein Rätsel?
Nein, aber so ein Juggernaut ist ja so ein ...
Trophäenzeremonien wagen, der sich in Bewegung setzt und immer weiter rollt und immer weiter rollt.
Und diese Metapher Juggernaut ist sehr verbreitet im britischen Diskurs.
Aber wir beziehen uns, um das schon mal hier rauszulassen, natürlich auf Marx.
Denn wir haben uns gedacht, wenn Carsten Maschmeyer und viele andere solche
Leute Kinderbücher schreiben, in denen sie schon den Kleinsten einreden, dass man vor...
Aber hat der nicht nur so ein kleines Bilderbuch gemacht?
Nein, nein, nein, der hat ein richtiges Buch mit einer Erzählung,
mit einem Kinderbuchautor zusammen.
Und da geht es darum, früh Investor zu werden, früh die Startup-Mentalität zu entwickeln.
Es gibt ganz viele Bücher, die sind irrsinnig beliebt bei Eltern.
Wie kann ich mein Kind zu einem reichen Kind machen?
Die lesen wir unseren Kindern alle vor und hören dabei Mozart.
Es ist grauenhaft, was da gemacht wird.
Wie mache ich aus meinem siebenjährigen Kind schon einen Bitcoin-Bro?
Es ist verrückt und wir dachten, wir müssen etwas dagegen setzen und haben eine
Abenteuergeschichte geschrieben, die 270 Seiten lang ist mit wunderbaren Illustrationen
von Nick Martin Sternske.
Ja, die wurden handgezeichnet, ne? Die sind nicht generiert oder so.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht hier, ChatGBT.
Muss man noch dazusagen.
Also das ist noch richtig geschrieben und noch richtig gezeichnet.
Sehr gut.
So wie du uns ja die ganze Zeit einredest, wird es bald nicht mehr sein.
Aber wir haben es nochmal so richtig gemacht und ja, das jetzt,
was ich dazu sagen will, wer das Buch vorbestellt, würde uns damit eine große
Freude tun, denn es ist ja gar nicht so leicht, im Buchhandel vertreten zu sein.
Das heißt, man kann es online vorbestellen.
Noch schöner wäre es, wenn es in den lokalen Buchhandlungen bestellt wird,
dann werden die auch darauf aufmerksam.
Also, Die kleinen Holztiebe und das Rätsel des Joganaut erscheint bei Insel bzw.
Surkamp und kommt am 12. August.
Sehr gut.
Wir müssen jetzt einmal Revue passieren lassen, was wir so im Podcast von uns geben.
Ein Hörer hat uns darauf hingewiesen, dass wir vor einem Jahr….
Haben wir Quatsch erzählt? Nein, nein.
Ich weiß noch nicht.
Worum es geht.
Naja, vielleicht du. Also wir werden jetzt mal gucken. Es geht darum,
dass wir vor einem Jahr über die Klimakleber diskutiert haben,
diese ganzen Aktionen auch im Museum und darüber, wie ist das dann jetzt mit
den Straßen, die blockiert werden.
Und wir hören uns jetzt mal den Clip von damals an.
Also wir spulen jetzt quasi ein Jahr im Podcast zurück und hören mal,
was wir damals so von uns gegeben haben.
Also ihr hört jetzt uns, aber aus der Konserve für...
Eine Minute siebenundvierzig.
Und es ist halt immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig, wohin führt es denn eigentlich?
Wir haben jetzt die Situation gehabt, dass die neue Justizsenatorin von Berlin,
das hast du bestimmt auch gesehen, in den Tagesthemen zu Gast war.
Genau, und sie hat ja da zum Beispiel über die Klimakleber gesprochen und meinte
dann, hat dann so vorgerechnet,
naja, erste Statistiken zeigen, dass in Berlin Krankenwagen mit lebensgefährlich
verletzten Menschen 26 Minuten später am Klinikum ankommen, also da Versorgung gefährdet ist.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich aber auch, wenn Berlin Marathon ist.
Und das ist nämlich der Punkt.
Jetzt hat sie von Seiten der Politik die Argumentation aufgemacht,
dass Stau, Verkehrsbehinderung grundsätzlich erstmal ein Problem ist.
Am Beispiel Blockade durch Klimakleber.
Aber was ist denn mit, wenn man das als Chiffre nimmt, mit den anderen Blockaden?
So, und jetzt kann man sagen, ja gut, die Selbstbeschreibung der Klimakleber war echt scheiße.
Jetzt kann man sagen, meine Fremdbeschreibung ist auch ein bisschen dämlich,
indem ich die irgendwie vergleiche mit zwei eigenen Kindern im Supermarkt.
Aber es führte dazu, dass wir jetzt eine regierende Justizministerin haben,
die plötzlich einen Diskurs aufmacht
zum Thema, die Gründe einer Verkehrsverzögerung sind nicht mehr egal.
Und du hast ja eben beschrieben, wie die Verkehrsverzögerungen so aussehen.
Welche Diskussionen haben wir denn in einem Jahr, wenn wir das mal ein bisschen
weiterführen, wenn daran jetzt angeschlossen wird.
So und da würde ich sagen, das kann durchaus mal eine Verkehrswende einleiten,
wenn nicht mehr jeder einfach alles auf der Straße machen darf,
zum Beispiel mit einem dicken SUV rumfahren, wenn der Anlass dafür war zu sagen,
nee auf der Straße darf man nicht alles, man darf sich zum Beispiel nicht da
festkleben, würde ich sagen, stimmt,
auf einer Straße darf man nicht alles, zum Beispiel, man darf sich da nicht
festkleben, man sollte man zum Beispiel noch alles nicht dürfen und dann ist
das für mich ein Einstieg auch in der SUV-Diskussion zum Beispiel.
Immer noch in der Argumentation schlüssig.
Ich bin total immer noch auf meiner Seite.
Die Sache ist nur, wir sind jetzt ein Jahr später und genau nichts ist geschehen.
Und das habe ich in gewisser Weise schon prophezeit. Das ist aber nicht so schwer.
Man kann eigentlich in Deutschland immer sagen, wird aber nichts ändern.
Man hat was gegen SUVs gesagt, ist aber nichts passiert.
Man hat immer recht, wir hören mal gerade noch, wie das weiterging,
die Diskussion zwischen uns, denn es ist glaube ich ganz gut,
jetzt nochmal zu sagen, Klimakreber waren das ganz große Thema. Weiß das noch einer?
Und ich saß auf dieser Bank, bei diesem Handbeispiel in der Sonne.
Und plötzlich höre ich diesen Scheiß da die ganze Zeit. Selbst die reden darüber.
Und da denke ich mir, ein guter Diskurs.
Aber ist das ein guter Diskurs? Denn sie reden ja dann über diese Aktionen und
sie reden ja nicht konstruktiv darüber, wie könnte man generell den Verkehr
besser, geschmeidiger organisieren.
Sondern es ist ja ein Aufregen über einzelne Akteure.
Und man sieht ja auch bei YouTube, was einem angezeigt wird.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das verändern wird.
Ich glaube, das sind solche Debatten, wie die um die Papierstrohhalme und so ein Kram.
Also man hat solche Scheindebatten und tatsächlich müsste man doch dahin kommen,
dass die Debatte eher ist, du hast es ja eben vorgemacht, die Wasserversorgung
stimmt ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Und ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass von diesen Aktionen und von der Debatte
um diese Aktionen, und das ist ja nicht alleine den Klimaklebern anzukreiden,
sondern generell, dass von diesen Debatten aus irgendetwas hinführt zu den fundamentaleren Fragen.
Also ich werbe nochmal für die eigene Sensorik. Es sind Zukunftsbilder.
Hier sind auch bestimmt KI-Leute und alles. Sie sollen mal so eine Erinnerung machen.
Wir haben jetzt Ende Mai 2023, Ende Mai 2024.
Vielleicht kann da irgendjemand mal eine Erinnerung machen, ob sich die Debatte
so verändert hat, wie Stefan uns das jetzt hier skizziert hat.
Wir haben es jetzt in Zahlen. Die Klimakleber sind mit ihren Aktionen nach einigen
Interviews und Fernsehauftritten nicht mehr weitergekommen, haben sich dann
dazu entschieden zu kandidieren, also die letzte Generation,
um es jetzt mal korrekt zu sagen, für das Europaparlament 0,3 Prozent.
Ich habe mir dann die Mühe gemacht und habe grüne Städte ausgesucht.
Man kann das ja sehr genau alles nachvollziehen. Also Städte,
in denen ganz viele Leute grün wählen, die sehr universitär sind,
die ein hohes ökologisches Bewusstsein haben.
Vogue Towns.
Könnte man, wenn man so will, sagen. Da haben die Grünen verloren.
Zum Teil deutlich verloren, mehr als 10 Prozent verloren. Was ist passiert?
Die Leute sind entweder nicht wählen gegangen oder sie haben Volt gewählt oder
sie haben vielleicht irgendeine andere Partei, die dem ökologischen nicht ganz abholt ist, gewählt.
Sie haben nicht die letzte Generation gewählt. Das heißt, wir haben vor einem
Jahr einen unglaublichen Tumult gehabt wegen dieser Aktionen.
Ich habe damals gesagt, diese Aktionen werden überhaupt nichts bringen.
Das wird so eine wunderbare Feuilleton-Debatte sein.
Alle können da mal im Sommerloch sich austoben dann und es führt zu nichts.
Und ich glaube, wir sehen hier schon bestätigt, was Anton Jäger,
auch wenn wir dieses Buch jetzt nicht über alle Maßen gefeiert haben,
diagnostiziert hat, nämlich das ist eine Hyperpolitik,
die so ganz kurz einmal funktioniert und dann wäre wahrscheinlich im Juni letzten
Jahres das Wahlergebnis für die letzte Generation bei 4,5 Prozent gewesen und
dann ist es aber sofort wieder weg.
Wir können das ja auch bei Fridays for Future sehen, dass große Aktionen dort
nicht mehr passieren und dass Luisa Neubauer eigentlich krampfhaft versucht.
Immer wieder neue Themen nochmal
zu besetzen, um weiterhin aktivistisch stattzufinden in den Medien.
Aber wir sehen daran schon, dass also keine Strukturen aufgebaut wurden,
die in irgendeiner Weise nachhaltig sind und es ist auch nicht gelungen von
diesen Provokationen etwas abzuleiten,
das dahin führt, dass man zum Beispiel mal darüber nachdenkt,
wie müssten denn eigentlich Städte, Straßen und so weiter organisiert sein.
Ja, aber rückblickend würde ich sagen, diese Proteste der Klimakleber haben
ja überhaupt nur medial funktioniert, weil die Gegenseite sie nutzen konnte.
Ja, dann hat es ja eher noch der Gegenseite genutzt. Aber das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Ja.
Aber diese, es gab dann, also irgendwo sind ja diese grünen Stimmen dann auch
hingegangen in die Nichtwählerschaft oder in diese Protestwählerei.
Mit denen, die sich drum gerangeln, wer denn jetzt die Beste gegen Gendern,
gegen Vogue, gegen was auch immer.
Und das hat dann CDU, CSU, AfD und so weiter unter sich aufgeteilt.
Und so sah ja auch das Wahlergebnis aus.
Aber das war das ja, weil du sagtest ja, die Leute haben damals alle drüber
gesprochen in dem Clip, den wir jetzt eben gespielt haben.
Achso, ja, die saßen auf dieser Bank und haben über die Heizungen,
über die Klimakleber, aber immer mit diesem Unterton solche Idioten.
Richtig. Und das ist nicht gelungen, dass man genau diese Leute für die Klimasache gewinnt.
Wenn man natürlich sagt, die sind alle verloren oder die sich so empfinden,
dann wählen die selbstverständlich CDU oder noch wesentlich weiter rechts.
Ich bin aber auch weiterhin dafür, dass wenn, das hatten wir jetzt auch bei
der EM zum Beispiel, es ist Europameisterschaft und hier finden Spiele in Frankfurt statt.
Was bedeutet, der Nahverkehr auf der Schiene kann nicht fahren,
nicht weil er auf der Straße fährt.
Er hat ein eigenes Schienenbett, sondern weil er ab und zu die Straße überqueren muss.
Und auf diesen drei Metern stehen dann die Autos. Die stehen eh 15 Kilometer
im Stau und dann auch noch genau auf den Schienen, sodass die Bahn dann auch nicht durchkommt.
Und da wäre ich dafür weiterhin, dass man dieses Tor nutzt, zu sagen,
also wenn es eine juristische Diskussion zum Thema,
da ist ein Krankenwagen zu spät, weil irgendjemand sich an der Straße festgeklebt
hat, dann will ich auch eine juristische Diskussion zum Thema,
20 Leute sitzen in der Straßenbahn und kommen einfach nicht an,
weil sich einer nicht an die Regeln gehalten hat im Straßenverkehr und dafür
einen Stau verursacht hat.
Also dass ein Verursacher eines Staus auf jeden Fall erstmal sich rechtfertigen
muss dafür, kann ja am Ende freigesprochen werden, wie auch immer.
Aber wer auf einer Schiene hält und weiß, ich kann jetzt nicht vor und zurück,
sondern ich ziehe den ganzen Straßenbahnverkehr in meine Mitleidenschaft,
der ist dafür verantwortlich zu machen, juristisch.
Ich bin ganz auf deiner Seite, nur die Sache ist ja, wie kommt man jetzt über
solche Einzelfälle hinaus zu einer anderen Klimapolitik?
Oder müssen wir zumindest mal eines tun, dass wir also nicht mehr auf solche
Aktivismus-Events hereinfallen?
Also dass man so viel Gehirnschmalz aufbringt, um jetzt über die Klimakleber
zu diskutieren, die dann ein Jahr später gänzlich marginalisiert sind.
Man kann es im Übrigen auch an der Buchbranche so gut sehen.
Man weiß genau, was los war. Klimakreber, großes Thema.
Also sollen Aktivisten aus diesem Umfeld oder Leute, die ihnen nahestehen,
mal Bücher über Protest und Aktivismus schreiben.
Dann werden diese Bücher schnell verfasst, aber natürlich nicht schnell genug.
Die erscheinen dann im Februar, März und niemand kauft diese Bücher.
Man kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen über Amazon oder wenn man Leute kennt,
die einen Media-Control-Zugang haben, dann weiß man einfach, das ist nicht.
Und manche Bücher, die angekündigt wurden, ich habe wirklich mal darauf geachtet,
wurden sogar schon jetzt verschoben ins nächste Jahr oder auf den Sankt-Nimmerleins-Tag
oder sind völlig wieder aus dem Programm genommen.
Also das ist schon bemerkenswert und deswegen will ich jetzt noch eine Kopplung
machen an die medialen Aufreger.
Also wir versuchen ja nicht so sehr in diese Schnappatmung reinzukommen,
dass wir auf alles so aufspringen. Klar, ein Duell müssen wir jetzt mal hier verhandeln.
Wir haben gar nicht so viel über Sylt gesagt, aber dieses Sylt-Video vor sechs
Wochen hat unglaublich viel Tinte freigesetzt.
Viele Leitartikel, Feuilletons wurden dazu geschrieben.
Was sagt das alles aus? Wir haben den Einblick von Dagmar Rosenfeld gehört,
als sie sich fragte, ob die Reichen jetzt auch rassistisch sind.
Ja, und zugleich würde ich jetzt aber mal Folgendes machen wollen.
Dieses Video war abscheulich und dieses Video sagt auch etwas aus über die deutsche Gesellschaft.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir ein Problem bekommen,
wo wir aufgrund dieses Videos, aufgrund von 20, 30 Leuten, wie viele es auch
sind, die ein rassistisches Lied grölen, dass man daraufhin auf Grundlage dieses
Videos eine große Gesellschaftsanalyse machen kann.
Ist das sinnvoll?
Also da gibt es ja eine gute Abhandlung, sehr soziologisch, von Fran O.
Sretschke, die Diagnosegesellschaft, wo genau dieses punktuelle...
Das gibt den Zeitgeist wieder, daran sieht man es, indem da einfach die Absage erteilt wird.
Denn es ist mir was aufgefallen, ich will das auch unbedingt ansprechen,
damit es nicht so ist, als würde man es verschweigen wollen.
Das war eine Gruppe von Leuten dort, die da saß und ein rassistisches Lied gesungen
hat und dann wurde das aufgenommen und dadurch hat das dann auch so einen Mimifizierungskarakter
und dann geht das überall viral.
Wovon wir keine Aufnahme haben, wovon wir aber trotzdem sehr gut unterrichtet
sind, ist der Fall, der jetzt gerade in Bad Oeynhausen stattgefunden hat,
in der Nähe von Bielefeld.
Was war denn da statt?
Naja, das ist schon interessant, dass du sofort auch nachfragen musst,
aber was ist das? Sylt ist ein Begriff, muss ich nur sagen, Sylt, weiß jeder Bescheid.
Also Bad Oeynhausen ist ja für uns auch ein Begriff, weil Niklas Luhmann da gelebt hat.
Ja, aber Bad Oeynhausen ist uns jetzt nochmal in anderer Weise ein Begriff,
deshalb, weil dort eine Abifeier stattfand.
Ein Abiturient, Philippos hieß er,
mit einem Freund zusammen durch diesen Stadtpark nachts nach Hause geht.
Dort ist eine Gruppe von jungen Männern, zehn, zwölf Leute, genaue Zahlen weiß
man noch nicht. Es gibt irgendeinen Wortwechsel, eine Streiterei und dieser
Philippos wird dann totgeprügelt.
Und dieser Philippos ist, der Name sagt es, auch jemand, der eine Migrationsgeschichte
hat, dadurch, dass sein Vater, glaube ich, Grieche ist.
Und zu der Sache gehört aber, dass der Hauptverdächtige, der jetzt von der Polizei
geschnappt wurde und die Medien haben ja darüber berichtet, ein Syrer ist.
Und wir haben vor einer Weile einen Mord an einem Polizisten gehabt mit dem Messer.
Wir haben ein paar solcher Fälle gehabt, wo eine Art von barbarischer Brutalisierung
stattfindet, die einen so erschaudern lässt,
genau deshalb, weil wir eigentlich gewöhnt sind, Gewalt im Ganzen zu ächten
und diese Art der Attacken, wo Leute totgeprügelt mit Messern erstochen werden,
in dieser Weise völlig geächtet und verbannt haben.
Und es ist aber auch da in der Gesellschaft. Es findet statt.
Und es sind dann...
Doch interessante Bewegungen zu beobachten, dass man bei Sylt sofort von linksradikal
bis linksliberal Mitte alle Ableitungen bereit ist zu machen.
Wenn aber sowas wie in Bad Oeynhausen stattfindet, wo ich sagen kann,
ja, das war ja etwa eine gleich große Gruppe, die haben aber nicht nur gesungen,
die haben auch jemanden noch totgeschlagen.
Dass daraus nicht eine Ableitung stattfindet. Ich will nicht dazu einladen,
zu den rechten Ableitungen.
Denn die Rechten greifen natürlich diesen Fall aus und sagen,
und deshalb brauchen wir mehr
Abschiebungen, Deshalb brauchen wir mehr dies, mehr das und so weiter.
Ich kann gar keine sinnvolle Ableitung da machen, weil ich erstmal fassungslos
gegenüber dieser Tat bin und nicht genau sagen kann, woran es liegt.
Aber dass es offenbar ein Problem gibt.
Das sich in solcher barbarischer Art Gewalt äußert, das kann nicht einfach von einem großen Teil,
also einem eher linksliberalen bis linksradikalen Teil einfach so,
ja, hat wohl stattgefunden, es ist einfach so wie so ein, gab wohl irgendwo
mal einen Banküberfall oder so.
Sondern es hat auch eine politische Komponente und es geht nicht,
dass man bei Sylt glaubt, die ganze deutsche Gesellschaft erklären zu können
und dass man bei einem solchen Fall einfach sagt, reden wir einfach gar nicht drüber.
Das ist ein immenses Problem, zumal es ja nicht hier ist, das sind irgendwie
die Migranten gegen die Deutschen, die hier schon immer wohnen.
Nein, hier haben wir auch jemanden, wo auch eine latente Migrationsgeschichte
da ist, aber wir haben auch offenbar mit dem Hauptverdächtigen jemand,
der hier war, der schon auffällig geworden ist der Polizei gegenüber und der
jetzt verdächtig wird, dieses barbarische Verbrechen begangen zu haben.
Und das ist einfach ein sehr großes gesellschaftliches Problem und das sollte man.
Nicht den Rechten überlassen, damit nicht nur diese Ableitungen erfolgen und
deshalb brauchen wir mehr Frontex oder so.
Das kann nicht die Lösung sein, es hilft auch niemandem da. Aber man kann auch
nicht die Augen davor verschließen.
Und die Wahrheit ist, dass auch viele Leute genau vor solchen Dingen Angst haben,
dass sowas passiert, weil es ein Ausmaß von Gewalt ist, was wir wirklich nicht mehr kennen.
Ich will noch einen letzten Satz dazu sagen, wenn wir jetzt irgendwelche Festivals
oder so besuchen, irgendwelche Veranstaltungen, da sind überall so Safety Teams.
Das heißt, es gibt richtige Ordner, die angestellt sind und dann gibt es nochmal
von den Veranstaltern selbst Leute, die sagen, hey, wenn da irgendwas ist,
wenn da sich jemand, jemanden bedrängt oder so, ihr könnt euch jederzeit hier
an die Leute mit den grünen Westen oder so wenden, ja.
Also man hat einen Sensibilisierungsgrad erreicht und das ist ein großer Fortschritt,
dass man also jetzt auch nochmal ein Team hat, das so diese kleinen,
nicht so juristisch gleich zu fassenden Dinge auch nochmal da einen Blick drauf
hat und da versucht, als Ansprechpartner zur Verfügung steht,
um Leute auch vor sowas zu schützen, was man nicht jetzt gerade mal so nur im
Gesetzbuch nachlesen kann.
Wir haben also dann einen hohen Grad von Sensibilisierung erreicht.
Und zugleich haben wir auch diese barbarischen Akte in dieser Weise.
Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja, aber es gibt ja auch ganz viele rechtsradikale
brutale Akte. Ja, genau, über die reden wir ja auch. Und wir müssen aber auch
über diese anderen Akte reden.
Ja. Also bei diesen medialen Diskursen, die ich jetzt in dem Falle so gar nicht
verfolgt habe, also von Bad Oeynhausen habe ich noch gar nichts gehört.
Kann natürlich sein, dass das ein mega Thema war und ich, aber ich hatte auch
Corona die Woche, mein erstes Corona.
Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen entschuldigt. Ähm.
Häufiger und wir kennen das im Podcast wie Micky Beisenherz oder so oder Sascha Lobo auch, viele News.
Da hat man dann so ein Tenor, okay, wir müssen heute mal über eine Austreten.
Und dann kommen plötzlich so Themen auf, dass man so Argumentationsstränge, die ungefähr so lauten.
Sehr viele Leute demonstrieren jetzt gegen den Einsatz Israels in Gaza.
Wo waren diese Leute, als in Somalia ein Völkermord stattfand?
Wo schauen die hin, wenn in Ruanda Elfenbeinküste, ist mir jetzt dunkel in Erinnerung,
dass da auch irgendwas war, Auf jeden Fall Jemen oder so.
Und daran sieht man ja, die Leute, die da und da und da nicht diskutiert haben,
aber jetzt plötzlich diskutieren, sind ja alles Antisemiten,
weil sonst hätten die ja auch, denen geht es ja gezielt um Israel und so.
Und wenn ich das höre, denke ich mir, nein, das ist der falsche Weg.
Wir wollen nicht noch mehr über irgendwelche Sachen diskutieren auf der Straße.
Also wenn wir jetzt auch noch Somalia und Ruanda und Jemen auf der Straße ausfechten,
dann ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis in Podcastgesprächen die Frage ist,
ja und wo ist jetzt die Aufregung zu so und so und so und so und so.
Es gibt halt manchmal Sachen, an denen, ich will jetzt nicht kristallisiert
sagen, weil das ist ja mein neu besetzter Grundbegriff, aber an denen,
die die erregen, haben so besondere subkultane irgendwas und so weiter.
Und dann werden die besonders diskutiert. Und da würde ich sagen,
wenn man sich prüft und denkt, das ist irgendwie komisch, ich verstehe nicht
genau, warum sie diskutieren, lass sie diskutieren.
Es ist jetzt keine Gegenrede erforderlich.
Deutschland ist gigantisch groß.
Jede Schule hat inzwischen irgendeine Jugendhilfe oder so. Wenn man da hingeht,
hat man genauso viele Probleme.
Also man könnte sich jetzt überall einmischen und einfach und so weiter.
Das haben wir in Amerika auch.
Da werden ja die Lehrer und so weiter von irgendwelchen Schoolboards bestellt
und über die Schoolboards haben dann die Eltern Einflüsse.
Also gibt es da so ein paar Eltern, die manche Themen einfach krass politisieren,
dann skandalisieren und am Ende funktioniert gar nichts mehr.
Beim Thema Gaza sitzen plötzlich die Vorsitzenden dieser Ausschüsse,
also dieser Leitungsausschüsse der verschiedenen Unis vorm Kongress, kriegen dort Fragen,
die sie nicht so beantworten, wie die popularisierte Öffentlichkeit das beantwortet
haben möchte und werden alle gefeuert.
Einfach nur weil so Stimmung im Raum ist.
Also wenn irgendwo Diskussionen stattfinden und man muss sich nicht beteiligen,
einfach nicht beteiligen. Einfach Sachen ignorieren.
Also falls das jetzt zu schwach klingt, was ich sage.
Politisch muss man sich davon, also ich meine jetzt auch nicht,
dass ich jetzt von jedem Mal einen Poster zu erwarte. Ich beteilige mich grundsätzlich
an solchen Dingen nicht.
Ich habe keine schwarze Kacke gepostet, ich habe auch keinen,
weiß ich nicht was, Seasfire Now
gepostet und ich poste auch nichts zu Bad Oeynhausen oder zu sonst was.
Das mache ich grundsätzlich nicht. Nur was auffällig ist, dass man bereit ist,
bei manchen Dingen große politische Ableitungen zu machen und bei den anderen
überlässt man die politischen Ableitungen nur den Rechten.
Und was die sagen, wissen wir alle, was dann da kommt und wem die die Schuld
in die Schuhe schieben, nämlich allen Migranten dann oder allen Leuten,
die sie als Migranten betrachten wollen.
Wollen, wenn ich aber selbst gar nichts dazu zu sagen weiß und dann am Ende
noch sich Leute sogar dazu versteigen und sagen, naja,
das Problem gibt es in dem Sinne gar nicht, das ist von Rechten gemacht,
dann würde ich sagen, das kann auch nicht die Lösung sein, denn,
solche Geschichten sind welche, die groß rezipiert werden und wenn das nicht,
aufgegriffen wird, man kann da nicht ignorieren, das ist ja was anderes,
also hier haben wir ja beim Nord-Ost-Konflikt eine sehr, sehr starke deutsche
Verwicklung in die Sache aus sowohl historischen wie aktuell politischen Dingen.
Das meinte ich ja gar nicht. Mir geht es nur darum.
Dass Appelle im Raum stehen zu mehr Protest, mehr Aufregung.
Warum regt sich jemand dazu nicht aus, wo sind die Bekenntnisse?
Ich will es nochmal anders formulieren.
Ich würde sagen, eher wenn man das vielleicht mit Sylt ein bisschen runter drosseln
können, dass man nicht völlig hyperventiliert über eine Woche hinweg.
Da ist aber jetzt die Frage, wem sagst du das? Denn bei Sylt,
hat sich Armin Laschet als ehemaliger Kanzlerkandidat geäußert und gesagt,
ich finde es gut, dass die alle ihren Job verloren haben.
Die amtierende Bundestagspräsidentin hatte gesagt, hier sollte das Strafmaß
ausgeschöpft werden, fünf Jahre Haft für solche Sachen.
Also an dem Punkt, klar können wir jetzt so einen Appell machen,
Leute irgendwie und so weiter, twitter doch mal weniger.
Aber hier haben sich ja wirklich die Staatsspitzen, die politischen Verantwortlichen
aufstacheln lassen zu irgendwelchen Kommentaren, die ihrerseits dann wieder
Leute in die Diskussion brachten. Das war natürlich völlig daneben.
So wie ich das mitbekommen habe, wir haben dieses SILD-Video gesehen,
der erste Blick, so wie wir auch bei Trump und Biden eben betont haben,
dieser rein visuelle Blick ist ja super entscheidend. Wir haben dort reiche Leute gesehen.
Dann stellen wir irgendwie fest, nee, das sind irgendwelche Halbtagsangestellten
bei Influencern und so weiter.
Wenn es dann heißt, oh Freude, die haben ihren Job verloren,
tun die mir auch ehrlich gesagt leid, wir wissen alle wie das ist da läuft halt
so ein Lied und man singt das Bild und grinst dann noch so in die Kamera,
da denkt sich nichts dabei keine Ahnung.
Ne, ne, also das jetzt fängst du ja an das zu verharmlosen das war ja nicht
mein Ansinn also dass die,
dieses Lied nicht einfach nur mal so mitsingen und die machen da ein Hitlerbärtchen
und so weiter, das kann das ist ja nicht so, ich hab,
irgendwo ein Lied mitgesungen, also die Ich würde schon sagen,
dass diese Gruppe und auch sicherlich symptomatisch für eine gewisse Klientel
steht, dass man sagt, ja, die sind…,
durchaus für rassistisches Gedankengut offen, was nicht bedeutet,
dass die jetzt alle AfD-Wähler sind oder so, nee, es ist eher so ein,
ja, aber irgendwie sind es doch wohl Ausländer, die anderen,
die nicht so aussehen wie du.
Da allerdings.
Sprengt, die in einer Rohheit Hoheit daherkommt und man dazu aber dann von dem
ganzen Lager, das sich jetzt nur mit Sylt beschäftigt hat, überhaupt nichts hört,
dann finde ich das verdächtig und es ist auch leicht zu erklären,
man kann natürlich seine Klischees, die man im Kopf hat, von Rich Kids bestätigen,
wenn da irgendwelche Leute mit Kaschmir-Pulli und Polohemd sitzen und ein rassistisches
Lied klingen und sagen, ah ja, man hat es ja immer gedacht.
Und während man hier Ja, was sagt man denn da eigentlich?
Man will ja nicht falsche Ableitungen machen, aber indem man jetzt einfach sagt,
wir reden gar nicht drüber, dann ist es für mich etwas,
was ich, weil ich ja glaube, dass diese Leute hinter vorgehaltener Hand am Ende
doch darüber reden, ist es doch etwas, was offenbar einen blinden Fleck im Diskurs veranschaulicht.
Okay, lass uns das abschließen, weil wir haben noch sehr viele Themen heute,
die wir behandeln müssen und die auch, sage ich ganz bewusst,
viel wichtiger sind, weil sie eben auf so einer strukturellen Ebene hier wirklich
Sachen zertrümmern, während manche Sachen halt so auf Gesprächsebene stattfinden.
Aber zwei Sachen. Mich haben ja zuletzt zwei Sachen wirklich verändert im Denken,
was ich nachhaltig merke.
Das eine ist das Kristallisieren, also dieser Wunsch, wenn politische Diskussionen
laufen, es von der emotionalen Ebene auf die erste pragmatische heruntertransferieren.
Ich habe das ja im Salon versucht, so ein bisschen spielerisch vorzustellen.
Wir werden das sehr übend machen bei vielen Sachen.
Aber wenn jemand sagt, wir sollen hier Remigration machen und so weiter,
dann so wie Malfalani da sitzen und sagen, was bedeutet das denn?
Wir schieben 25 Millionen Menschen ab. Wie sieht es dann aus im Krankenhaus?
Wie sieht es dann aus in der Schule? Ganz konkret wissen, nicht irgendwelche Sachen fühlen.
Das zweite ist dieser immer wiederkehrende Gesprächsanlass, weil der Rassismus im Spiel ist.
Nach der Lektüre von Gilda Sahebis Buch habe ich mein Denken da wirklich grundlegend
geändert, denn ich finde fast alles, was man im politischen Diskurs sieht,
ist rassistisch. Alles.
Die Frage ist nur, wenn man das anmerkt, meint man das dann vorwurfsvoll oder
wie Sahebi, dass man sagt, das steckt einfach in der Natur des Menschen drin
und das ist immer zu bändigen.
Wir unterscheiden uns von anderen. Wir können auch nicht 8 Milliarden Menschen
übersehen, also überspannen in unserer Argumentation.
Dieser Universalismus aufs Ultimative getrimmt ist ein Desiderat,
ein Wunsch. Den wollen wir immer transportieren.
Deswegen auch diese ganze Kant'sche Philosophie, die ist eigentlich schon 7000
Jahre alt. Warum ist sie immer noch aktuell?
Warum sitzt Precht jetzt in einem Interview und sagt, ich halte mich da an Kant?
Weil wir es immer wieder aktualisieren müssen.
Also, wenn irgendwer auch nur sagt, Migration begrenzen, ist das Rassismus.
Und zwar nicht vorwurfsvoll gemeint, sondern nur als Hinweis,
das bringt keine Lösung.
Wir müssen das hier kristallisieren. Die Probleme sind woanders.
Wenn also, wie ich jetzt höre, in Bad Oeynhausen ein Syrer jemand anderen verprügelt
hat, dann gibt es da ganz viele Sachen, die wir beachten müssen.
Sehr viele Opfer politischer Gewalt sind AfD-Abgeordnete.
Sehr viele Opfer ausländischer Gewalt sind Ausländer.
In dem Falle ist der Täter ein Ausländer. Wenn wir uns diesen Fall dann wirklich
anschauen, es gibt eine juristische Aufarbeitung, schon von Staats wegen bei solchen Sachen.
Wenn wir das jetzt abwarten, in einem Jahr auf diesen Fall gucken,
wie prägend für die Erklärung, was da vorgefallen ist, wird es sein,
dass der junge Mann aus Syrien kommt?
Wie prägend werden andere Merkmale sein?
Diese Abwägung kann man dann alle machen und selbst wenn es krass prägend ist,
dass er aus Syrien kommt, ziehen wir dann die Diagnosegesellschaft,
Fran Uschretski, den Schluss, ja das ist ja klar, alle Syrer sind doch Mörder. Eben nicht.
Aber das wird ja gerade von den Rechten gemacht.
Ja, genau. Und deswegen Und deswegen.
Sage ich ja, deswegen darf man ja nicht jetzt von der anderen Seite einfach
sagen, wir tun so als gäbe es das Thema nicht.
Genau, ich habe leider weder den Vorfall noch viel oder wenig Aufregung aus der solchen Seite.
Und de facto ist es ja so, dass fast alle Syrer, die hier leben, sowas nicht machen.
So, und das heißt ja erstmal was.
Und da muss ich aber zugleich sagen, es gibt aber offenbar irgendwelche Missstände,
die vorhanden sind, denn sonst könnte es ja nicht sein, dass eine solche Tat geschieht.
Irgendwas wird schon vorgefallen sein, genau. Die Devianz des menschlichen Verhaltens
gehört zum menschlichen Verhalten, gerade in größeren Zusammenhängen und Bad Oeynhausen.
Von uns in Frankfurt aus müssten wir durch ganz Hessen fahren und dann durch
ganz Nordrhein-Westfalen, um da anzukommen. Das liegt ganz im Norden.
Wir fahren also, wenn wir nur rechts und links jeweils 100 Kilometer betrachten,
fahren wir an 30 Millionen Menschen vorbei, bevor wir zu diesem einen devianten
Fall kommen, über den wir dann reden.
Und das sagt auch was. Also die Friedfertigkeit der 30, 40 Millionen Menschen,
die wir da einfach haben links liegen lassen, kann man auch reinholen in so eine Diskussion.
Aber das muss man machen. Also darüber muss man ja reden. Also man muss nicht
sagen, Bad Oeynhausen ist überall, das wäre das, was die Rechten jetzt gerne machen.
Die sagen, draußen ist Bürgerkrieg, wir müssen euch davor beschützen.
Aber man muss ja genau diesen Zusammenhang dann darstellen und muss es aber
auch in aller Sensibilität tun, denn das hilft dem Opfer und hilft den Angehörigen
nicht, wenn man sagt, aber die anderen 40 Millionen waren friedlich.
Sondern man muss auch ein konkretes Problem versuchen auszumachen.
Und ich bin in den Fällen nicht einig, weil ich kenne ja die Umstände nicht
in dem Sinne. Ich habe Pressemeldungen gelesen.
Aber dass man es auswendet und nicht als solches sieht, genauso auch dieser
Messermord an den Polizisten, der stattgefunden hat, das hat ja auch möglicherweise
eine politische Dimension.
Also bei Sylt ist man sofort bereit zu politisieren. Und ich pfeif dich ja hier
direkt zurecht, sobald du sagst, die haben da ein Lied mitgegrillt.
Das ist das, was ich gesehen habe.
Und wir haben alle nur ein Video gesehen.
Wir müssen das politisch ableiten, das finde ich schon. Nur hier muss man das vielleicht auch.
Und wenn dies zum Beispiel in Zusammenhang stünde mit einem fundamentalistischen
Islamismus, dann muss es auch so benannt werden. Und man kann nicht immer so
tun, als gäbe es das überhaupt gar nicht.
Es wird von den Rechten groß gemacht, weil die davon sich Wählerstimmen erhoffen.
Aber man kann auch nicht einfach sagen, es gibt das nicht.
Das ist falsch. Es gibt das nicht. Ich bin noch nicht...
Man kann es daran sehen, dass es von ganz vielen Seiten sehr gerne gar nicht thematisiert wird.
Und ich finde, da kann man schon, ich will niemanden aufrufen,
dazu irgendwelche Posts zu machen.
Bei Thürnhausen habe ich zuletzt gehört, als ich in Bielefeld studiert habe.
Also ich will jetzt nicht dazu aufrufen, aber es ist auffällig,
dass zu solchen Taten keine Posts von ganz, ganz vielen, die sonst immer zu
solchen Dingen posten stattfinden.
Und das ist für mich nur etwas, was ich erlebe und dann, und ich merke ja selbst,
wie ich hier mit Worten ringe, das ist offenbar sehr viel schwerer.
Vielleicht ist es zu thematisieren, wenn wir vielleicht nochmal was zu Sylt sagen können.
Du hast das jetzt problematisiert, weil sehr viele Leute zu sehr vielen anderen
Themen sich äußern. Ich möchte...
Das Problematisieren nicht, weil sie sich dann nicht zu Bad Oeynhausen äußern,
sondern weil sie sich zu den anderen Themen äußern.
Haltet doch einfach mal alle die Fresse.
Löscht eure Twitter-Accounts. Das ist doch nicht mehr erträglich.
Ich kriege mittlerweile Push-Nachrichten, weil Julian Reichelt irgendwas auf News gepostet hat.
Auf dem Neue20er-Account. Der Neue20er-Account hat zwei Follower. Du und ich.
Und irgendwer auf der Welt, Elon Musk, entscheidet, Es sollte einen Algorithmus
geben, der mich deswegen, weil wir da unsere Podcast-Dinger posten,
darauf hinweist, dass ich mich jetzt auch noch zu den Sachen,
die Julian Reichelt gemacht hat, äußern soll.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin da jetzt dagegen.
Leute, schaltet den Fernseher aus. Fahrt Slalom um die Nachrichten.
Hört neue Zwanziger. Wir zeigen euch am Ende des Monats, was wichtig ist.
Aber diese allgemeinen Diskussionen, die in Deutschland gerade ablaufen,
sind wirkliche Zeitverschwendung. Ihr verschwendet euer Leben.
Kein Milliardär im Silicon Valley duldet es, dass seine Kinder so ein Medienverhalten haben.
Niemand bei Verstand macht es. Schaltet aus.
Wir kommen in Teufels Küche.
Habeck war in China.
China ist nach den USA der zweitwichtigste Handelspartner Deutschlands.
China ist aber auch systemischer Rivale.
Entsprechend viel Fingerspitzengefühl fordert diese Reise von Wirtschaftsminister Habeck.
Erst recht, weil Peking sauer ist wegen der Strafzölle auf chinesische Elektroautos.
Die USA hatten hier den Anfang gemacht mit 100 Prozent Einfuhrzoll.
Die EU-Kommission in Brüssel zog nach, droht nun auch mit Zöllen bis zu 38 Prozent.
Wie erwartet schlägt China zurück, prüft wohl auch Strafzölle,
zum Beispiel auf Schweinefleisch, was vor allem Spanien treffen könnte.
Willkommen im Handelskrieg. Habeck ist jetzt als Wirtschaftsminister dahin gereist,
einmal um deutsche Interessen zu vertreten, aber auch um europäische Interessen zu moderieren.
Wir haben jetzt hier gehört, China ist unser systemischer Rivale.
Wir haben das Buch von Brecht dazu gelesen.
Es ist, wie dieses Buch Feuer mit Wälzer, umso mehr Zeit ins Land geht,
umso wichtiger nehme ich das.
Weil erst jetzt höre ich ja umso sensibilisierter, was so der allgemeine Sprech ist.
Und in China leben 400 Millionen Menschen im Rentenalter.
Die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt
bei 25 Prozent oder sowas. Das halbe Land steckt noch immer in Armut.
Wir sind kein systemischer Rivale, sondern es ist wie Precht schrieb,
wir sind in einer globalen Schicksalsgemeinschaft um die großen Fragen der Menschlichkeit mit China.
Und jeder, der davon abrückt und es anders sieht, muss das begründen.
Und diese Begründung fand in diesem O-Ton hier nicht statt.
Was für mich bedeutet, das ist kein akzeptabler, von gut und schlecht will ich
gar nicht sagen, das ist kein akzeptabler Journalismus für die deutsche Wählerschaft.
Ja. So kann man das nicht machen.
Und ich will es ausdrücklich dazu sagen, wir haben jetzt alle auch das Gespräch
von Precht bei Thilo gesehen.
Dieses ich habe da einen Philosophen, der wirklich wichtige Anmerkungen macht
und ich zwinge ihn die ganze Zeit in irgendwelche Kinkerlitzchen,
die so dumm sind, wie wir es sonst nur bei Trump gegen Biden sehen.
Wer kann hier weiter mit dem Golfschläger schlagen? Ist auch völlig daneben.
Und wir finden langsam keine Nische mehr, in der ordentlich diskutiert wird.
Also wir sollten sehr froh sein, dass wir jemanden wie Precht haben,
der nochmal in ökonomischer Freiheit, die er sich erarbeitet hat und solche
Themen überhaupt bearbeitet.
Weil so wie Trump sagte, ich kann ja auch jetzt Golf spielen gehen und so weiter,
aber der richtet ja das Land zugrunde und deswegen, ja, diese große Lüge muss
ich ja jetzt hier rein. Das ist bei Precht nicht so.
Precht sagt niemandem, ich will dein Kanzler sein, ich belüge dich jetzt,
damit du mich wählst und so weiter und so fort. Dieser ganze Scheiß.
Nein, Precht macht ein Denkangebot.
Das kann man lesen oder nicht. Dann kann man daran anschließen oder nicht.
Nämlich, wenn man das Buch nicht mag, einfach ignorieren.
Man muss den Autor jetzt nicht in irgendwelche Pseudokontroversen reinziehen.
Und ich sage das auch explizit, weil wir immer wieder Fragen bekommen von jungen Hörern.
Wir haben sie jetzt getroffen, sie war mit uns in der Oper, wir haben sie in der Case gesehen.
Und dann kommt immer mal wieder die Frage, ihr informiert uns jetzt so über
die Sachen, wie kann ich denn jetzt Sachen verändern?
Und es tut mir dann in meinem Herzen leid zu sehen, wie engagiert diese jungen
Leute sind und ihre eigene Biografie, die sie gestalten können,
darüber verlieren und vergessen und übersehen, in so einem, nee,
ich geh jetzt raus in die Welt und verändere irgendwas für alle. Nein.
So falsch es klingt, aber wenn jeder sich um sich selber kümmert und dann noch
um eine weitere Person, dann ist schon ganz schön viel erreicht.
Was nicht erreicht ist, wenn sich Leute irgendwie auf die Straße kleben und
den ganzen Scheiß. Diese Bilanzen haben wir doch jetzt gerade in ad hoc gezogen.
Hier muss jetzt ein neues Umdenken stattfinden.
Begonnen bei Kritik an so einer Art von Journalismus. China ist nicht unsere systemische Rivale.
Es kann sein, dass die politischen Klassen Kontroversen haben,
aber da leben 1,4 Milliarden Menschen und hier leben 80 Millionen Menschen und
die sind einfach nicht in systemischer Rivalität. Das ist einfach gelogen.
Die meisten von uns haben noch nie mit Chinesen längere Zeit gesprochen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Rivalen sind, wenn ich die überhaupt nicht kenne.
Ja, wenn wir Rivalen sind, machen wir eine Fußball-EM. Aber nicht sowas.
Nicht so ein Journalismus.
Ein Satz noch zu dieser Frage nach dem Engagement, das bekommt man häufig gestellt,
ich würde es jetzt nicht ganz so individualistisch beantworten.
Ja, man muss sich um sich selbst kümmern und da kommt man auch nicht umhin.
Also man kann sich nicht selbst verlieren darüber, dass man sich um andere kümmert.
Damit ist am Ende niemandem geholfen. Nur was ich schon glaube ist,
dass man sich über mehr als noch eine weitere Person verständigen kann,
sondern man kann sich durchaus in kleineren Gruppen zusammenschließen,
die irgendetwas machen.
Also es gibt ja Vereine, die sich für besseren Wohnraum,
für eine grünere Innenstadt, um sehr zu kleinere Dinge anzusprechen,
also im Sinne klein von lokal bis hin zu anderen Fragen, zum Beispiel Seenotrettung
oder so, zusammenschließen.
Und das geht schon, nur ist es nicht ein entweder oder.
Also es ist nicht ein, ich opfere mein Leben der grünen Innenstadt oder ich
führe ein eigenes Leben, sondern ich führe ein eigenes Leben und dazu gehört
auch, dass ich mich für die Umwelt einsetze oder für irgendetwas anderes einsetze.
Und das muss, glaube ich, zusammengedacht werden und dieses ausschließliche
ich gehe hinaus in die Welt und verändere sie, das ist etwas,
was nur Enttäuschungen produzieren kann. Nun,
Haben wir jetzt schon sehr gut herausgearbeitet, wie einfach dieses Regierungssprechen
vollkommen übernommen wird vom ZDF heute.
Wir hören jetzt mal weiter in diesen Bericht rein.
Als Robert Habeck in Peking ankommt, macht er sich erstmal auf den Weg zu einem
Treffen mit den Botschaftern der EU und verkündet danach seine Idee für eine
europäische China-Strategie.
Das neudeutsche Wort ist immer Diversification,
also eine breitere Aufstellung von Lieferketten, die Investitionen,
die wir im Ausland tun, nicht alle nur in China vorzunehmen,
sich, man muss es so hart sagen, von chinesischen Abhängigkeiten zu befreien.
Wozu die aktuellen Abhängigkeiten führen können, spürt er bei dieser Reise besonders.
Denn es brodelt ein Handelsschreit.
Ausgelöst, weil China E-Autos unrechtmäßig subventioniert haben soll.
Brüssel droht mit Strafzöllen, Peking mit Gegenmaßnahmen. Sie könnten u.a.
Deutsche Autobauer treffen.
China ist mit ihr wichtigster Absatzmarkt. Es wächst die Sorge vor einem Handelskrieg.
Die Stimmung ist da schlecht. Da hoffe ich mir, dass der Vizekanzler und Wirtschaftsminister
jetzt hier hinkommt und auch ein klarer Message sendet, dass Deutschland kein
Interesse an diesen Zöllen hat.
Das war ein Herr von der Handelskammer. Nun, welche Sache finden wir hier eigentlich vor?
USA und China befinden sich in so einer Systemrivalität, die ausgerufen wurde,
aber vor allem von Trump und dann von Biden dankbar übernommen wurde.
Jetzt will die EU sich dem anschließen, denn wir wissen Ursula von der Leyen
ist da ganz auf Bidens Seite. Nun ist Habeck in einer eigenartigen Position,
eigentlich in einer dreifachen.
Er soll jetzt die europäischen Interessen moderieren in China,
er soll aber auch die deutschen Wirtschaftsinteressen vertreten,
die andere sind, denn da hat man kein Interesse an den Zöllen.
Und sagen wir, es gibt sogar vier Ebenen. Die dritte Ebene ist,
dass er jetzt seiner Partei zeigen muss, dass auch er wertegeleitete Außenpolitik machen kann.
Und genau, das ist das vierte, den Journalisten und das hat schon wohl ziemlich
gut funktioniert, alle haben sich wieder sofort verliebt in Habeck,
den Journalisten muss er zeigen, dass er eigentlich der bessere Kanzler ist.
Und.
Die Frage ist dann, was geschieht hier eigentlich?
Ich meine, wir sehen ihn in China, wie er da steht und was von Diversifizierung
erzählt und wie man sich von chinesischen Abhängigkeiten löst.
Man kann ja nur hoffen, dass die das in China nicht sehen. Denn eigentlich müsste
er ja in China sagen, es waren wunderbare Gespräche, wir haben tolle Kooperationen
gemacht und wir haben einen wunderbaren Zukunftsplan für eine saubere Zukunft oder so etwas.
Ja, sowas würde man eigentlich machen.
Als Wirtschaftsminister. Aber nein, er erzählt da nur seinen Journalisten nochmal
ganz deutlich, ja, es gibt diese Systemrivalität.
Ja, hier müsste man eigentlich auch auf dieser nonverbalen Ebene,
gibt es eine gemeinsame Pressekonferenz?
Wenn nicht, wo kriegt er noch einen Raum, wo er das machen kann?
Steht er nur auf der Straße und so? Brauchst noch den Spaß.
Solche Sachen müssten hier, das sind diese Haltungs- und Stilnoten,
auf die die Chinesen ja so viel Wert legen.
Er ist also dort unterwegs und dann am späten Abend ein Achtungserfolg.
Würde sogar sagen überraschend, als es die ganzen Leute, letzten Wochen nicht
gelungen ist, in einen konkreten Verhandlungsfahrplan einzusteigen.
Ich hatte über den Tag das Gefühl, dass die Botschaften, die ich senden wollte,
die wir gesendet haben, immer mehr verstanden wurden.
Wenn das dazu beigetragen hat, dass der europäische Kommissar und der chinesische
Handelsminister so reden konnten, dass sie für die Zukunft auf einen konstruktiven
Pfad einschwenken, dann wäre das gut.
Du weißt jetzt auch nicht, was Habeck da eigentlich gemacht hat.
Also er hat in China dafür gesorgt, dass doch mal Europa und China wieder miteinander redet.
Dass es Gespräche gibt, bevor Europa endgültig entscheidet, was jetzt Sache ist.
Mit diesem Zoll. Wir hören jetzt mal, wie Habeck das überhaupt einschätzt, was die EU da plant.
Die zweite Frage ist, es ist ja eine Struktur der chinesischen Wirtschaft,
die auch dazu geführt hat, dass diese Zolle jetzt verhängt werden.
Das ist ja kein Einzelfall, was dahinter steckt. Also wie viel ist da überhaupt zu machen am Ende?
Ja, das ist auch meine Beobachtung, beziehungsweise so würde ich die Lage insgesamt beschreiben.
Die chinesische Gesellschaft ist darauf angewiesen, dass es Wachstum gibt.
Dieses Wachstum ist durch einen großen Baumuhm beispielsweise ausgelöst worden.
Nun kann man hier in Shanghai sehen, es ist ziemlich viel gebaut worden.
Also man kann diese Halbinsel ja nicht zweimal bebauen.
Man muss ein anderes Wirtschaftsmodell sich überlegen.
Und dieses Wirtschaftsmodell ist sehr stark exportorientiert.
Das ist auch richtig und gut und soll so sein. Wir kommen aus Deutschland.
Ich bin der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister.
Wer hätte etwas gegen eine leistungsfähige Exportwirtschaft?
Nur wenn dieser Export leistungsfähig gemacht wird, indem er staatlich subventioniert
wird, dass kein anderes Land auf einem fairen Wettbewerb, bei einem fairen Wettbewerb
mithalten kann, dann gibt es ein Wettbewerbsproblem.
Ja, also nicht nur versteht man nicht, was er sagt, sondern auch,
wie man dieses Problem jetzt im Klein-Klein lösen sollte.
Subventionen müssten nachgewiesen werden, damit man die auf Welthandelsorganisationsebene
mit entsprechenden Bestrafungen dann irgendwie ausgleichen kann.
Also dann mit Zöllen höheren Gebühren bei der Einfuhr, die diese Subventionen ausgleichen.
Nur diesen Nachweis kann man halt nicht erbringen. Es ist doch Quatsch.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass China das jetzt hier billiger anbietet,
als sie das anderen Partnern anbieten oder so, das ist einfach nicht wahr.
Aber selbst wenn man es irgendwie nachweisen könnte, gibt es ja immer noch,
finde ich, die Großwetterlagen Klimadiskussion.
Beim Klima sagen wir auch, klar, jetzt gerade verbraucht Deutschland so zwei
Prozent des weltweiten Budgets an CO2, aber historisch gesehen ist die Verantwortung
viel höher, weil wir ja schon Jahrzehnte länger und so weiter und so fort.
Die europäische Wirtschaftsmacht, beginnend beim Kolonialismus und allen Einmischungen danach,
beruhten immer darauf, dass man mit politischem Interesse und auch so ein bisschen
über den partikularistischen Zaun eines Unternehmens hinausgrasend,
Hermes-Bürgschaften und dieser ganze Kram, gehen wir ins Ausland,
wenn es scheitert, gleichen wir das aus und so.
Und jetzt kommt man den Chinesen gegenüber und sagt, das ist aber alles verboten,
das darf man gar nicht und so. Das ist doch verlogen.
Wir hatten in der Wirtschaftskrise eine Abwrackprämie. Was ist denn das anderes
als eine Subvention der Autoindustrie?
Jetzt kann man sagen, ja damit konnte man aber noch ein anderes Auto kaufen,
ja aber es hat vor allem die heimische Wirtschaft gestärkt.
Wir hatten sprichwörtlich eine Deutschland AG und kritisieren jetzt,
dass es eine China AG gibt.
Ich lese vor aus dem Inflation Reduction Act, was da eigentlich der Fall ist.
Da gibt es nämlich auch Voraussetzungen dafür, dass man E-Mobilität gefördert bekommt.
Um aktuell in den Genuss der Gutschrift zu kommen, Auto, Motor und Sport ist
das jetzt hier, muss es in Nordamerika montiert worden sein. Nein.
Fragt man sich, was hat das mit E-Mobilität zu tun? Ich denke,
man ist für E-Mobilität, ist ja egal, wo das Ding zusammengeschraubt ist.
Weiteren Vorgaben ab 2024 zufolge werden nur noch Modelle mit dem vollen Fördersatz
subventioniert, wenn ihre Batteriekomponenten nicht aus einem als bedenklich
angesehenen Land stammen.
Als solche Länder gelten zum Beispiel China, Russland, Nordkorea oder der Iran.
Von 2025 an gilt diese Vorgabe auch in Sachen Batterierohstoffe.
Das heißt, man supportet die westliche Industrie, aber Klimawandel second.
Das ist hier das Ding. Also wenn wir uns jetzt nochmal überlegen,
die Merkel-Ära, du weist ja gerne darauf hin, hat dafür gesorgt,
dass mehr Menschen in Armut leben und es mehr Millionäre gibt.
Deutlich mehr. Ja, doppelt so viel sogar.
2008 ist die Finanzkrise, Merkel und Steinbrück retten die Banken in einer großen
Aktion mit vielen anderen zusammen.
China hat auch mit der Krise zu kämpfen, kommt aber danach zum Schluss,
wir müssen also jetzt staatliche Investitionen hochfahren, um auch das Klimaproblem
anzugehen, denn bei denen meint Klima auch einfach Smog, meint,
dass die Leute Kraft und Luft haben zum Atmen.
Wir haben diese Bilder aus Peking und so weiter, deswegen diese Elektromobilität.
So und dann gehen sie dazu über. Was machen wir? Wir machen eine Niedrigzinspolitik
und hoffen mal, dass schon irgendwie die Investitionen an die richtige Stelle rücken.
Was passiert? Die deutsche Autoindustrie baut jetzt inzwischen irgendwelche Luxuslimousinen,
die so PS-stark sind, dass man sie nur getrosselt fahren kann,
dass die nie anders irgendwo losgelassen werden,
mit irgendwelchen verrückten Specials, die es noch gibt.
Zwei Tonnen zu schwer pro Auto.
Und man hat es jetzt sogar noch geschafft, um noch an eine E-Förderung ranzukommen.
Also wenn du jetzt so eine Luxuslimousine fährst mit verlängertem Radstand,
da gibt es noch eine E-Förderung, wenn da noch ein Teil mit Batteriebetrieb ist.
Wenn die Bremskraft aufgefangen wird in einem kleinen Akku fürs Licht.
Dann… Da wird nochmal, also das subventionieren wir, wir subventionieren sogar noch Luxuslimousinen.
Was macht China? China sagt, ja wir brauchen E-Mobilität, Busse und so weiter,
aber auch Autos, denn China ist ein Land, das nicht nur mit Gleisen befahren werden kann.
Autos, wer kann sich eigentlich Autos leisten? Die deutsche Autoindustrie geht
von Leuten aus, die 50.000 Euro für ein Auto ausgeben.
China sagt, nee, wir brauchen vor allem E-Mobilität, Autos unter 20.000, die zuverlässig sind.
Die deutsche Autoindustrie ignoriert das, die französische auch,
die westliche generell ignoriert es.
China geht darauf ein, also das ist ja auch eine sehr große Industrieentscheidung
gewesen. Es ist ja nicht einfach, die Partei lenkt das alles,
das ist ja vollkommener Unsinn.
Und dann, was du schon angesprochen hast, worum geht es denn jetzt eigentlich?
Ist der Klimawandel jetzt unsere primäre Aufgabe, um die wir uns kümmern müssen?
Wenn die Antwort darauf ja ist…,
Dann kann man sagen, es gibt keine Überkapazitäten, sondern wir haben offenbar
viel zu wenig E-Mobilität, viel zu wenig Photovoltaikanlagen.
Wenn wir aber sagen, na Klimawandel ist schon ganz wichtig, aber nicht so wichtig.
Viel wichtiger sind geopolitische nationale Interessen im Sinne von wer ist der Stärkere.
Dann kann ich sagen, scheiß auf Klimawandel, die sollen mit den Autos draußen
bleiben. Und genau das passiert ja jetzt gerade.
Ja, ich bin über ein TikTok-Video gestolpert, das ich jetzt per Perplexity mir
inhaltlich nochmal aufrufe, mit der Frage, konnte ein Audi mit Verbrennermotor
mal mehr als 4000 Kilometer fahren?
Du hast ja gerade die technischen Errungenschaften, die Deutschland so jetzt gemacht hat.
Jedes zweite verkaufte Auto ist ein SUV und alle wiegen doppelt so viel und
der Rebound-Effekt, die Motoren werden ein bisschen effektiver,
aber das Auto ist doppelt so schwer, also verbraucht es am Ende mehr.
Stellt sich raus, im Jahr 1989 führte Audi eine bemerkenswerte Werbeaktion durch.
Sie sind mit einem Audi 100 durch Europa gefahren.
Die Bedingung war eine Tankfüllung.
Sie haben zum Beispiel eine Route ausgewählt mit wenig Verkehr und kaum Steigung.
Sie haben Seitenspiegel abgebaut für Luftwiderstand.
Die Reifen wurden übermäßig aufgepumpt, um den Rollwiderstand zu reduzieren.
Also würde ich jetzt so sagen, das sind alles so Sachen, die kann man auch nochmal
technisch optimieren und daraus Serienmodelle fahren, machen.
Sie sind damals mit diesem Audi 100 mit einer Tankfüllung 4818 Kilometer weit gekommen.
Hätte man in die Richtung optimiert, hätten wir gar keine Diskussion zum E-Mobilität,
sondern da könnten wir einfach mit so Autos, die ein Zehntel des Verbrauchens,
Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit 60 kmh.
Wenn man heute auf die Autobahn schaut, klar, wir wollen alle irgendwann mal ankommen.
Aber was spricht dagegen, LKWs stromlinienförmig zu machen und die mit 50 kmh
über die Autobahn zu schicken?
Wird für sie halt die linke Spur reserviert, sodass einfach klar ist,
Da stören sie nun wirklich niemanden. Alle anderen fahren so.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, auf die man hin optimieren könnte.
Man hat in die völlig falsche Richtung hin optimiert und erklärt jetzt eine
systemische Rivalität, während die Chinesen wirkliche soziale und ökonomische
Probleme lösen und nicht wie wir solche ästhetischen.
Es ist grotesk, wie diskutiert wird. Und dank Precht wird mir das klar im Kopf.
Wie umgedacht ich hier eigentlich werden muss.
Wir hören jetzt France24, da wird Li Qiang zitiert, er ist im Sommerlager von
Davos, also vom World Economics Forum,
ja, haben wir diesen Monat gar nichts mitbekommen, spielt auch keine große Rolle,
aber hier mal einen Auszug.
Crisis and... We should follow the principle of having common but differentiated
responsibilities und unsere entsprechenden Emissionen-Reduktion-Vorgaben erfüllen.
Wir können unsere Zeit in der grünen Transition nicht langsamen,
um kurzfristige ökonomische Entwicklung zu erreichen, und wir können auch nicht
in der Name von grünem Entwicklung oder der entwicklungsfähigen Schutz trainieren.
Worum es ja gehen muss, ist, dass man klar erkennt, auch dieser Mann,
der Premierminister Chinas, hat geopolitische Absichten und vertritt die Interessen seines Staates.
Aber wir haben doch eigentlich diese Idee, dass wir alle für das Klima verantwortlich
sind, die einen mehr, die anderen weniger und dass wir alle entscheidend zusammenarbeiten müssen.
Also man kann doch eigentlich nur über den Weg des Klimas oder am einfachsten
sage ich mal über den Weg des Klimas nur Kooperationen herstellen,
wo sie wirklich gebraucht ist und wo auch der Wohlstand ja zugleich wächst.
Also eine florierende chinesische Autoindustrie mag zwar jetzt gerade für Mercedes
oder BMW ein größeres Problem sein,
aber de facto ist es ja so, dass wo alles klimafreundlicher wird,
auch dann wieder eine neue grüne Wirtschaft prosperieren kann.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur sage, ich will meine überkommenden Modelle noch weiter festhalten,
dann verzögert man eigentlich nur sein eigenes Abgleiten, denn die Weltbedeutung
kann man nicht mehr damit erlangen, dass man sagt, wir haben nochmal den Verbrennermotor
nochmal optimiert, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, man kann nochmal 100 kmh schneller fahren.
Ja, vor allem das sind alles diese Autos, hier S-Klassen und so.
Die Spitzenmodelle, auf die diese Konzerne auch so angewiesen sind,
dass sie sich verkaufen, also die Dinger, die werden selbst in Deutschland nicht
von Privatleuten gekauft, sondern das läuft über dieses Firmleasing,
dann kommt irgendwie die Mercedes-Benz Bank und macht diesen ganzen Kram und so.
Die kosten 200.000 Euro.
Die Welt hat gar kein Geld dafür. Die Welt will jetzt in Afrika vorwärts kommen.
Da brauchen die Leute jetzt Autos. Die kaufen niemals jetzt im großen Stile,
so dass es für die Deutschen ertragreich ist, irgendwelche Mercedes, Audis, BMWs oder so.
Ja, naja, auch hier ist es ja so.
Also ich meine, wer kann ein Auto kaufen, das 50.000 Euro kostet?
Wie lange will man das fahren, dass sich das für einen irgendwie rechnet.
Die Autos sind generell einfach zu teuer. Der sogenannte Mittelklassewagen ist
ein Oberschichtswagen.
Der Mittelklassewagen ist nicht für, ja was ist der Mittelklasse,
ist schon die Frage, aber würde ich sagen, wenn man jetzt verbeamteter Lehrer
ist, kauft man sich so ein Auto schon nicht.
Und da gibt es ja noch ganz, ganz viele, die sehr viel weniger verdienen.
Und man wird über individuelle Mobilität nicht drumherum können,
es sei denn, man wohnt in Frankfurt, wie Stefan.
Ich kann ja ohne Führerschein leben, aber das ist nun wirklich….
Die deutsche Autoindustrie produziert mehr, als die Deutschen brauchen.
Sage ich jetzt, ach, das ist aber schlimm mit diesen Überkapazitäten.
Das müssen wir denen aber mal abgewöhnen.
Jetzt hören wir, die Chinesen wollen jetzt die Schweineimporte,
die vor allem aus Spanien kommen, wollen sie dann auch mit Zöllen belegen.
Soll ich jetzt sagen, ach ja, die Spanier, die produzieren offenbar Überkapazitäten.
Naja, das ist Welthandel.
Wir hören einen letzten Clip, denn es gibt jetzt so einen Deal von China und
das ist natürlich toll, wie man jetzt einfach sagt, Gut, die Deutschen wollen
ihre alten Marken und Verbrenner und so.
Machen wir denen doch jetzt mal so ein Angebot, das auch einen Habeck in die Bredouille bringt.
EU-Kommission in Brüssel, um auf die provisionalen Tarife, die sie auf chinesische
EV-Importe gefordert hat, zu beurteilen.
Sie haben die Idee gefordert, die Idee gefordert, die existente Tarife auf große
Fahrzeuge auf die chinesischen Märkte zu beurteilen. Diese stehen aktuell bei 15 Prozent.
Sie haben auch vorher den Stick als Kaffee verwendet, der die 25 Prozent-Fee
auf große EU-Fahrzeuge which would particularly hit makers like Mercedes or BMW.
Wir können Steuern senken, wir können sie anheben. Was wollt ihr dann jetzt eigentlich?
Ich bin hier bei einem Text gestolpert von oder ein Interview mit Jens Südekum,
geführt von Marc Schieritz und Kollegen und die Zusammenfassung,
da kann man auch nur sagen, es ist im Grunde, weil Schieritz sich da so positiv,
Südekum so positiv, ja, das muss schon sein, es geht um 700.000 Arbeitsplätze.
Wir sollten nicht denselben im Fehler machen wie bei der Solarindustrie,
als wir zu spät die eigene Industrie protokzionistisch gesichert haben und dann
alles nach China abwanderte.
Nur, wenn man sich diese Argumente so anschaut, das ist ökonomischer,
struktureller Realismus.
Hier wird einfach, Zölle sind Lenkungsinstrument.
Damit machen wir Interessenpolitik. Da würde ich sagen, ja genau,
so haben wir das ja auch diskutiert.
Ursula von der Leyen kommt ins Amt, sagt, wir brauchen einen Green Deal.
Wie erreichen wir das, dass Saarstahl jetzt auf Wasserstoff als Hitzequelle
für die Stahlproduktion umstellt?
Naja, wir müssen halt der Stahl, der von außerhalb kommt, strafbezollen.
Wir haben dann einen Ring um Europa und dann heißt es einfach,
hier wird eine Klimaanpassung gezahlt.
Und alles, was den Stahl billiger macht, weil noch mit Kohle und sonst wie hergestellt,
wird halt einfach als Preis draufgeschlagen.
Da wird also nicht mit Überkapazität oder die befluten uns oder irgendwas,
sondern nein, wir haben das Ansinnen, hier klimaneutral hergestellten Stahl zu verwenden.
Also hat das einen Preis für die Welt. Wenn in Europa entschieden wird,
das so zu machen, hat das einen Preis.
Und das sind aber ganz andere Argumentationen, als wenn hier irgendwie systemische
Rivale, da müssen wir mal dagegen halten aus Prinzip und die befluten uns und
das ist Überkapazität, solltest du es doch woanders verkaufen.
Vor allen Dingen ist ja momentan der Anteil chinesischer Autos noch wahnsinnig gering in der EU.
Das mag sich ändern, nur das ist dann eine Sache, die liegt nicht bei den Investitionen,
die da von chinesischer Seite getätigt wurde, sondern sicherlich auch daran,
dass diese Autos eine gewisse Qualität haben und auch einen Preis,
den Leute eher bereit sind zu zahlen
und Kanada versucht ja jetzt auch die chinesischen Autos auszudrängen,
wo man erst sagen kann, naja die Chinesen stehen da vor dem Beginn und da sieht
man, es geht hier also um Staatsinteressen und es geht nicht mehr darum,
dass man das Klima in den Mittelpunkt rückt.
Von den Sozialdemokraten kommt ja auch nichts entscheidendes dazu und damit
würde ich überleiten. Wir können bei den Autos noch sagen.
Autos kann man halt gut an der Grenze abfangen.
Das geht bei sehr vielen anderen Gütern nicht. Wenn wir aber diese anderen Güter
jetzt aufladen mit so einem politischen Wunsch, die müssten wir auch mal so
abfangen können, dann kommen wir in Teufels Küche.
Weil dann sind die Maßnahmen so kompliziert, dass wir uns näher dieser schießenden
Auseinandersetzung nähern.
Ja. Weil dann kommt irgendwie so, nee, wir müssen hier eine Firewall einrichten,
damit nicht die digitalen Services darüber schwappen und so weiter.
Und dann wird es, sowas ist alles brenzlig. Von daher, also ich bin total,
Wenn irgendwer auf der Welt ein billiges Auto herstellt.
Ich habe mich das immer gefragt, als es immer hieß, ja, die Deutschen,
die machen immer so und dann leben die ja auf dem Defizit der anderen.
Wo ich mir dachte, wo ist das Problem, wenn Deutschland jetzt an alle exportiert,
die dann ein Handelsbilanzdefizit haben, weil im Hintergrund kann man sich auch
einfach sagen, na, ist doch schön, dass die chinesische Regierung für uns die
Autos bezahlt, uns die Autos billiger macht.
Ja, so ist es ja.
Und das sollten wir doch eigentlich dankbar annehmen, oder? Statt uns zu beschweren,
dass die Chinesen uns Autos anbieten, die 18.000 statt 23.000 Euro kosten.
Ich gehe doch auch nicht in die Oper und sage, also dass sie jetzt so eine Operncard
haben und ich auf jede Karte, die ich kaufe, 30% Rabatt bekomme.
Das ist doch bescheuert. Das will ich gar nicht. Ja.
Und so. Ja, also so auf der Ebene.
Aber das...
Sollen sie doch ihr Handelsbilanzdefizit verbuchen und ja, dann stehen wir halt
bei China in der Kreide, in Anführungszeichen.
Hauptsache wir haben halt kostengünstige Mobilität.
Ja, oder man lässt sich dann herausfordern und sagen, okay, Challenge angenommen,
wir produzieren noch günstigere Autos oder produzieren Autos,
die noch was anderes Tolles können.
Wo ist der deutsche Ingenieursgeist?
Was du jetzt gerade ja deutlich machst ist, wir Konsumenten profitieren doch davon.
Absolut. Also verstehen wir uns doch viel mehr jetzt mal wieder als Konsumenten.
Ich bin eigentlich in systemischer Rivalität mit unserer Bundesregierung,
die mir die E-Mobilität teurer macht.
Ja, richtig. Ja, aber du sollst ja, und da ist ja dann auch schon so eine Moderationseinleitung
für da, dich als Staatsbürger angerufen fühlen und nicht als Konsument.
Okay. Weißt du, du sollst, wenn du jetzt durchs Geschäft gehst,
sagen, oh, ist das mit der deutschen Staatsräson vereinbar?
Damit sind wir jetzt beim Thema Scholz oder was?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, aber darum scheint es wohl zu gehen.
Ja, Thema Scholz. Es ist ein weiteres Trauerspiel, das ich hier mitbringe.
Es gibt eine Institution, die heißt das Progressive Zentrum.
Das ist so ein bisschen Think Tank und Veranstaltungen machen die.
Jedenfalls war dort Lea Ippi zu Gast.
Das ist eine Philosophin, die hat auch ein sehr interessantes Buch über ihre
eigene Kindheit und Jugend geschrieben.
Frei heißt das über ihre Zeit in Albanien und sie hat also eine Unfreiheit erfahren,
erlebt aber jetzt in einem westlichen Kapitalismus auch eigentlich keine Freiheit.
Jedenfalls ist sie dort und diskutiert mit dem Kanzler. Also der Kanzler hat
sich gedacht, ich setze mich jetzt mit einer Philosophin und Schriftstellerin
und Sozialistin, wie sie sich selbst bezeichnet, auf ein Podium.
Könnte ja interessant werden, denkt man. Und sie macht auch gleich zum Einstieg mal einen Witz.
It's a pleasure and an honor and I feel a little bit like wannabe Machiavelli
talking to wannabe Lorenzo.
Ja, also Lorenzo war der Bratenwurde von Machiavelli. Nun will sie über den Kapitalismus reden.
I think it is about capitalism per se and we think that neoliberalism is indeed the worst evil.
Kapitalismus ist ein historisches Phänomen und eine Struktur, die, wie gesagt,
für alle pervasive, globale Effekte hat und die durch Perioden von Boom und
Bust geht, wo, wenn Dinge gut für Kapital gehen, gehen sie gut für Demokratie
und wenn sie nicht gut für Kapital gehen, gehen sie nicht gut für Demokratie.
Ja, beziehungsweise könnten wir sagen, was ja auffällig ist und Veit Selck schildert
es ja auch in dem Buch, ist, dass das Vertrauen in die Demokratie da nachlässt,
wo der Kapitalismus ins Straucheln gerät.
Also wo dauerhaft Krisen sind, wo nicht mehr dieses Wirtschaftswachstum wie
eins da ist, da merkt man, dass sich beides nicht mehr so gut miteinander verträgt.
Das ist ja in Deutschland wirklich eine historisch einmalige Ko-Evolution gewesen.
1949 wird hier die Demokratie eingeführt und 1955 beginnt das Wirtschaftswachstum,
das Wirtschaftswunder.
Dass das bei den Leuten in die DNA einprogrammiert wurde, ist klar.
Dass die Ossis dann heute anders wählen, ist auch klar, weil die haben genau
diese Ko-Evolution eben nicht mitgemacht.
Ja, und diese Ko-Evolution hat ja auch stattgefunden in anderen westlichen europäischen Ländern.
Große zweite Weltkriegsnachgeschichte.
Jetzt sagst du auch gerade Einmaligkeit, heißt das, es kann sich nicht wiederholen?
War das eine Laune der Geschichte?
War das ein Zufall? Die Frage ist, hängen also Demokratie und Kapitalismus eigentlich
gar nicht miteinander zusammen, aber da sind die mal zusammengekommen?
Ja, das wäre so die Arbeitshypothese.
Sind die gar keine Geschwister?
Ja, es ist erstaunlich. Wir haben ja die größte Zerstörung Europas,
die gleichzeitig die Lehre mitbrachte, wir müssen es jetzt politisch ganz anders machen.
Also hat man es demokratisch gemacht und dann ist wahrscheinlich,
müsste man jetzt mit Historikern darüber streiten und sich ökonomisches nochmal
anschauen, ob diese Art der, wir öffnen es demokratisch und lassen damit eben auch,
Unternehmen machen, also zur Demokratie gehört die Freiheit und das eben auch
die unternehmerische, dass es da schon einen Zusammenhang gibt,
der auch strukturell begründbar ist und nicht einfach nur Zufallshistorie darstellt.
Aber ich würde trotzdem unter Maßgabe, dass wir ja noch andere Regionen auf
der Welt sehen und wie es anders funktioniert,
gerade jetzt China, die nun mal den zentralen Zugriff auf alle unternehmerische
Freiheit sich immer noch erlauben, politisch, und trotzdem Wirtschaftswachstum
organisieren und vielleicht sogar unter Druck besser als wir gerade.
In der Hinsicht müsste man jetzt diskutieren eigentlich mit so jemandem wie
Scholz, der am Hebel sitzt.
Wir hören aber vorher noch einmal Lea Eppi.
Des Sozialismus geschrieben hat, wo der Argument tatsächlich ist. Are they?
They are. I disagree.
Demokratie und Kapitalismus sind nicht kompatibel, sagt er.
Ja, das ist ja noch die ganz alte SPD.
Ja, er wurde allerdings historisch dann schon ein bisschen matt,
schach gesetzt. Nicht schachmatt, aber schach vielleicht.
Wir hören uns jetzt die Argumentation von Scholz an.
The question is whether we are able to develop democracy, which is important for all of us.
And it makes a difference if you are living in a society without fear,
to say it with a famous philosopher, as a liberal democracy,
or if you are not living in such circumstances.
And the second is that I think there are different models of capitalist market economy possible,
and one is the social welfare state, which my party is proposing,
Und vor allem die ehemaligen Führer unterstützen wirklich den Entwicklung unserer Gesellschaft.
Debattiert wird. Wir haben aber ganz kurz einen Ausschnitt aus einer Scholz-Rede
jetzt vor wenigen Tagen im Bundestag.
Wir brauchen einen funktionsfähigen Kapitalismus in Europa, der die Wachstumsfinanzierung
der Unternehmen zustande kriegt.
Wir sehen jetzt Lindner-Platschen.
Ich glaube, er jubelt FDP und CDU zu.
Merz freut sich auch über diesen Satz. Es scheint ja offenbar darum zu gehen,
dass Scholz nicht nur den Kapitalismus lobt als Wohlstandsmacher,
sondern hier eigentlich implizit deutlich macht,
der Kapitalismus muss das aus sich selbst heraus schaffen, dann zu investieren.
Das heißt, das ist schon eine kleine Absage an jene in seiner Partei,
die die Schuldenbremse gerne abschaffen würden.
Ja, dieser Satz in der Kürze, wie er ihn sagte, ist, finde ich, von allen gut zu finden.
Die Frage ist dann, wie man ihn auslegt.
Denn Elizabeth Warren hat auch gesagt.
Sie will mehr Kapitalismus.
Nur eben mit klaren oberen Untergrenzen. Nichts geht unter Mindestlohn und ab
100 Millionen oder so bezahlt man jedes Jahr 2% auf sein Vermögen,
bis man unter 100 Millionen liegt.
Also es wird nichts wirklich aufgezehrt, aber es wird abgeschöpft oben.
Und dazwischen dann aber totale kapitalistische Freiheit, hauen und stechen.
Wir gucken mal, wie Scholz das so dann der Philosophin erklärt.
Globalisierung ist ein Vorteil für Weltentwicklung.
Und dass wir von den Ansätzen, die wir in den 70ern hatten, oder die wir diskutiert
haben, als es um den globalen Süden ging, sagen, dass das ein Risiko für sie ist.
Aber die Realität ist, dass Billionen von Menschen in die Mitte gekommen sind,
überall auf der Welt, besonders in Asien, aber nicht nur dort,
auch in Südamerika, auch in Afrika.
Und es gibt eine gute Chance, dass wir in der Mitte dieses Jahrhunderts with
10 billion people will be a world that possibly has a standard of living that
is very similar to the one we had let's say 1950.
Naja, also die sind nicht alle in den Mittelstand aufgestiegen,
sondern die sind aus dieser existenziellen Armut herausgehoben worden und,
das ist selbstverständlich eine große Leistung, die aber vor allem den asiatischen
Staaten zuzurechten sind.
Da ist jetzt nur zu sagen, und der Westen hat es nicht verhindert,
denn es war ihm daran gelegen.
Jetzt ist ja gerade die Frage, wenn er das so beschreibt, ist der Westen nicht
gerade dabei, das zu verhindern, dass genau dieser Prozess weitergeht,
zum Beispiel durch einen Handelskrieg.
Jetzt kommt er aber darauf zu sprechen, und da kommt man nicht umhin,
wenn man sich kurz nach der Europawahl mit einer Philosophin trifft,
auf diesen Rechtsruck einzugehen.
Why in the most lucky countries of the world we have right populist movements and unrest.
And you see it in Finland. From outside of Finland, people ask, do they have problems?
You see it in Sweden. From outside Sweden, the people ask, do they have problems?
The same with Norway, with Denmark, with the Netherlands, with Germany,
with Austria, with Swiss, with the north of Italy, to be precise.
So this area of very rich countries that made it that there is a high employment
rate, that people have a chance for a better life, but there is the development
of a certain welfare state that is existing,
where there is access to schools and a chance for a good education,
also if you are living in a family of poor people.
Jetzt hat er das Problem umrissen und versucht jetzt eine Antwort darauf zu geben.
Und das ist etwas, was wir verstehen müssen. Und ich denke, es hat mit der Globalisierung
zu tun, weil es nicht so ist, wie in den 70er, 60er, wo wir nur Ressourcen aus
diesen Ländern verwendet haben.
Aber weil es ein Welt, in dem es Industrialisierung gibt, in diesen Plätzen
des Weltes auch, sind die Menschen nicht...
Anymore that sure that nothing could happen to them because of the big distance between us and them.
Also man kriegt das noch nicht so ganz zusammen, was er da beschreibt,
also die Globalisierung.
Er wollte das Subkutane irgendwie kurz markieren.
Es scheint darum zu gehen, denn die Globalisierung ist ein Erfolgsmodell,
aber damit wächst die Welt näher zusammen.
Also die, die dort an der Globalisierung so weit entfernt beteiligt sind,
sind doch näher an uns herangerückt und er sagt dann folgendes.
So the success of globalization I think is one of the aspects of insecurity
and is exploited by the far right as we see and so this is what we have to understand.
In gewisser Weise sagt er hier etwas sehr ähnliches wie Precht,
dass er sagt, weil andere auch jetzt eine wichtigere Rolle spielen,
wird das als eine Unsicherheit wahrgenommen und das wiederum wissen die Rechten auszubeuten.
Vor allem sagt er ja, the success of the globalization.
Wir kennen ja eigentlich den Globalisierungsverlierer.
Der wird jetzt plötzlich zum Globalisierungsgewinner gemacht,
der aber sein Schicksal nicht versteht und deswegen verwirrt die Neurechtenwelt.
Ja, beziehungsweise ist die Frage, ob er uns als die Globalisierungsgewinner
betrachtet oder ob er diejenigen,
die jetzt aufgestiegen sind, als die Globalisierungsgewinner betrachtet und
die Globalisierungsverlierer, sind zwar die, die, wenn man sich mal die Löhne
ansieht oder die Vermögensverhältnisse ansieht, eigentlich die reicheren sind,
aber plötzlich nicht mehr so ganz reich sind, dass sie so weit weg sind von den anderen dort,
dass das nie zusammenkommen kann.
Lea Ippi sagt folgendes.
The problem is not that it lifts people from poverty, the problem is that in
doing so it creates inequality.
And we know that inequality has been rising and that power differentials between
the north and the south of the world put pressure then on countries in the north as well,
where again it's not about developing social welfare states here and then hoping
that globalization will trickle down and will produce the same effects elsewhere.
It's about understanding that what is done here comes at a cost.
And there I would disagree with you with the analysis that says,
well, we're not in a model like the one from the 70s, because we're not exploiting
resources, because in a way you are exploiting resources still.
Das ist sehr gut. Auf dieses Ungleichheitsargument muss man immer wieder kommen,
denn es ist so wirkmächtig und verschwindet aber immer so aus dem Blick.
Es hat ja sehr viel mit nicht mehr absoluten Argumentationen,
sondern eben mit Anmerkungen zu Relationen zu tun.
Und mit Relativitätstheorien tun wir uns ja immer schwer, nicht nur in der Physik.
Das ist dann immer nur so, versteht man alles nicht.
Aber in der Hinsicht ist das natürlich, weil jetzt könnte man die ganze Diskussion
dann nochmal von hinten aufziehen, wenn das als Grundbegriff jetzt einmal da
ist, Globalisierungsgewinner und Verlierer.
Wenn wir die bisher eingeteilt haben in, naja, es gibt die Herrenländer und
dann die Vasallenstaaten und dann ist das halt die Werkbank und so weiter.
Und dann stellt man irgendwann fest, nee, also es gibt schon noch die Näherin
in Bangladesch, aber die gehört jetzt nicht mehr dem reichen Amerikaner,
sondern dem Xi'in-Inhaber in China.
Es ist sozusagen dasselbe Ausbeutungsverhältnis, aber das Wir und Die passt
nicht mehr. Dann kommt alles durcheinander.
Und dann muss man sich alle Relationen neu anschauen.
Und in der Hinsicht, ja, so wie immer, wenn man sagt, was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Männern und Frauen, kann man drüber reden.
Aber die Unterschiede innerhalb der Frauen sind halt größer als die Unterschiede
per se zwischen Mann und Frau.
Arm und reich genauso, jung und alt genauso.
Auf allen Themen holt einen das dann immer wieder ein. Nur sich auf...
Und Relativitätsargumente einzulassen ist natürlich super schwer.
Da kannst du ja nicht mehr einfach mit Zahlen argumentieren und so.
Du musst ja immer beide Seiten betrachten.
Und noch Veränderungen im Zeitverlauf.
Deswegen fordert uns alles einfach aus.
Gehen sollten. Wenn man sie heute schaut, You have two days for laughing because
you won't find a single one or nearly no single one of those today in the economy.
So there are a lot of new companies that came up through the dynamics of the market economy.
And just to name the most famous like Google or Tesla or what happened in the last decades.
Naja, man kann natürlich jetzt sagen, eine Enteignung ist schwierig und man
kann auch betonen, dass die Firmen, die einst groß waren, heute abgelöst wurden durch andere.
Jedoch kann man ja steuerlich schon etwas dafür tun, dass diese Firmen nicht
zum Beispiel irgendwo in Steueroasen sich ansehen können.
Man kann auch was dagegen tun, dass Kapitalerträge niedriger besteuert werden als Arbeitseinkommen.
Also das sind ja alles Dinge, die wären ja jetzt anzusprechen von einem Sozialdemokraten,
kommt aber nichts. Wir hören mal weiter.
To work on the wrong question. And the right question from my perspective is
developing a secure perspective for people in a world that is changing,
giving them hope that they themselves, people that are similar as they are, will have a good future.
Also Hoffnung kann er uns versprechen. Was machen wir damit? Wenig.
Hoffenheit.
Lea Epi.
Und mein Wunsch ist, dass die Partiedemokratie jetzt ein Ort geworden ist,
wo es um den Leiter geht, um die Politik geht, um die Visionen des besseren
Weltes in sehr generellen Terminen geht, aber wo wir eigentlich keine spezifischen,
konkreten Diagnosen davon bekommen, was falsch geht.
And when we want to have those specific diagnoses, it's all turned into either
geopolitical conflicts or conflicts between cultures or conflicts between religions.
And this all essentializes factors that, although they're important,
miss out on a really important part of the socialist tradition,
which is, well, there are also distributive conflicts and material conflicts.
Und daran denke ich nicht, dass die Frage der Ungleichheit von innen kapitalistischen
Prinzipien und von innen dieser Art von Versuchungen behandelt werden kann.
Ungleichheit immer das zentrale Problem. Wir bräuchten im Grunde so eine Psychoanalyse,
die sagt, egal mit welcher Diagnose du kommst, egal wie du dein Leiden beschreibst,
die Ursache ist immer dieselbe, die Eltern. Und so müsste man hier auch.
Egal mit welchem Problem du gerade kommst, egal welches Thema hier ist,
Migration, der schickt die ganzen Verbrecher, der ganze Kram,
da hat ein Syrer jemanden erstochen, wie auch immer. mal, breche es erstmal
runter, welche Ungleichheitsverhältnisse haben wir?
Welche Lebenschancen können hier wie oder nicht genutzt werden?
Wie stellt sich das im Alltag dar? Woher kommt die Wut und so weiter?
Also das finde ich...
Würdest du so weit gehen, dass du sagst, man kann alles darauf runterbrechen?
Also der Psychoanalyse würden wir ja auch den Vorwurf machen,
dass es vielleicht doch ein bisschen zu einfach ist, wenn man sich immer mit
den Eltern beschäftigt nur.
Und genauso würde ich auch sagen, ja, Ja, es gibt Ungleichheit und das ist ein
großes Phänomen, das auch ganz, ganz viel durchdringt über das Portemonnaie hinaus.
Aber zum Beispiel bestialisch zu morden,
Femizide zu verüben, andere Dinge dieser Art sind jetzt nicht über Ungleichheit gleich herzustellen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Oder aus der Welt zu schaffen.
Naja, wir haben als Anlass Einzelfälle.
Und dann suchen wir das strukturelle Argument. Und das finden wir aber nicht.
Weil wenn du jetzt sagst, bestialisch morden, ja, dann ist jemand eine Bestie gewesen.
So, jetzt können wir natürlich danach gehen, die Menschen in Bestien und nicht
einzuteilen. Also man findet dann schon so ein paar.
Nur ein strukturelles Phänomen sehen wir dann nicht. Wenn wir ein strukturelles
Phänomen aber haben wollen und politische Entscheidungen können nun mal nur
am strukturellen Phänomen rumdoktern, deswegen sind es ja politische Probleme
und dann keine pädagogischen, persönlichen, was auch immer,
für die niederste Ebene der politischen Handlungsfähigkeit sind immer die ökonomischen,
Ungleichheitsargumente die wichtigen.
Also das sein bestimmt das Bewusstsein im Prinzip.
Ich will es mal historisch theoretisch aufdröseln. Also wir haben eine ganz
klare Entwicklung und die ist wirklich strukturell einfach einprogrammiert.
Wir hatten zuerst eine ökonomische Ungleichheit.
Menschen haben irgendwo ein Eigentum abgesteckt, haben das verteidigt.
Es gab also eine ökonomische Ungleichheit, die dann zu Gewalt führte und diese
Gewalt wurde politisch eingehegt. Wir haben Gewaltmonopole.
Gewalt wurde nicht ausgemerzt, sondern man hat gesagt, wenn hier jemand zuschlägt,
ist es der Polizist und wenn er sich rechtfertigen muss, dann nicht vor dem,
den er verprügelt hat, sondern vor dem Staatsanwalt. So, also zuerst in die
ökonomischen Asymmetrien.
Diese werden politisch eingefangen, führen aber ihrerseits wieder zu politischen
Asymmetrien. Es gibt mächtige und nicht so mächtige.
Das muss dann auch wieder eingehegt werden. Also hat man dann im dritten da
nochmal juristische draufgebaut. Und beim Rule of Law haben wir zwar einen Richter,
aber der weiß von sich immer, ich bin nicht die letzte Instanz, wie und so weiter.
Und dann haben wir immer noch diesen Sonderfall, dass es dann doch so letzte
Instanzen gibt, weshalb man ja im amerikanischen Richterwesen immer von Judge spricht.
Außer beim Supreme Court, dort heißen sie Justice. Also wir übersetzen Richter mal mit der Richter.
Außer für diesen Posten, da nennt man sie quasi Gerechtigkeit.
Da nennt man den Begriff der Gerechtigkeit dafür.
Da kriegt man es halt nicht ausgemerzt. Aber die ökonomischen Ungleichheiten
werden politisch eingefangen.
Weshalb immer, wenn politische Fragen im Raum stehen, im Grunde Eigentumsverhältnisse,
diese, egal in welcher Verbriefung.
So kann ich das nachvollziehen. Ich würde nur unterstreichen wollen,
dass es auch Probleme gibt, die nicht ökonomisch begründbar oder lösbar sind.
Genau. Und dann ist aber die Frage, sind es politische? Und da würde ich sagen,
sehr häufig wahrscheinlich nicht.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel,
fundamentalistisch in irgendeine Richtung wäre.
Das sind juristische Probleme. Weil dann gibt es Urteile darüber,
wie wir mit diesen Leuten umgehen.
Richtig, aber das ist nichts mehr, was sich ökonomisch grundieren kann.
Also in vielen Fällen zumindest nicht.
Zurück in die Bahnen gebracht. Die Strafprozessordnung ist wichtiger als das
Verbrechen. Wenn man die nicht einhält, ist das ein Verbrechen auch und so weiter.
Und am Ende wird der Täter isoliert. Das ist ja der Sinn des Urteils.
Die Welt weiß, egal ob er das anerkennt oder nicht, der normative Zwang gilt.
Er ist verurteilt, er ist isoliert bis hin zu Haften.
Scholz macht sich diese Überlegungen nicht.
As I said, we need a social market economy and a social welfare state.
We have to look that everyone has a good chance for safe development in his life.
And this means that we have to have demands on this question.
This was the question of minimum wage, which we raised and was part of our campaign.
Es war die Frage des Respekts, die wir erhoben haben, dass es darum geht,
wie wir die Menschen, die arbeiten, und wie ihre Perspektiven sind.
Ich kommt jetzt auf Marx zu sprechen.
Is being driven by the right, and we just don't, have a convincing alternative
that can speak across boundaries, across nations, and it's a vision for change
that can be cross-national in that way.
Ja, sehr richtig.
Das müssen wir nochmal ausbuchstabieren. Denn der Appell da drin ist ja,
liebe Linken, werdet Nationalisten.
Denn ihr kommt am Nationalstaat als Akteur nicht vorbei.
Aber sie sagt ja gerade nicht. Also sie sagt doch jetzt gerade,
das Problem ist, dass die eigentlich ökonomischen und Ungleichheitsverhältnisse,
Verhandelt werden jetzt als ein Konflikt zwischen den Nationen.
Also das, was jetzt mit dem Handelsstreit eigentlich stattfindet zwischen China und der EU.
Und darum ging es ja eben nicht, in dieser nationalistischen Denkweise das zu
tun, sondern jetzt zu sagen, wie kann man dann über das Thema Ungleichheit reden,
ohne jetzt nur darüber zu reden, ja, aber wir bauen Fahrradwege in Peru.
Deswegen ist mir ja wichtig, dass wir das jetzt nochmal repromodieren.
Aber du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, wir sollen der Nationalstaat denken.
Und Precht hat ja gesagt, es wird alles so kreuz und quer abstrahiert und dann
haben wir noch so rausgelesen, sozusagen mehr in den Text reingelesen, als drin stand.
Okay, wir erkennen jetzt an, global handelt der Nationalstaat und schafft damit
besondere Freiheit für Unternehmen unter seinen Fittichen.
So, also eine ökonomische Freiheit kann gewährleistet werden,
wenn eine höhere Instanz für Sicherheit sorgt.
Und das ist der Nationalstaat. Brecht hat ja dann auch im Gespräch nochmal gesagt,
am Nationalstaat führt kein Weg vorbei.
Was für mich jetzt bedeutet, wenn ich so einen Clip höre und sie betont auch
nochmal, ja die Rechten kapern so den Nationalstaat und bringen ihn so auf Konfrontationskurs.
Ja, der Konfrontationskurs ist falsch, aber nicht das Kapern des Nationalstaats.
Dann müssen jetzt die Linken den Nationalstaat kapern, um dann zu sagen,
nee, wir sind nicht in systemischer Rivalität, sondern wir könnten das auch
brüderlich in Gesprächen, die nicht auf Konfrontation getrimmt sind,
in dem Sommer Davos klären.
Aber am Nationalstaat kommen wir nicht vorbei.
Nur kommt man ja damit in eine Predurie, man muss ja dann sich in Eins setzen
mit dem Nationalstaat, was man ja eigentlich nicht tun sollte.
Denn aus der nationalstaatlichen Perspektive betrachtet, war die Schaffung des
größten Niedriglohnsektors Europas durch Gerhard Schröder absolut richtig.
Aber das ist ja eine Perspektive.
Die man von links nicht einnehmen kann oder sollte. Das hat ja gerade die SPD
so unglaubwürdig gemacht, sondern man müsste ja jetzt etwas jenseits dieser
nationalstaatlichen Interessen, die in eins gesetzt werden, wiederum mit Kapitalinteressen betrachten.
Das Wunder, das ja da drin steckt, dass sich...
Sagen wir mal, 20.000 Kapitaleigner durchsetzen gegen 8 Millionen Menschen,
die in diesem Niedriglohnsektor arbeiten.
Das hat nichts mit dem Nationalstaat zu tun als Rahmen, sondern das ist einfach,
wie führen wir Diskussionen, welche Rolle übernehmen die Medien,
wer kommt mit welchen Argumentationen.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht den Nationalstaat immer, das hat mit dem Nationalstaat
gar nichts zu tun. Das ist so ein bisschen wie...
Aber der muss es ja umsetzen. Also am Ende muss ja eine Regierung dann so was
was wie die Agenda 2010 auf den Weg bringt.
Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt die Europäische Union etabliert hätten und den Nationalstaat
entsprechend aufgelöst, dann würden wir halt sagen, ja, die EU ist schuld,
dass sich da die Mehrheiten nicht durchsetzen.
Das sollte ich deutlich machen, denn das unterscheidet mich auch nochmal,
oder was heißt unterscheidet mich?
Vieles unterscheidet mich von denen, aber das ist nochmal so eine Differenz,
die aufzumachen ist gegenüber Volt.
Volt macht das ganz interessant. Volt ist gegen dieses nationalstaatliche Denken,
aber die transferieren das nur auf die höhere Ebene und sagen,
bitte die EU soll nationalstaatlich denken.
Das ist das Brecht-Dilemma.
Aber das ist nicht internationalistisch gedacht. Und worum es glaube ich gehen muss, ist, dass wenn man,
sozialdemokratisch agiert, dass man zunächst mal die Bredouille erkennt, dass man zum einen,
Arbeiter vertritt und damit meine ich jetzt alles, was so die Arbeitskraft verkaufen
muss und Miete zahlen muss und so weiter,
und dass man zugleich aber angehalten ist, nationalstaatliche,
das heißt Kapitalinteressen zu vertreten, also Autoindustrie und was weiß ich.
Und dadurch ist man natürlich in einer permanenten Zwickmühle.
Das kann man aber zunächst mal so benennen und dann wird es schon mal deutlich.
Hier wird ja von Scholz so getan, als, und wir hören da jetzt gleich noch ein
sehr gutes Beispiel für, als würde er,
nur koordinieren, was ohnehin super Hand in Hand funktioniert.
Und das ist nicht der Fall. Wir hören noch mal, wir erinnern uns,
so will ich es einleiten, an Christoph Möllers, der sagte, was ich an der AfD
doch bewundere, ist, dass sie noch an die Politik glaubt.
Und da waren wir ja so verblüfft über diese Aussage.
IPI vermisst auch das Politische.
I think this is what we have to achieve, a European debate on politics with
different positions, so that people can follow it.
But I think we don't have a European debate on politics, because we actually don't have politics.
We only have policies. We've lost the politics. And this is the problem.
This is also why in Albania... For politicians it's something quite difficult to accept.
But it's a good sentence.
Although we sometimes have too much politics. Okay, let me say what I mean.
Let me be even more specific. Party politics.
That is to say, principled projects for how society should change in the light
of the crisis that we face.
I don't really see any exchange between principled projects between the European parties.
Gibt es irgendwelche europäischen Visionen, außer wir müssen die AfD verhindern,
wir müssen den Rechtsruck verhindern.
Diese ganzen Wahlaufrufe waren nur, bitte nicht die Rechten,
aber sonst keine positive Vision.
Ich sehe, dass es ein Projekt gibt, das niemand mag, das ist das rechtliche Projekt.
Und ich sehe, dass es eine Art Narrativ hat über Konflikte, über Kultur,
über Zivilisationen. Und ich sehe auch, dass die Progressiven diese Narrative
nur fassen, anstatt ihre eigene zu schaffen.
Ich sehe also nicht, wie man die europäischen Debatten verändern kann,
wenn man keine Art Politik hat, die Europa als Ganzes unterstützen kann,
mit einer Vision für Europa, die eine prinzipielle sozialdemokratische Vision ist.
Also wie sie das sagt, es gibt ja so ein politisches Projekt,
das wir alle nicht mögen, das ist der Rechten.
In Amerika wollen die Hälfte der Wähler Trump wählen.
Und ich höre ausschließlich im Podcast, dass man dagegen ankämpfen muss,
dass das ja gar nicht geht.
Und nirgendwo gibt es ein Verständnis dafür, warum die das machen.
Als würde man gegen so eine dunkle Masse irgendwie oder so ankämpfen.
Und das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Und das fällt mir dann immer wieder auf, wenn ich solche Hypesätze Auch in Deutschland,
16% haben jetzt die AfD gewählt.
Und zwar Menschen, die auf der Straße rumlaufen, in denselben Supermarkt gehen,
mit denen wir reden können, die können wir einfach fragen, warum die das machen.
Das ist die dunkle Masse, also gegen die müssen wir einfach ankämpfen.
Berlin Wall and the end of the Cold War and all the patterns that set in motion
and the way in which, if you want to call it neoliberalism, I call it capitalism
in the neoliberal phase, has drained politics out of societies.
Because it's replaced them with parties that have turned into technocratic managerial entities,
into leaders that are just driven by questions of charisma and these sort of
completely shallow, unprincipled discussions about what a leader should be and what a party should be.
And the whole debate is about nothing.
Wir alle wissen, was sie meint.
Erinnere ich an deine Argumentation zur Schuldenbremse? Ja, der Bundestag kann
prinzipiell alles entscheiden.
Und wir kritisieren, dass er immer nur so ganz eng fenstern,
ob jetzt der Mindestlohn 12,40 Euro
oder 60 oder so und dann wie die Mindestlohnkommission da beauftragt wird.
Oder eben er ist nicht mehr dafür zuständig, sondern hat das schon aus der Hand
gegeben. Könnte er alles zurückholen, kann alles selber machen.
Nur der Bundestag könnte dann halt wirklich über alles bestimmen.
Ja, ja.
Und wenn dann der Wind falsch weht, ist schlecht.
Scholz probiert es mit einem Scherz.
Ist, that there is a lot of politics that will change people's life.
We could discuss about and which are different between the top parties on the
national level as also on the European level.
And we have to develop these questions and discuss them and they will be part of our activities.
Jetzt hätte man ja gerne mal ein Beispiel für diese Politik gehört,
die nicht irgendwo in der Ferne liegt, die nicht allzu abstrakt ist.
Und dann denkt die Moderatorin sich, frag ich doch mal was Konkretes nach in
der Hoffnung auf eine konkrete Antwort.
Warum haben so viele junge Leute nichts gewählt?
Scholz beginnt jetzt und es wird jetzt sehr zäh, es wird jetzt sehr schlimm.
Ich verspreche es, es wird ganz, ganz schlimm, aber wir müssen da einmal durchgehen.
I mean... They're poorer than their grandparents, aren't they?
Nein, ich denke, es ist nicht überraschend, dass man jede politische Position
zwischen jungen Leuten und älteren Leuten finden kann.
Gebracht. Aber wir können generell sehen, junge Wähler, und zwar 16 bis 24,
haben zu etwa einem Viertel andere Parteien gewählt.
Das meint also Parteien, die nicht zu dem Spektrum aus dem Bundestag gehören.
Andere Parteien, also die haben einzelne kleine Parteien sehr groß gemacht.
Aber das heißt ja, ja, es mag ja sein, dass da auch noch sieben Prozent oder was die SPD wählen.
Also nicht alle wählen alles anders als die Großeltern und Eltern.
Aber es gibt ja offenbar eine große Differenz.
Ich glaube, er fasst mehr sonstige Wähler als Nichtwähler. Das ist ja vorher undenkbar gewesen.
Ich finde auch den Satzbau von ihm sehr problematisch, sein Einstieg.
Es war falsch zu glauben, die Jungen wählen anders als ihre Eltern.
Weil da steckt ja so ein bisschen die Manufaktur dieser Entscheidung drin.
Warum man jetzt das eröffnet hat, auch den 16-Jährigen zu wählen,
würde ich grundsätzlich sagen, nein, es ist natürlich immer richtig,
die Jüngeren auch wählen zu lassen, unabhängig davon, was man glaubt, wie die wählen.
Wenn die richtig wählen, machen wir das, dann dürfen die wählen,
aber wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Das war ja ein gewisses Kalkül auch bei den Grünen, denke ich,
das nicht aufgegangen ist.
Weil ich bin ja dafür, dass wir wählen ab null Jahre.
Wenn alte Menschen dement werden, wählt für sie der Betreuer.
Ihnen wird die Stimme nicht weggenommen.
Wir nehmen sie Kindern aber weg. Und die Kinder haben alle Betreuer.
Und deren Eltern, die diese Betreuerrolle einnehmen, wissen sehr genau,
was gut für ihre Kinder ist. ist, wenn wir die ganzen Mütter ermächtigen in
Deutschland, für ihre Kinder mitzuwählen, haben wir einen ganz anderen Wahlkampf.
Deswegen will ich hier nochmal ein Plädoyer dafür machen.
Lass die Eltern für ihre Kinder wählen. Und nicht nur die Rentner,
die dann ihren Betreuer losschicken, dem sie nicht mal erklären können,
was sie eigentlich mit ihrer CDU-Stimme vorhaben.
Ja, ich bin dagegen. Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass man nur für die Zukunft wählt,
sondern man wählt auch für die Gegenwart.
Und die gegenwärtigen herrschenden Verhältnisse...
Die sind dann von Leuten bestimmt, die einfach drei oder vier Stimmen haben
aufgrund der Anzahl ihrer Kinder.
Wer hatte bitte drei oder vier Kinder in Deutschland?
Du hast drei Kinder. Wir kommen gleich auf die Großfamilien zurück.
Ja, ja, ja. Du hast dann vier Stimmen, aber selbst wenn es nur ein oder zwei
sind, andere haben dann mehr und die entscheiden dann auch mit über die Gegenwart.
Also das heißt, du entscheidest über meine Gegenwart dann vierfach,
während ich über deine Gegenwart nur einfach entscheide.
Ich habe eine Stimme für meine Gegenwart, du hast eine Stimme für deine Gegenwart.
Ja, aber deine Kinder werden ja nicht gefragt von dir, sondern du entscheidest
ja dann für deine Kinder.
Ja, aber die sind ja trotzdem da.
Ja, aber du entscheidest für sie.
Ja, und? Ich entscheide sowieso für meine Kinder. Alle möglichen Lebensentscheidungen,
jeden Morgen. Wie viel Nutella kommt aufs Toast?
Also ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich schwierig wird.
Da wünsche ich mir jetzt mal Kommentare. Auf welcher Seite seid ihr hier? Wolfgangs oder meiner?
Ich würde sogar sagen, es wird sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht viel ändern.
Also es ist ja nicht so, also wenn wir uns an… Jetzt auch nicht den Scholz-Fehler. Nein, nein, nein.
Das man ja vorher und dann hat man aber… Ja, wir haben ja geglaubt.
Pass auf. Nein, nein, nein, wir glauben hier gar nichts. Wir wollen nur one man, one vote.
Hast du Zahlen darüber, dass Familien eher klimapolitisch sinnvoll abstimmen?
Hast du Zahlen dafür, dass Familien eher für eine Vermögenssteuer und eine Erbschaftssteuer sind?
Ich würde behaupten, nein. Ich würde sogar so weit gehen zu sagen … Ich bekomme recht zu sagen.
Ich beziehe mich auf Kant. Die Leute sollen wählen, was sie wählen.
Ich beziehe mich auf die Empirie, die du doch immer so hochhalten willst. Glaubst du wirklich,
dass Menschen, die in der Familie sind und dann viel mehr Stimmen plötzlich
zur Verfügung haben, diese Stimmen dafür einsetzen, dass hier von uns Dinge,
die wir oft ansprechen, dann eher umgesetzt werden?
Oder neigen nicht gerade Leute, die eine Familie haben, häufig dazu,
einen gewissen Konservatismus zu pflegen?
Wäre dein Vorschlag nicht einer, der Ja, der CDU zu ganz neuen Höhen verhelfen könnte.
Ja, jetzt lass mich mal antworten. Wenn in Thüringen sehr viele Menschen die
AfD wählen wollen, bin ich der Meinung, sollten sie ihren AfD-Ministerpräsidenten kriegen.
Wenn alte Menschen sagen, die Jungen sind mir egal, ich will nochmal Sturm und
Drang für meine letzten acht Jahre, ich wähle jetzt CDU, sollen sie CDU kriegen.
Wenn junge Familien sagen, das Familiengeld in Bayern ist eine gute Sache,
ich wähle die CSU, dann sollen sie die CSU wählen.
Ich möchte nicht...
Eltern eine Stimme für ihre Kinder haben, um irgendetwas zu verhindern oder etwas zu ermöglichen.
Ich habe da keine Hintergedanken.
Mir geht es um das Prinzip.
Und zwar egal, was dann inhaltlich passiert. Mir geht es um das Prinzip,
es sind Menschen in der Welt und wir sagen, in der Demokratie hat jeder eine Stimme.
Unabhängig davon, was er mit der macht. Und jetzt haben wir verschiedene Prinzipien,
in denen wir diese Stimme übertragbar machen. Zum Beispiel in diesem Krankheitsfall,
eine Stimme wird nicht zurückgenommen.
Wer lebt, wählt, darf wählen.
Das kann dann ein Stellvertreter machen, in dem Fall der Betreuer.
So, Kinder leben auch und die haben auch eine eigene Gegenwart und ich kann
dir sagen, auch Siebenjährige führen sehr politische Diskussionen im Vergleich
zu dem, was wir gerade bei diesen 80-Jährigen gesehen haben.
Sehr viel bessere, sehr viel wichtigere und von beiden Seiten sehr viel besser
argumentierte politische Diskussionen.
Nach dem, was wir heute gesehen haben, bin ich bereit, das zu glauben.
Kein Grund, einem Dreijährigen, einer Einjährigen oder einem Siebenjährigen
die politische Stimme zu verwirken.
Und sei es nur, um ihn darauf vorzubereiten, hör mal zu mein Sohn,
die letzten drei Mal habe ich für dich gewählt, jetzt bist du selber dran.
Wollen wir darüber mal reden. Es gibt sehr viele Gründe dafür,
ein Familienwahlrecht einzuführen. Und wichtig ist mir nur dieses Prinzipielle.
Eine lebende Person hat eine politische Stimme.
Aber es gibt dann, also am Ende gibt es ja eine Gerechtigkeit für jeden,
der über 18 oder jetzt bei der Europawahl über 16 ist, darf wählen.
Und diese Gerechtigkeit ist ja eine, wo die Gleichheit der Stimme geachtet wird.
Es geht ja hier darum, dass Leute dann,
Nur weil sie Kinder haben, mehrere Stimmen bekommen.
Und die Stimmen geben sie ja nicht, das ist ja nicht wie, ich lege 100 Euro
für mein Kind monatlich an.
Nee, hast du ja nicht, die gibst du ja aus.
Nein, ich sage, das ist ja nicht stellvertretend. Das ist ja nicht 100 Euro,
die lege ich da an und die kriegt das Kind, wenn es mal groß ist,
sondern ich kann einfach meinen.
Traust du den Wählern nicht? Natürlich traue ich den Wählern nicht.
Na, wir haben Veit Selk gelesen, ich wäre ja völlig irre, wenn ich dem Wähler vertraue.
Wir kommen gleich auf die Bildungserfolge zurück.
Ja, ja, also es sieht überall düster aus und ich bin auch mittlerweile bereit
zu sagen, ja, wenn dieses Präsidentschaftsduell unter Siebenjährigen stattgefunden
hätte, wäre es vernünftiger gelaufen.
Das wäre besser gewesen. Die Frage, gibt es heute Pudding zum Mittag oder nicht?
Das sind übrigens Fragen für Vierjährige. Siebenjährige stellen wirklich gute Fragen.
Ich habe ein Kinderbuch jetzt geschrieben aus den Gründen, weil ich nicht sage,
Kinder sind doof, sondern weil ich sage, Kinder sind vermutlich,
gerade was solche Fragen wie Ungleichheit anbelangt, viel intelligenter.
Also du musst nämlich jetzt jemanden, der schon siebenmal FDP gewählt hat, erstmal austreiben,
darüber nachzudenken, dass es einfach richtig ist, dass von Generation zu Generation
Vermögen wächst und weitergegeben wird.
Während jetzt jemand, der zehn Jahre alt ist, diese ganze Ideologie noch gar
nicht geschluckt hat und dann vielleicht sagt,
das ist aber ungerecht, warum hat denn dann plötzlich jetzt mehr,
nur weil dessen Großvater vor 100 Jahren mal das und das gemacht hat.
Also Kinder verstehen das intuitiv viel besser.
Dann müsste man eher nochmal Ich würde sagen.
Wir lassen mal die Hörer entscheiden Ja, wir lassen die entscheiden Schickt
gerne E-Mails, also schickt E-Mails Auf der Seite haben wir unten mail.neue20er.de
Diese E-Mails kriegen wir beide,
Und wir lassen Claude das dann auswerten, wie das Stimmungsbild ist.
Okay, ja, ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Also ihr könnt freischreiben zum Thema, ihr müsst nicht irgendwelche,
wir sagen jetzt nicht, sagt ja, sagt nein oder so, sondern Claude macht das dann schon.
Claude versteht euch nämlich alle, schickt ganze Sätze zum Thema.
Gut, wie er es nicht machen sollte, das führen wir jetzt vor.
Also wir hören jetzt einen dreiminütigen Clip. Ich will es aber wirklich machen.
Also Scholz hatte jetzt angefangen zu sagen, ja, wir hatten geglaubt und es
ist aber anders. Er ist aber noch nicht zu Ende mit seiner Rede.
Er wurde jetzt schon darauf hingewiesen, ja, aber die jungen Leute sind ja auch
nicht mehr so vermögend wie ihre Eltern oder Großeltern.
Scholz sagt, wir müssen auch eigentlich mal konkret und das ist die Antwort.
That are important for them. And this is on the one hand, I'd say,
labor rights, it's a social welfare state, I will not come back to it,
because I've mentioned it often enough in our debate.
But it's also about security.
Is there an international order we work for, which is something you can rely on?
I think, for instance, it would be very useful if we could establish again something
like north-south policy, which was established by Willy Brandt.
Which was really a big success, and we have to come back to it.
We have to develop a policy that is equal-footed with the rising countries of
the global south, which have the best rights to be influential in the future.
And we have to find a way to explain our people that in the world of 10 billion,
the European Union with its then 4 to 500 million inhabitants will be relevant.
We will have a chance to defend what's important for us, Demokratie,
Regeln der Glauben, soziale Markte, Wirtschaft, um sie nur zu nennen, in diesem Welt.
Aber es ist nicht ein Threat für uns, dass es eine ökonomisch und politisch
erfolgreiche 400 Millionen Nationen von Indonesiern oder Indienern gibt.
Das ist alles Schwachsinn.
Was er sagt.
Er beantwortet immer noch die Frage nach den jungen Wählern.
Wie kann das sein?
Ich meine, wir haben 40 Sekunden.
Wir haben uns eben über beiden lustig gemacht. Das ist nicht besser.
Jetzt kommen wir mal bei der Sicherheitspolitik.
Jetzt kommt noch gleich dein Thema.
That you can go on every street without having fears.
And it's the same when we discuss the question of economic development.
And this must be a question of us, which is not an unimportant aspect of the future life.
People have fears. If in a world with, I named them, artificial intelligence, for instance.
Artificial intelligence. Es wird doch einfach nur noch irgendwas rausgesprudelt.
Ja, das was ich gerade sagte, also diese soziologische, subkutane Grundlogik,
wir haben ökonomische Ungleichheiten durch Eigentumsverteilung,
wie auch immer, seit Jahrzehnten, also zehntausenden Jahren in der Menschheit
und haben dann immer versucht politisch darauf zu antworten,
um das wieder einzuhegen.
Was ja einfach nur bedeutet, und das muss man dann nicht verstehen, sondern jeder fühlt es.
Christopher Nolan könnte einen Film darüber machen, das würde ihn so langweilen,
weil das so einfach wäre, das darzustellen.
Junge Menschen, von denen eben gesagt wurde, sie sind ärmer als ihre Eltern
und ihnen wird auch ein bisschen mitgeteilt, dass sich daran wahrscheinlich
wenig ändert, weil ihr seht ja, wie die Welt ist und so.
Die fragen sich die ganze Zeit, okay, ökonomisch schaffe ich es nicht.
Wie hilft mir die Politik jetzt aus der Patsche?
Und die politische Antwort ist dann, ja, ich gehe jetzt nochmal in meine Exit-Tabelle,
wir hatten uns gestern in der Gremiumssitzung 16 Punkte rausgeschrieben,
die wir auf jeden Fall ansprechen wollten, im Sinne von, um euch zu verdeutlichen,
dass wir für euch handeln und dann kommt nichts bei rum.
Und da sitzen diese jungen Menschen da und verstehen, achso,
die Politik hat nichts für mich im Angebot, um diese ökonomischen Asymmetrien auszugleichen.
Ich werde immer der ökonomische Verlierer bleiben, die Politik hilft mir hier nicht.
Das ist die Antwort, die er jetzt gegeben hat. Politik hat nichts für dich im Angebot.
Sie versteht dein Problem nicht, sie möchte es nicht akzeptieren,
dass das überhaupt problematisiert werden muss. Fertig.
Er könnte auch sagen, mir sind die jungen Menschen egal, bitte stellen sie eine
andere Frage. Die Moderatorin fragt noch einmal nach.
Und do you think these are greater fears for the young? Do you think that's
why they've turned to the far right?
I think this is, the young are not supporting the far right.
Some of them did when they vote, as the elder did as well. This is my view on this question.
So I would say, we have to discuss these topics and develop a perspective where
things are running into the right direction.
So my answer to everyone should be, and I'm working for it,
yes, we will have artificial intelligence, it will change our economies,
we will have a different way of wealth, we will be able to control it,
that we are not ruled by these systems.
Also ich spekuliere jetzt nur, aber wir haben diese Claude-Diskussion zum Thema
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt.
Claude sagt Wohnbau, weil machbar, keine internationalen Verstrickungen,
jeder muss wohnen, es ist für jeden da, es ist total praktikabel und so weiter.
Wenn ich jetzt diese Antwort hier transkribiere und Claude als Nachfrage in
diesem Thread sage, das ist die Antwort von Olaf Scholz, warum wird sie nicht funktionieren?
Claude wird sagen, bist du bescheuert? Ich habe es doch oben geschrieben.
Es steht doch alles schon drin. Wieso schickst du mir hier den dümmstmöglichen
Kommentar von, ach das ist dein Kanzler, ja gut, okay.
Er sitzt einer Philosophin gegenüber und sagt, er will konkrete Politik,
wir können jetzt nicht nur über abstrakte Visionen sprechen und er bringt nicht
eine einzige Sache mit, bei der er sagen kann, das haben wir jetzt demnächst
vor, das wird den Jungen oder den Alten oder sonst wem helfen.
Es gibt nichts, was er hat, es ist nur die Verwaltung des Status Quo,
er wird dann noch gefragt,
was er von Keir Starmer hält, den findet er auch toll, da freut er sich drauf,
also ein anderer Technokrat und was wir doch jetzt gerade sehr gut erleben können,
ist wie diese herrschenden Politiker, Biden,
Scholz und andere, einfach signalisieren durch ihr Auftreten und ihr Sprechen, ihr seid uns egal.
Und mir ist jetzt was aufgefallen in den Interviews, die Thilo mit Pranko Milanovic
und Adam Tooze geführt hat, dass beide da gefragt werden, was sie wählen und
Milanovic sagt, ja, ich habe eine Green Card.
Ja, aber ob er dann in Serbien wählt, ja, ich habe vielleicht ein- oder zweimal
gewählt, weiß ich nicht, also wähle ich nicht. Dann wird Adam Trues dazu befragt.
Adam Trues sagt, ja, ich habe ja keine amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ich würde aber auch keinen der beiden wählen.
Und über UK will ich gar nicht reden.
Wen soll ich dann wählen? Ich kann doch nicht Keir Starmer wählen.
Also da sieht man eigentlich, dass die Leute, wenn sie zu der Elite da gehören, sagen.
Die haben ja kein Interesse an den Menschen, aber ich zeige jetzt auch kein
Interesse denen gegenüber.
Ja, es ist, ich habe ja eben schon versucht deutlich zu machen,
wenn politische Diskussionen laufen, einfach nicht dazu äußern.
Es ignorieren, nicht mal rezipieren.
Ist ja schwierig, wenn man so einen Podcast macht.
Ja, aber dasselbe hier.
Es hat auch meine Laune gestern sehr runtergezogen, als ich das schneiden musste.
Ja, wenn jemand vor mir sitzt wie Precht, Tuus, Milanovic und die gehen nicht wählen.
Gehe ich nicht in Kontroverse, sondern versuche ich zu verstehen,
warum die das nicht machen.
Und alleine, wenn ich das jetzt in meinem Kopf durchdenke, sage ich mir,
ich muss das gar nicht diskutieren. Das ist mir total logisch.
Das ist mir total schlüssig.
Ja, nach dem, was wir jetzt hier alles gehört haben.
Ja, ich meine, diese Leute haben Einfluss über Publikum, das sie erreichen.
Sie haben besondere Zugänge, um nochmal zu informieren, Leute,
die wirklich handlungsfähig sind und so.
Warum sollen die jetzt an einem Sonntag sich einreihen und mit 60 Millionen
nochmal ihre eine Stimme abgeben? Es macht wirklich keinen Sinn.
Und sehr viele Menschen denken so, und zwar völlig zu Recht.
Diese Politik kann meine ökonomischen Asymmetrien, die ich sehr genau beschreiben
kann, nicht beantworten.
Obwohl doch die Antwort so einfach wäre.
Wir können ja mal durch simulieren. Wir wären so der Kanzler.
Wir wissen jedes Jahr 800.000 Schulabgänger.
Was könnte man für die machen, um den guten Staat ins Leben zu erleichtern?
Naja, jeder kriegt einfach 100.000 Euro überwiesen.
Fertig. Warum machen wir das nicht? Weil der Bundestag nicht entschieden hat,
dass wir das machen. Gibt es noch einen anderen Grund?
Keinen sinnvollen. Jedenfalls. Man kann auch ein paar Sachen irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, dann sind wir immer wieder bei so einem entweder Klassismus oder
Rassismus, wir gönnen eben irgendwem was nicht, du gönnst ja den Kindern keine Wählerstimme.
Man gönnt dann einfach dem Nachbar, der ist ja eh scheiße, der soll jetzt auch
100.000 Euro kriegen, nö, dann lieber gar keiner, bevor der noch 100.000 Euro kriegt.
Das ist das Einzige, also diese menschliche Natur, deren Sicht Rutger Breschmann
im Grunde gut, man könnte ja nochmal von einer utopistischen Sicht aus das durchdenken
und dann feststellen, im Grunde schlecht.
Wir gönnen es uns einfach nicht. Aber der Weg aus dieser ökonomischen beobachteten
Asymmetrie, ich fühle mich hier wirklich aussortiert, ein Deplorable.
Wie kriegt man jetzt hin, dass ich nicht Trump wähle, dass ich nicht far right
in Europa wähle? So schwer ist es eigentlich nicht.
Naja, aber was wir doch erleben ist im Journalismus, dass da ganz ähnlich gesprochen wird.
Man redet ja auch da über die jungen Leute als so eine Verfügungsmasse und die
soll sich dann bitte dort einpassen, wo man sich das gerade vorstellt.
Oder wir haben ja dann die Debatten jetzt auch, das geht ja auch weit über so ein CDU-Lager hinaus,
dass man schon eigentlich, ist noch nicht so massiv formuliert wie jetzt ein
Dobrindt, aber doch nahelegt, liebe ukrainischen Männer, kämpft mal anständig
weiter, denn es geht hier um Freiheit, verdammt nochmal.
Und das sagt man ja auch aus sehr angenehmen Podcast-Studios heraus.
Ja, vor allem, wir haben diese Europameisterschaft und jedes Polizeiauto,
und man sieht hier in den Spielstätten wirklich viele, haben diese Trauerbeflaggung,
will ich nicht sagen, sondern die schwarzen Bänder an die Tür griffen.
Jeder deutsche Polizist trauert wochenlang über ein Menschenleben und wir sagen, völlig zu Recht.
Wir haben gleichzeitig eine politische Diskussion, in der wir sagen,
also diese 100.000 Leute, die haben ihren Aufentrecht hier verwirkt,
denen können wir gerade noch eine Waffe in die Hand geben und dann geht es ab
zurück in die Ukraine und seinen Krieg führen.
Während gleichzeitig Julian Assange aus dem Gefängnis kommt.
Und die einzige Logik, die zentrale Logik, können wir ja mal kurz spielen.
Das ist nämlich dann, also wir haben eine ökonomische Asymmetrie,
die nicht aufgefangen wird, weil die Politik versagt, dann juristische.
Und es schaukelt sich dann hoch in Kriege.
Ja.
Was, warum Kriege? Julian Assange hier, ich habe mir diesen Clip,
der kursiert dir jetzt wieder nochmal rausgezogen, der ist wirklich,
da steckt im Grunde alles drin.
One of the hopeful things that I have discovered is that there is a lot of hope.
Ist, dass fast jeder Krieg, der in den letzten 50 Jahren stattgefunden hat,
ein Resultat von Medien-Lügen gewesen ist.
Die Medien hätten es stoppen können, wenn sie tief in die Rechte gesucht hätten,
wenn sie nicht die Regierungs-Propaganda reprintiert hätten,
hätten sie es stoppen können. Aber was bedeutet das?
Das bedeutet, dass die Bevölkerung keine Kriege mag. Und die Bevölkerung muss
in die Kriege gefühlt werden.
So, Menschen gehen nicht von sich aus in Kriege. Ja.
Wenn sie es doch machen, wurden sie belogen. Und zwar gilt das für jeden einzelnen Krieg.
So immer, wenn jemand losgeschickt wird, um jemanden zu töten und akzeptiert,
das ist ja nur ein politischer Maßstab, Irgendwer muss irgendwas verteidigen.
Dann ist es immer eine Lüge und dann sagt er dazu, eine mediale Lüge.
Man könnte ja durchaus sagen, der Dobrindt ist halt der Dobrindt.
Keine Ahnung, warum diese 70.000 Leute in München den jetzt unbedingt wählen
müssen, damit er da in seinen Wahlkreis oder was auch immer.
Nur irgendwer transportiert ja deutschlandweit, was Dobrindt sagt zum Thema
ukrainische Männer und dass sie alles verwirkt haben hier, wenn sie nicht bereit
sind für unsere Freiheit zu sterben.
Und da es hier um einen Kriegskontext geht, ist das per se immer eine Lüge.
Und Journalisten, die das transportieren, lügen dann auch.
Die tricksen uns hier als Verfügungsmasse oder was auch immer.
Aber vielleicht sollten wir dieses Kristallisieren noch ernster nehmen, noch härter.
Alles immer runterbrechen auf einfachste Logiken.
Ja, das ist ja schon, wie du das jetzt gerade deutlich gemacht hast an diesem
Beispiel, Dobrindt lügt.
Aber was ist eigentlich mit den Medien, die das so übernehmen?
Die machen einfach mit.
Wir haben Pro und Cons in den Medien.
Brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht für Männer und Frauen oder brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht
nur für Männer? Das ist Pro und Contra.
Das ist die Kontroverse, die jetzt diskutiert wird.
Es ist nicht mehr, brauchen wir eine Wehrpflicht oder nicht,
sondern nur noch alle, alle, alle oder nur alle Männer.
Das sind Debatten und das ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht, das ist genau so in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung erschienen.
Ja, ich habe mir das gestern, also ich habe gedacht, das kann doch alles nicht wahr sein.
Dieser Ole Jarius wurde jetzt freigesprochen. Ich sage mal freigesprochen,
er wurde natürlich nicht freigesprochen, sondern es gab ein Beschlussurteil,
er ist medizinisch nicht in der Lage zu,
ich muss unbedingt diesen Titel des Politik-Podcasts.
Also wir haben einen Banker, der 82 Jahre alt ist. Wir haben jetzt gesehen,
82 Jahre, das ist schon ganz schön viel.
Der sitzt vor Gericht, nicht weil er Steuern hinterzogen hat,
sondern weil er mutmaßlich 42 Millionen Euro aus der Finanzkasse seines Finanzamts
an sich hat überweisen lassen.
Mit der trickreichen Begründung, das steht mir zu.
Und ich sage, nee, das hat doch jemand anders schon gekriegt.
Nee, das steht mir zu. Ich habe hier einen Zettel, da steht das.
Ja, okay, dann überweisen wir Ihnen das.
So, dann wurde später festgestellt, nachdem man vorher dachte,
das wird ja keiner machen, oder? Es gibt ja erstmal keinen Straftatbestand.
Dann kam raus, doch, es ist jetzt ein Straftatbestand.
Also sitzt er vor Gericht. Seit acht Jahren läuft dieses Verfahren.
2011 kam das ja so auf, jetzt ist es 2024.
Und jetzt stellt das Gericht fest, ja, wir haben das mal durchkalkuliert,
der Gutachter sagt, er kann nur 45 Minuten pro Verhandlungstag verhandeln.
Die Beweisaufnahme würde aber noch so und so lange dauern, also wären das drei
Jahre, ist ihm nicht zuzumuten, deswegen jetzt aus gesundheitlichen Gründen freigesprochen.
Also in Anführungszeichen, aber ich sage trotzdem freigesprochen.
Denn gesunde Menschenverstand würde sagen, Momentchen mal, Die Beweisaufnahme
dauert so lange, wer könnte denn die beschleunigen? Vielleicht der Beschuldigte?
Könnte der einfach mal ein bisschen mithelfen, dass es dann eben nicht drei
Jahre dauert, wenn er darunter so leidet? Ich hätte hier schon gerne einen Abschluss des Verfahrens.
Denn es geht ja hier um insgesamt, er ist ja nur einer von mehreren tausend
Beschuldigten, 30, vielleicht 40 Milliarden Euro, während uns die CDU gerade
erzählt, wir wollen jetzt 170 Millionen sparen durch Bürgergeldtransallierungen.
Ja, also hier haben wir eine wirklich harte ökonomische Asymmetrie im System,
die politisch und wie ich skandalös jetzt feststelle, auch juristisch nicht aufgefangen wird.
Das ist für mich, also das was ja jetzt stattfand mit diesem Olearius-Prozess,
gerade im Sinne von noch drei Monate und vielleicht hätten wir dann auch Scholz
als Zeugen da gehabt und so. Eine der größten Ungerechtigkeiten und auch Frechheiten, die stattfand.
Das war also am 26. Juni.
Am 27. Juni veröffentlicht der Deutschlandfunk den Politik-Podcast Nummer 374
zu den aktuellen politischen Themen.
Thema Bürgergeld stützen oder stutzen.
Und das ist einfach skandalös.
War ja auch Thema.
Also das ist nicht zu rechtfertigen.
Im letzten Presseclub auch wieder. Jede Woche ist das das Top-Thema. Das wird gesetzt.
Wenn jemand für 40 Millionen, die er mutmaßt, also er hat sie überwiesen gekriegt,
die Frage ist jetzt, mutmaßt er sich zu Recht oder nicht.
Und wir wissen, nee, das wurde schon, also es ist eigentlich alles klar so.
Und er kommt dann frei, weil, nee, ich habe mich am Prozess ja nicht beteiligt.
Und weil ich mich nicht beteiligt habe, dauert das alles so lange,
dass es mir nicht zuzumuten ist.
Ich bin frei. Also wir kommen nicht zu einem normativen, ihm zu irgendeiner
Handlung zwingenden Urteil, weil er einfach keine Lust hat. Es tut ihm nicht gut.
Er hat seinem Arzt gesagt, ich brauche eine Krankschreibung,
aber er hat eine nicht gekriegt. Und der mediale Diskurs parallel dazu,
während wir 50 Milliarden im Haushalt suchen, ist Bürgergeld stützen oder stutzen.
Das geht einfach wirklich nicht, liebe Journalisten.
Das ist kurz vor Bürgerkriegserklärung.
Das ist durchgegangen, ist das ja so. Also wir hatten ja im letzten Podcast doch das Beispiel,
dass dann tatsächlich Scholz mal einen höheren Mindestlohn angesprochen hat
und sofort kommt Micky Beisenherzen in seinen Podcast und sagt,
muss der das dann jetzt auch noch sagen?
Dieser Stress. Also wir haben hier ganz schiefe Diskussionen, das ist alles nicht gut.
Und wir kommen erst noch zum Bildungsbericht. Wir haben ja noch ein bisschen
Scholz haben wir noch, oder?
Wir hören jetzt auf damit. Mir reicht es.
Kommen wir zu ernsthaften Problemen. Die Jugend, die haben wir ja gerade schon angesprochen.
Es gibt alle zwei Jahre einen Bildung in Deutschland Bildungsbericht,
kurz vorm Bildungsbericht.
Der wurde jetzt wieder veröffentlicht, einmal in kompakter und ausführlicher Form.
Und interessanterweise, Phoenix hat es nicht übertragen. Team Junge Naiv war vor Ort.
Und auf der Webseite des Ministeriums gibt es ohne weitere Angabe ein Video
der Bundespressekonferenz dazu.
Also ich weiß nicht genau. Für mich wurde das versteckt als Thema.
Deswegen holen wir es uns hier raus.
Wir hatten ja einige Themen bisher schon mal behandelt, die wir jetzt aufgreifen.
Leseleistung. Also die Analphabeten, die Selke uns aufgeschrieben hat.
Die Leseleistungen, steht im
Bericht, sind sowohl im Primar- als auch im Sekundarbereich 1 rückläufig.
Bei wachsendem Anteil leserschwacher SchülerInnen.
Also was diesen strukturellen Alphabetismus, der ja 17 Millionen Menschen betrifft in Deutschland.
Zwischen 18 und 64.
Das ist im Grunde jeder dritte Wähler. Ja, ist viel.
Also man muss es nochmal, gerade deutlich machen, für die, die den Salon nicht gehört haben.
Wir haben über das Buch von Veit Selck gesprochen, Demokratiedämmerung,
und da zitiert er eine Studie, die jetzt auch wieder aufgegriffen wurde medial,
die besagt, dass 17 Millionen der Menschen,
18- bis 64-Jährigen auf dem Niveau von Viertklässlern oder darunter lesen,
schreiben, Texte verstehen können.
Weshalb jetzt die Tagesschau auch einmal am Tag in einfacher Sprache gesendet wird.
Da wird dann deutlich gemacht, ja, das richtet sich ja an Leute,
die kognitive Schwierigkeiten haben oder Leute, die frisch nach Deutschland
gekommen sind und noch nicht so gut Deutsch können.
Ja, aber das ist nicht die größte Gruppe. Die größte Gruppe ist wirklich die,
die da von Selke auch beschrieben wird, die eigentlich gut lesen und schreiben können müsste.
Also wo offenbar es andere Probleme
gibt und die können wir einfach bildungspolitische Probleme nennen.
Genau, wir stellen ja zum Beispiel fest, wir hatten ja über die NEETs gesprochen,
N-I-E-T, auch ein Grundbegriff, Not in Education, Employment or Training.
Die werden ja auch aufgegriffen.
2022 verließen bundesweit wieder mehr Jugendliche ohne Schule den Abschluss.
Es waren jetzt 6,9 Prozent eines Jahrgangs, also sieben Prozent.
Plus, das wird im Bericht deutlich und auch in der Bundespressekonferenz,
es gibt eine Dunkelziffer, die da sehr beachtenswert ist.
Ja, gerade schon TPA-Frage an Herrn Prof. Marz.
Die Anzahl der Schulabbrecher würde mich nochmal interessieren.
Da haben Sie ja 52.300 oder so.
Können Sie das mal erklären, was an dieser Zahl so relevant ist,
wenn man das zum Beispiel im Vergleich zu 11 Millionen Schülern insgesamt und
den Trend der vergangenen Jahre da mal skizzieren und warum das Ihnen auch wichtig
ist, weil Sie das ja im Bericht auch haben?
Ja, vielen Dank. Die Zahl ist aus verschiedenen Gründen wichtig.
Nämlich einerseits transportiert die Zahl noch nicht die gesamte Geschichte,
weil hier nur diejenigen jungen Menschen gezählt werden, die am Ende des Schuljahres
die Schule ohne Abschluss verlassen.
Diejenigen, die das unterjährig machen, sind in der Statistik nicht enthalten.
Wir können auch nicht verlässlich sagen, wie groß der Anteil ist.
Es gibt eine Dunkelziffer und selbst ohne Dunkelziffer verlassen am Ende des
Schuljahres 50.000, also mehr als 50.000 die Schule ohne Abschluss.
Wir haben es auf einer Folie gehabt in der Käs letzte Woche.
Bürgergeldverweigerer, die dann wirklich Sanktionen bekommen, 13.000.
Das sind die Totalverweigerer.
Unter der politischen Diskussion, die sollten wir ja auch mal für den Arbeitsmarkt
fit machen, da müssen wir jetzt mal richtig ran und so, wird ewig breit diskutiert.
Und mehr als dreimal so viele Leute verlassen die Schule ohne Abschluss,
sind also noch jung, könnten noch 40 Jahre vor sich haben im Berufsleben. Kein Thema.
Nirgendwo Thema. Das kann doch alles gar nicht sein.
Und von denen ist ja niemand verloren. Müsste niemand verloren sein.
Ja, von denen ist niemand verloren. Die sind da, die sind geboren, die sind am Leben.
Mit denen müsste man einfach nur, wir haben es ja besprochen,
win-win-win. Das ist für alle ein Gewinn, für die Gesellschaft,
für sie, für die Familien.
Denn die Sache ist ja, es gibt sicherlich einige Totalverweigerer,
die sind nicht mehr einzugliedern.
Jetzt kann man sagen, wir sind ein reiches Land, wir müssen damit leben,
dass es diese Art der Dissidenz gibt und dann ist das so.
Nur sich damit jetzt zu beschäftigen, solche volkswirtschaftlichen Aufwallungen
zu machen, bis man die doch noch in irgendeinen Beruf bekommt,
ist völlig irrsinnig, während ich mit 18-Jährigen grundsätzlich was machen kann.
Die müssen nur ins 1 zu 1 Betreuungsverhältnis, sodass man halt sieht,
um die kümmert sich jemand.
So, also Leseleistungen rückläufig, Schulabgänger ohne Abschluss werden mehr.
Rückgänge bei Weiterbildungsaktivitäten. Nur 42 Prozent der Betriebe in Deutschland
nehmen an Weiterbildungsaktivitäten teil.
Also nicht mal die Hälfte, während wir hier einen auf Wissensgesellschaft,
lebenslanges Lernen und so.
Findet alles nicht statt. Gab es denn mehr Geld für die Bildung?
Es werden jetzt Zahlen genannt. Ich will nur daran erinnern.
Also die Inflation 10 Prozent plus.
In diesem Zeitraum, alle zwei Jahre machen die diese Studie.
Eine Entwicklungslinie, die
wir ausmachen konnten, ist, dass für Bildung mehr Geld ausgegeben wird.
Dass dieses zum Teil aber sich darauf zurückführen lässt, dass die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung der letzten Jahre, wenn man Corona ausschließt, sehr positiv war.
Der Anteil am Bruttoinlandsprodukt hat sich dagegen nur um 0,2 Prozentpunkte erhöht.
Das ist insofern ein wichtiger Befund, weil einerseits die Bedarfe für Bildung,
Stichwort frühe Bildung, Stichwort Ausbau vom Ganztag, aber auch Ausfinanzierung von Weiterbildung,
in den letzten Jahren gestiegen sind und steigen werden und die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung nach Corona sich in Deutschland noch nicht so erholt hat,
wie das im europäischen Vergleich der Fall ist.
So, das Bildungssystem wächst also einfach mit dem BIP.
Während wir in den letzten zwei Jahren ja Zuwanderung im in Deutschland nie
gesehenen Rekordmaßstab mit
mehr als zwei Millionen Menschen pro Jahr 2022 den Ukraine-Krieg hatten.
Was ja bedeutet, wenn mehr als die Hälfte der Migrationsströme Minderjährige betrifft.
Ja, Frauen mit Kindern kommen.
Frauen mit Kindern, dass die in dieses Bildungssystem reinrutschen.
So.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass man an den Zahlen sehen kann, dass die irgendwie
aufgefangen wurden. Nein.
Aber es ist wirklich haarsträubend. Hier hören wir, Christine Streichert-Klivoth, sie ist in Saarland.
Zuständige Kultusministerin und gleichzeitig Vorsitzende der KMK,
also der Kultusministerkonferenz zum Thema, ja, sind ganz schön viele mehr Aufgaben.
Wir haben viele Herausforderungen, das bestätigt der Bildungsbericht aufs Neue.
Nicht nur in quantitativen Zahlen haben wir mehr Schülerinnen und Schüler im System.
Das ist etwas, was zunächst mal sehr positiv auch zu bewerten ist.
Das heißt, wir haben weiterhin junge Menschen, die in unsere Bildungseinrichtungen kommen.
Wir stellen aber auch fest, dass wir eine zunehmende Heterogenität haben.
Dass die Gesellschaft sich wandelt und dass das mit zusätzlichen Herausforderungen verbunden ist.
Aber was ist das überhaupt für eine merkwürdige Formulierung?
Es steht einem ja nicht frei, in die Schule zu gehen oder was anderes zu machen,
sondern man ist jung und geht in die Schule, oder?
Ja, eigentlich hat man eine Schulpflicht und so. Und ich dachte,
wir hätten das mal diskutiert, als irgendwie alle dann plötzlich freitags demonstrieren
gingen für zwei Stunden oder so.
Ja, weil sie sagt, es ist schön, dass so viele das Angebot wahrnehmen.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass man stattdessen als junger Mensch auch was anderes machen könnte.
Ja gut, es gibt ein paar Freiwillige, also wie bei Thomas zum Beispiel da in
Bamberg, man möchte gern eine Hochschulzulassung, wird aber im bayerischen Abiesystem
aussortiert, ist dann volljährig, hat keine Schulpflicht mehr,
kann aber auf die Oberschule gehen und da noch und dann ist natürlich freiwillig so.
Aber ich hatte nicht den Eindruck, dass ihr diese Leute meint.
Ne, es ist eigentlich total Banane, das so zu sagen, wir halten auch nur von
ihr fest, sie sagte, es sind mehr.
Und es ist heterogener.
Und es ist heterogener, also mehr in der Zahl und mehr in der Qualität,
der man sich da stellen muss.
In der Gesamtentwicklung ist festzuhalten, gegenüber 2012 ist um 7% der Anteil
der Menschen gewachsen, die diese Bildungseinrichtungen in Anspruch nehmen,
also Kindertageseinrichtungen ab, also auch die U6 und U3,
allgemeinbildende Schulen aller Arten, berufliche Schulen, Hochschulen und so weiter.
Wir sind in Deutschland bei 17,9 Millionen Menschen, die also im Bildungssystem zugegen sind.
Wir wollen natürlich, dass alle so durch das Bildungssystem rauschen,
dass sie am Ende für die Volkswirtschaft nützlich, ich sage es ganz ausdrücklich,
denn es macht keinen Sinn zu argumentieren, nee, ich finde es nicht gut für
mehr Menschen oder Verwertungslogik. Es ist immer Win-Win.
Also wenn wir den volkswirtschaftlichen Verwertungslogik folgen,
ist das immer gut für den Zögling, der da reinrutscht.
Er wird umso erfolgreicher für die Volkswirtschaft verwendbar sein,
umso mehr er da beiträgt und Produktivität schafft, umso mehr wird er auch verdienen
und so weiter und so fort.
Also da kann man sich einfach gemütlich dranhängen an das Argument,
da gibt es jetzt gar keine moralischen Gesichtspunkte, warum man das nicht tun sollte.
Denn hier kann man es ja auch wirklich mal direkt an die individuelle Situation binden.
Absolut.
Es leuchtet ja jedem sofort ein, je mehr ich in mein Kind investiere an Zeit
und Geld für eine Ausbildung,
desto mehr Chancen wird es haben am Arbeitsmarkt, desto besser qualifiziert
wird es sein. Niemand würde dem widersprechen.
Auf volkswirtschaftlicher Ebene denkt man, also wenn wir da jetzt nochmal Millionen
locker machen, wie finanzieren wir das denn eigentlich?
Ja, deswegen ja auch nochmal mein Plädoyer, Kindergrundsicherung braucht kein Konzept.
Gebt den Familien einfach Geld, die wissen schon, wie sie es verwenden können für die Kinder.
So, damit aber alle erfolgreich oben rauspurzeln, müssen wir irgendwie,
das ist eine deutsche Eigenart, mit diesem soziale Herkunftsding umgehen.
Der Bildungsbericht ist dazu ganz interessant. Es ist ein recht komplizierter
Satz, ich lese ihn mal vor, der da drin steht.
Der Bildungserwerb ebenso wie die Wahl eines Berufs sind nach wie vor stark
an die familialen Gegebenheiten einerseits und an die damit zusammenhängenden
Bildungs- und Erwerbsbiografien andererseits gebunden.
Okay, brechen wir das mal runter auf einen politischen Wunsch.
Wir hören Bettina Stark-Watzinger.
Wir wollen nicht länger hinnehmen, dass der Zusammenhang von sozialer Herkunft
und Bildungserfolg in Deutschland überdurchschnittlich hoch ist.
Und deswegen ist es ein Auftrag an uns alle,
Und deshalb setzen wir uns mit aller Kraft dafür ein, die Startchancen für die
Kinder und Jugendlichen in unserem Land nachhaltig zu verbessern,
für mehr Chancengerechtigkeit und wir wollen zeigen, dass es geht.
So, sie wollte unbedingt das Wort Startchancen unterbringen,
weil sie ja ein Startchancenprojekt hat, 20 Milliarden Euro für 4000 Schulen.
Und ich sage, okay, schon ganz gut, aber da fehlt doch noch eine Null,
so ungefähr. So, jetzt hat sie gesagt, wir wollen und so weiter,
wir kennen ja alle das Problem, es sollte immer besser werden,
es ist ein bisschen blöd, dass es noch nicht erreicht ist. Die Zahlen sind wie folgt.
Ich lese jetzt den Original-Bildungsbericht, wie er dieser Expertenkommission
geschrieben, fürs Bildungsministerium der Bundesregierung vorgelegt wurde.
Nur 25 von 100 Nicht-Akademikerinnen-Kindern nehmen ein Studium auf.
Stammen Kinder aus einer Akademiker-Innen-Familie sind es 78 von 100 Kindern. Also 25 zu 78.
Auch hier vermeintes und vermientes Gelände.
Es muss nicht jeder studieren. Und wer nicht studiert, hat auch jedes Recht
dazu, eine Berufsausbildung zu machen.
Nur, diese Zahlen sind für uns Indikatoren.
Ja. Wenn die nicht kongruent aufeinander liegen, sondern mit 25 zu 78 weit auseinander,
haben wir es hier mit Disbalancen im System zu tun.
Ja.
Alle anderen Fairness-Gesichtspunkte würden sich nämlich, wenn sie fair wären,
statistisch ausgleichen.
Dann würden wir einfach sagen, wir haben 50 Prozent Abiturienten,
die kommen zu 50 Prozent aus diesen und zu 50 aus diesen Familien.
Das wäre einfach, weil Kinder werden biologisch gleich geboren.
Alles andere sind soziologisch, sozialisierungs- und pädagogische und eben politische
und ökonomische Sachen, die da einwirken.
So, was für Bettina Stark-Watzinger heißt, sie bindet es auf diese Losung.
Bildung ist die Zukunft unseres Landes, individuell für jedes Einzelne,
für jeden Einzelnen, aber auch für unsere Gesellschaft insgesamt und deswegen präsentiert sie das.
Mögliche Bildung für alle.
Aber sie sagt an keiner Stelle wie.
Es ist so schlimm. Es ist wirklich eine schlimmere Bildungsministerin als diese
komische Betsy DeVos, die als Milliardärin Trumps Pseudo-Bildungsministerin
wurde. Das ist wirklich ganz gruselig.
In dem Text, bei gleichen Leistungen, also selbst wenn man jetzt sagt,
okay, die Leute haben es geschafft, bis an die Grenze, wo dann entschieden wird,
du machst jetzt hier Bildungsweg und so weiter.
Also jetzt können wirklich nur noch ökonomische oder die Familie sagt so,
ich kenne mich da nicht aus in der Uni, willst du das echt machen und so,
ich kann dir da gar nicht helfen als Mutter.
Bei gleichen Leistungen also, bei gleichen Leistungen und Noten,
gehen 44% der Kinder aus sozioökonomisch benachteiligten Familien an ein Gymnasium über.
Also es ist das harte Aussortieren in der Viertelklasse, während es unter Kindern
aus privilegierten Familien 58% sind.
Also hier haben wir es auch immer noch, selbst wenn alles sonst stimmt,
immer noch mit so einer krassen Ungerechtigkeit zu tun.
So, könnte man diese Benachteiligung fördern? Ja, es ist ein volkswirtschaftliches Nullsummspiel.
Das muss man hier immer ganz deutlich betonen. Wir haben so wenig Nachwuchs,
dass kein armes Kind, das in ein Gymnasium kommt, irgendeinem Reichen den Platz da wegnimmt oder so.
Wir haben Ballungszentren, wo manchmal eine Schule fehlt, dann wird eine gegründet.
Das funktioniert gerade hier in Frankfurt, finde ich, jetzt gerade sehr gut.
Gut, das ist dann schon, wir könnten alle so weit wie möglich fördern,
niemandem wäre was weggenommen, plus volkswirtschaftlicher Winn,
privater Winn, also wirklich Winn, Winn auf allen Ebenen.
Mit 32% erhalten deutlich weniger Kinder aus sozioökonomisch benachteiligten
Familien eine Gymnasialempfehlung als jene aus privilegierten Elternhäusern.
Also die Eltern sind arm, die Lehrer, 32 Prozent kriegen ja eine Gymnasialempfehlung.
Bei den privilegierten Elternhäusern 78 Prozent.
Nachhilfe, der ganze Kram, kopffrei für solche Sachen.
Und du kannst ja mal mit Lehrern reden, die Eltern, die privilegiert sind,
kommen ja gleich mit dem Anwalt, wenn die Note nicht stimmt.
Das kommt dann auch dazu, genau. Es ist sehr viel schwieriger,
diese Leute auszusetzen.
Selbst bei entsprechender Leistung, wie auch immer. Aber wie gesagt,
man muss niemanden nach unten drücken. Man könnte alle einfach anheben. Wäre schon gemacht.
Soziale Unterschiede nach formalen Bildungsabschluss oder Erwerbsstatus bleiben
bestehen, sowohl beim Präsenz- als auch beim Online-Lernen.
Also hier irgendwie, ja, mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist.
Mein Argument ist ja, wenn die Kinder erstmal alle Claude auf dem Handy haben,
dann werden sehr viele ganz schön krasse Gespräche mit einer KI stellen,
wo sie sich fragen, über was reden die Erwachsenen da, wer besser golfen kann.
Frühkindliche Bildung, also das große Thema, das große Thema Startchancen, wie sie da hat.
Eine Journalistenfrage an Bettina Stark-Watzinger.
Frau Stark-Watzinger, können Sie sagen, was Sie als die wichtigste Aufgabe aus
dem nationalen Bildungsbericht ableiten?
Das ist jetzt natürlich eine Frage, die dem widerspricht, was ja einleitend
auch von Professor Marz gesagt wurde, dass die Herausforderungen im Bildungssystem ja vielschichtig sind.
Insofern gilt es ja, an jeder Ebene anzusetzen. Aber ich finde es sehr gut,
dass die KMK sich in ihrer letzten Sitzung, und ich finde, das ist auch ein
wichtiger Schritt, gerade noch mal mit der frühkindlichen Bildung auseinandergesetzt
hat, weil die ja traditionell, klassisch bei uns in Deutschland,
eben von dem Finanzierungsvolumen her,
im Vergleich zu den anderen Ebenen eben nicht so stark finanziert wird.
Und auch traditionell, da hat sich sehr viel getan, Aber es startete ja eher
mit Blick auf Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf und der Wechsel dazu,
oder der Perspektivwechsel dazu, dass es eben Bildungseinrichtungen sind.
Und da hat die Forschung ja gerade auch sehr viel dazu beigetragen,
Professor Marz kann das besser sagen, dass im Alter bis zu drei Jahren die Grundlagen
für den weiteren Bildungsweg gelegt werden.
Insofern finde ich, ist das wirklich ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt,
weil er eben am Anfang steht und dann den weiteren Bildungsweg so stark beeinflusst.
Also sie hat zur Kenntnis genommen, dass es eine Studie gibt,
die das besagt, aber was sie da politisch für sich daraus ableitet,
das verrät sie uns heute nicht.
Also bei der Frage, was ist am wichtigsten, würde sie als FDPlerin natürlich
sagen, also ich mag die MINT-Spitzenforschung.
Wenn die da die Teilchen beschleunigen, das ist so geil, das ist genau mein Ding.
Und dann kommt sie aber und denkt, nee, ich sag mal kurz, ich will mich nicht
festlegen, aber diese frühkindliche Bildung, U3, das ist schon ganz wichtig.
Nun ist es aber so, U3. Wer ist U3, wenn über zwei Millionen Menschen fluchtbedingt
nach Deutschland kommen?
Und wie du sagst, Frauen und ihre Kinder, weil die Männer müssen ja kämpfen.
So steht im Bericht, so ist der im Bereich Demografie aktuell quantitativ relevanteste
Faktor die größtenteils fluchtbedingte Zuwanderung,
Dank der die Bevölkerungszahl 2022 gegenüber dem Vorjahr um 1,1 Millionen auf
84,4 Millionen Personen angestiegen ist.
Also sie weisen nochmal kurz darauf hin, es gibt eine Großwetterlage,
Demografie, Krieg und so weiter. Es kommen, ja wer kommt?
Die Altersgruppe der drei bis unter sechsjährigen, besonders relevant für die
frühe Bildung, hat sich mit einer Zunahme um 20 Prozent innerhalb der letzten
zehn Jahre deutlich vergrößert.
Kurzer Hinweis, es sind nicht die Geburten gewesen.
Das ist dieser, deswegen ja auch
vorher der kleine Hinweis für die Ministerin, wenn sie das hier lesen,
Der relevante Faktor ist ja Zuwanderung und nicht ihre tolle Familienpolitik,
die dazu führte, dass ja alle Leute sich plötzlich wieder zukunftswohlwollend Kinder trauen.
Und diese Kindergärten, darüber sprechen wir ja dann hier, die sind ja nicht
durchweg in einem guten Zustand.
Ich war bei einer Freundin zu Gast, die hat ihr Kind im Kindergarten.
Das war aber dann schon zu Hause. Und dann erzählte mir der vierjährige Hannes,
dass es jetzt schon zu warm ist.
Und wir hatten da gerade einmal 26, 27 Grad.
Aber dieser Kindergarten ist so schlecht gebaut, so schlecht isoliert.
Und der ist erst zehn Jahre alt, dass die Kinder jetzt umgezogen sind in die Turnhalle.
Und jetzt wird einfach der Sommer in der Turnhalle verpackt.
Ja, die hat kein Fenster.
Das ist gut für die.
Richtig.
Kommt nicht so viel Wärme rein, kommt zwar auch kein Licht rein, aber.
Aber das gibt es doch nicht.
Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Vor allem, du hättest ihm ja sagen können,
naja, die Ministerin hat gesagt, frühkindliche Bildung ist ihr das Wichtigste.
Ich habe ihm ein Stofftier mitgebracht.
Der U3, U6-Bereich. Jetzt hören wir den Bildungsforscher zum Thema U3,
U6-Bereich. So viele neue junge Menschen, was passiert denn da?
Und hier wird deutlich, dass wenn man Bildung verbessern will,
dass der alleine Blick aus der bildungspolitischen Richtung oftmals nicht ausreicht.
Wir sehen beispielsweise bei der Bildungsbeteiligung der drei- bis unter sechsjährigen
Kindern mit Migrationshintergrund, dass hier der Anteil in den letzten Jahren sogar gesunken ist.
Das heißt, selbst wenn die Bildung in der Kita noch so gut ist,
wenn wir die Kinder dort nicht erreichen, dann wird das letztendlich nicht hinreichen.
Insofern ist es wichtig, dass hier auch immer die Familien bei Integrationsfragen
mit in den Blick zu nehmen sind.
Ja, diese Bildungsbeteiligung der U6-Jährigen ist rückläufig.
Also ja, wir haben mehr junge Kinder und die könnten wir in Deutschland,
aus denen könnten wir Kristalle machen, müssten sie nur einmal ins Integrationssystem
Bildung reinschleusen, findet nicht statt.
Und das heißt, die gehen nicht in den Kindergarten.
Die gehen nicht in den Kindergarten. Die kommen in die Schule,
können dann kein Deutsch.
Dann sitzt Johannes Winkel mit mir in der Landsendung und dann sagt er,
das geht ja gar nicht, dass die da nicht Deutsch sprechen.
Und da hat der Carsten Lindemann dann? auch völlig recht damit zu sagen,
dann dürfen die auch nicht in die Schule.
Also wir verweigern denen sozusagen, also wir ermöglichen denen gar nicht,
Deutsch zu lernen mit anderen Kindern, die in dem Alter auch Deutsch lernen.
Aber warum gehen die nicht in den Kindergarten?
Weil die keinen haben. Wenn du als ukrainische Frau nach Deutschland kommst
und du suchst einen Kindergarten, findest du keinen.
Es gibt manchmal so in Thüringen, hat man ja gehört, dass dann so Plätze reserviert
werden, aber die müssen halt wirklich reserviert werden, weil wenn du als Kindergarten
eh schon überlastet bist mit allem und dann kommt eine Anfrage von der ukrainischen Familie,
ob dein Kind damit, also ob das Kind mit aufgenommen werden kann, dann denkst du dir,
wie war nochmal der Trick mit der Warteliste und so weiter.
Das ist einfach, das gibt es hier einfach nicht.
Ich hörte dann von einer Dame, die im Kindergarten arbeitet, wie groß diese Last ist.
Also Kinder bringen ja Krankheiten mit sich und das Problem ist aber nicht nur
das, sondern viele Eltern müssen ja arbeiten und es gibt ja einfach für die
nur ganz geringe Möglichkeiten, also kommt natürlich sehr auf den Job an,
wenn das Kind krank ist, zu Hause zu bleiben. Also das wird nicht gern gesehen.
Was passiert, erzählte sie, naja, die geben dem fiebernden Kind morgens ein
Zäpfchen, setzen das im Kindergarten ab, dann verstreut sich das natürlich.
In der Hoffnung, dass sie erst 14 Uhr merken, dass das Kind Fieber hat und nicht schon um 11.
Richtig und dann verstreut sich das natürlich auch gut mit den Keimen überall,
sodass es dann bald jeder hat und das ist die Situation, der man da heute ausgesetzt ist.
Ja, es ist wirklich alles nicht gut. Jetzt könnte man ja denken,
naja, es kamen ja auch diese Mütter mit.
Wir brauchen Menschen, die Betreuungstätigkeiten erfüllen.
Könnten wir nicht da so Anwerbeprozesse machen, wie zum Beispiel hier in Frankfurt. Es ist EM.
Wer könnte denn mal als Ordner, komm, wir gehen mal hier ins Migrationsheim
und so und dann rekrutiert man.
Also geht man wirklich als Stadt dahin und sagt, hier wohnen doch 20 junge Leute, oder?
Können die nicht mal für uns hier die Security machen? So, den Leuten sagen, wo das Klo ist.
So, also, es kommt nicht nur, und ich will es nochmal die Zahlen nennen,
der U6-Bereich ist in den letzten 10 Jahren um 20% gewachsen.
Und naturgemäß, es sind nicht die Geburten, das sind Familien,
alleinerziehend, kriegsbedingt, die kein Deutsch sprechen, die müssten ja aufgefangen werden.
Dann haben wir aber Personalknappheit. Wäre das nicht irgendwie zu kombinieren?
Also der Anteil der Personen mit Einwanderungsgeschichte an der Gesamtbevölkerung
wird kontinuierlich größer.
2005 betrug er noch 16%. 2022 ist er auf 24% angewachsen. Das ist auch so eine Textstelle.
Da kommen dann immer gerne so AfD-Tweets mit, das ist ja skandalös,
habt ihr diese Zahlen gesehen und so?
Ja, weil die Zahlen vorher keine kannte. Also das sind krasse Zahlen.
Nur die sind halt nicht skandalös im Sinne von rassistischer Denke,
sondern die sind einfach krasse Zahlen.
Also hier ist einfach eine echte politische Herausforderung.
Wenn man die Zahlen allerdings zum ersten Mal mitbekommt in einem rassistischen
konnotierten Chat, ja dann ist man natürlich, wie soll man das schaffen und
so, sondern man könnte es ja auch einfach mal als politisches Problem einhegen.
Würde natürlich bedeuten, dass Olaf Scholz dann keine Angst vor der AfD hat,
sondern das Thema einfach proaktiv anspricht, statt da irgendwie Blödsinn zu erzählen.
Ich erinnere an seine letzte Rede als Finanzminister im Bundestag.
Dazu hat der Maaz auch eine kleine Anmerkung.
Anhaltende Personalengpässe lassen sich in allen Bildungsbereichen feststellen
und gerade nicht nur im Bereich der Schule, die da oftmals im Fokus steht.
Wir haben das in der frühen Bildung, wir haben das in der beruflichen Bildung,
wir haben das auch in der Weiterbildung, die Probleme entsprechend das Personal zurück rotieren.
Wir haben einen hohen Anteil bei den allgemeinbildenden Schulen wie bei den
beruflichen Schulen von SeiteneinsteigerInnen,
die keine vollständige pädagogische Ausbildung haben.
Und hier auch eine große Variation zwischen den Bundesländern.
Potenzial liegt möglicherweise in einer Gruppe von Zugewanderten.
Hier konnten lediglich von 14 Prozent, die einen Antrag auf Anerkennung ihres
Hochschulstudiums gestellt haben, eine vollwertige Gleichwertigkeit attestiert bekommen.
Das heißt, wir haben hier eine Gruppe, wo wir überlegen müssen,
ob bestimmte Voraussetzungen, die wir an den Lehrkräfteberuf binden,
in Zeiten des Mangels hinreichend sind.
Beispielsweise die Forderung nach einer Zweifachqualifikation.
Er hat das jetzt.
Ich muss das jetzt nochmal gerade zusammenfassen. Es ist so,
dass nur 14% jener, die sich beworben haben,
nur 14% von denen wurde der Bildungsabschluss anerkannt.
Es kommen Menschen, die haben was studiert und dann sagt Deutschland,
das ist uns egal, das erkennen wir nicht an.
Mach mal noch ein paar Feige.
85 Prozent der Fälle, das ist nicht auf deutschem Niveau. Und jetzt sagt er
ja, wir könnten ja mal Anpassungen vornehmen,
und seine Erwartungen an den Lehrerberuf. Und da sage ich, no.
Es gibt schon gar keine Erwartungen mehr. Hier greift Rassismus eins zu eins.
Die Schulen haben Pools für Lehrer, die ausfallen.
Das sind dann Rentner, also hier Pensionierte, irgendwelche Ehemaligen.
Oder mittlerweile, wir hatten doch immer diese Oma von der Emily mit,
die hat doch immer ganz toll die Kinder mit betreut, als wir so auf dem Ausflug waren.
Könnte die nicht zweimal die Woche reinkommen und hier Unterricht machen?
Hat die denn irgendwas mit? Nö, die hat an der Kasse gearbeitet. So ungefähr, ne?
Also völlig wesensfremdes reinrekrutieren.
Hauptsache deutsch. Hauptsache deutsch.
Ich kann dir auch ein Beispiel nennen.
Wenn du im Ausland Pädagogik studiert hast. Ne, das geht nicht.
Also diesen Abschluss können wir nicht annehmen. Du kannst ja auf gar keinen Fall Lehrer werden.
Ach, sie sind schon 95 Jahre alt und erklären sich noch bereit.
Soweit, kommen Sie, wir geben Ihnen noch eine Medaille, betreuen Sie mal die Dreijährigen hier.
Also der Rassismus hier ist so krass einprogrammiert in dieses System,
dass nur 14 Prozent dieser Abschlüsse anerkennen. Das ist wirklich grotesk.
Jaja, ich kenne auch einen Fall von jemand, der kein Pädagogikstudium hat,
nie Lehramt studiert hat, ein geisteswissenschaftliches Fach studiert hat,
das aber eher für den Unterricht nur bedingt tauglich ist und trotzdem unterrichtet er fast alle Fächer.
Notgedrungen, ist ja sonst keiner da.
Ja, aber er ist deutsch.
Irgendwer muss am Schuljahresende ein Zeugnis schreiben, in dem irgendwas für
die Eltern drinsteht, was sie verwerten können.
Aber er ist deutsch und sieht damit für alle anderen so aus wie ein Lehrer.
Das ist das GPT-Phänomen, also die Grammatik stimmt. Der Rest,
aber die Grammatik stimmt.
Sie weisen nochmal darauf hin 2,7 Millionen Zuzüge 2022 1,1 Millionen davon
im Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg was eben bedeutet 1,5 Millionen sind auch,
1,2 Millionen sind fortgezogen. Also wir haben eine Nettoeinwanderung von 1,5 Millionen Menschen.
Also hier ist richtig viel Bewegung in Deutschland.
Nur halt nicht in diesen Systemen, die irgendwie den Laden am Laufen halten.
Die Integration von Menschen mit Flucht- und Migrationserfahrung ist also eine,
wie Sie sagen, kontinuierliche Aufgabe.
Ja, ich würde mal sagen, das ist noch ein bisschen wichtiger als dieses lebenslange
Lernen, denn das kann man ja intrinsisch motivieren.
Die Leute, die hierher kommen nach Deutschland und dann vielleicht sogar sagen,
für uns dankenswerterweise, sie wollen hier leben bleiben, die sind schon intrinsisch motiviert.
Die sind schon aktiviert. Nur, wir holen die halt nicht ab.
Wir haben für die kein Programm, die irgendwie einzubinden.
Und dann kommen sie noch auf so einen Punkt zu sprechen und das müssen wir jetzt verweben.
Also die soziale Herkunft war seit Jahrzehnten immer ein Thema,
wird so krass vererbt. Und dann dieser hohe Ausländeranteil.
Denn es gibt Risikolagen und zwar drei.
Risikolage formal gering qualifizierter Eltern, die also ihren Kindern nicht
richtig helfen können oder wie auch immer.
Eltern, die nicht erwerbsfähig sind, ist auch eine soziale Risikolage.
Und Armutsgefährdung im Haushalt. Die gehen natürlich alle so Hand in Hand.
Also da gibt es häufig immer Schneidungen, was im Bericht heißt hier.
2022 war fast jede dritte minderjährige Person von mindestens einer dieser Risikolagen betroffen.
Also von 12 Millionen Kindern in der Schule oder so sind hier 4 Millionen.
Entweder können die Eltern nicht helfen oder sie haben keine Ahnung vom System
oder haben kein Geld, um daraus zu helfen, wie auch immer.
Also jedes Dritte. 60% der Kinder aus Familien mit Einwanderungsgeschichte wachsen
aktuell unter der Belastung mindestens einer dieser Risikolagen auf.
Bei den Kindern ohne Einwanderungsgeschichte sind es demgegenüber 20%.
Also es verteilt sich hart entlang dieser Migrationshintergrund oder nicht.
60 zu 20%. Was bedeutet, hier kann es allein eine staatliche Aufgabe sein.
Hier nützt es nichts, die Eltern zu motivieren, jetzt seid doch mal weniger
arm, jetzt seid doch mal besser gebildet, spricht doch mal besser Deutsch.
Wird nicht funktionieren.
Entweder hier gibt es eine staatliche Investition ins System oder es bleibt,
wie es ist und dann sinken diese Bildungsbeteiligungen der Kinder und so weiter,
dann gehen die nicht in den Kindergarten.
Es ist nun mal so, die müssen dann zu Hause abgeholt werden vom Kindergarten.
Zumindest für die erste Zeit. Und das spricht auch gar nichts dagegen.
Meine Kinder waren auch in so einem, da gibt es so ein Übergangsjahr,
wo die dann vormittags schon in der Schule sind, aber nachmittags noch im Kindergarten.
Da kommt der Kindergarten in die Schule und holt die ab.
Warum kann man nicht einfach morgens alle Kinder abholen? Das ist auch lustig,
wenn man mit den Kindern von Haus zu Haus geht und einfach vier Kinder sich da morgens abholen.
Also es ist wirklich crazy.
Während in paar Familien rund ein Viertel der Kinder von mindestens einer Risikolage
betroffen sind, ist der entsprechende Anteil bei Kindern Alleinerziehender mehr als doppelt so hoch.
Also wenn wir hören, Alleinerziehende Ukrainerinnen haben Kinder hier,
dann können wir gar keine Ansprüche an die stellen.
Dann greifen einfach alle Risikolagen und wir müssen trotzdem diese Hoffnung
formulieren, es wäre gut, wenn die es schaffen, hier in Deutschland Fuß zu fassen,
weil volkswirtschaftlich brauchen wir die, ansonsten können wir die Renten nicht bezahlen.
Naja, also dieser Bildungsbericht zeigt mir wirklich sehr deutlich,
wie tief der Rassismus institutionell verankert ist und wie krass Deutschland
immer noch so eine Normfamilie hat.
Bio-Deutsch-Eltern mit ein oder zwei Kindern, eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Da müssen wir auf jedes zehnte Kind mal achten.
Zugezogen, alleinerziehend, immer ein Problem. Da kann man gleich sagen,
haben wir registriert, fahren wir hin, holen zu Hause ab. Also es ist wirklich crazy.
Und da es gut passte, der Juso-Chef Johannes Winkel war in einer Diskussion
mit der grünen Jugendvorsitzenden Svenja Ampun.
Johannes Winkel ist Juso-Chef? Nein.
Der heißt doch anders.
Nee, das ist der Neue. Vorher hieß es immer Tilman Kuban.
Nein, du meinst Junge Union.
Ja, Junge Union. Ich war jetzt gerade so. Nein, nein, nein. Wie heißt er?
Sehr gut. Sehr guter Mann.
Junge Union.
Sehr guter Mann, der Juso-Chef. Nein, Junge Union. Sorry, Junge Union-Chef.
So wie es hier auf meinem Notizzettel steht.
Also die beiden, die Junge Union und die Grünen treffen sich hier und wir hören
jetzt aus grüner Richtung,
Problembeschreibungen und so weiter und so fort und dann platzt ihr auch kurz
der Kragen, weil das Einzige, was aus der Richtung JU kommt,
ist wirklich einfacher Rassismus.
Im Krankenhaus erlebt, was passiert, wenn in stressigen Situationen Beschäftigte
nicht gut Deutsch sprechen.
Ich habe Freundinnen und Freunde, die gerade anfangen als Lehrer zu arbeiten
und die merken, was es für eine Belastung ist, in einer ohnehin schon sehr großen
Klasse mit Kindern, wo sowieso schon Kinder mit erhöhtem Förderbedarf sind,
dann noch mehrere Kinder, die nicht gut Deutsch sprechen.
Es gibt Herausforderungen, die durch Migration entstehen, keine Frage.
Man kann auch nochmal sagen, Wenn man in Deutschland alle Menschen mit Migrationsgeschichte
abzieht, dann bricht unser Gesundheitssystem, unser Bildungssystem alles zusammen.
Aber es gibt diese Herausforderung, keine Frage.
Was mich bloß ärgert, ist, weshalb führen wir dann keine Debatte darüber,
wie wir mit diesen Herausforderungen konkret umgehen. Machen wir es doch.
Führen wir die Debatte, woher kriegen wir die Kita-Plätze, die fehlen?
Da müsste man Geld ausgeben.
Da hängen aber einige massiv an der Schuldenbremse. U.a. die Union,
die verhindert, dass wir da rangehen. Es geht ja um die Begrenzung der Migration.
Gucken wir uns das Thema mehr Geld für die Schulen an. Aber das ist genau der Punkt.
Ihr landet immer einfach nur bei Ausländern raus. Und das ärgert mich.
Nein, aber genau das hast du gesagt. Migration begrenzen. Die Mauern höher ziehen.
Der Punkt ist bloß, hast du mal mitbekommen, was in dieser Welt da draußen los ist?
Die steht in Flammen.
Und Migration ist eine Realität. Und wenn man die Mauern jetzt höher zieht,
dann werden einfach nur Menschen auf dem Weg hierher, mehr Menschen auf dem Weg hierher, sterben.
Ja, braucht man gar nicht machen, denn er hat ja schon eingestanden,
dass es ohne die schon hier seienden Migranten nicht funktioniert und sagt aber
dann, Migration ist unser Problem,
Ausländer raus, sagt er nicht, aber sie legt sie mir in den Mund und ich finde,
sie macht das berechtigterweise.
Und genau das ist die Argumentation, die wir jetzt überall hören.
Es geht der Wirtschaft schlecht. Wen können wir ausweisen?
Irgendwelche Ziele von uns erfüllen sich nicht. Wer muss dran glauben?
Neuerdings ukrainische Männer, die noch hier sind, bitte jetzt ab in den Krieg.
Ja, also dieses, ja, ihr wollt ja nicht mit uns diskutieren,
wir sagen doch Migration begrenzen, ihr lasst euch ja nicht drauf ein,
dann sagt sie, nee, das ist genau dieser Ausländer-Rassismus,
der uns hier nicht hilft.
Und man muss dann nicht mit, die Welt steht im Feuer oder so,
Deutschland steht im Feuer.
Wir sollten heilfroh sein, dass diese Kinder schon im Land sind,
ansonsten müssen wir uns wirklich bald Gedanken machen, von woher wir sie importieren,
denn irgendwer muss hier in zehn Jahren Rente bezahlen.
Und ich finde es erstaunlich, als ich im September 2022 mein Buch rausbrachte,
habe ich noch so gedacht, okay gut, Fachkräftemangel ist immer noch und so weiter.
Und dann hat es ja nur ein Jahr gedauert, bis September 2023 und dann war Fachkräftemangel
plötzlich überall Thema.
Und ich war so ein bisschen überrascht und dachte, uh, das Thema geht aber schnell.
Nur jetzt bin ich gerade wieder, denke ich so, nee, die haben das alle zu eingehegt.
Die meinen damit MINT-Spitzenkräfte.
Ja, aber dass ein Drittel der Hausärzte in den nächsten zehn Jahren in Rente
gehen und ersatzlos diese Praxen wegfallen, ist irgendwie noch nicht so richtig angekommen.
Ich kenne Hausärzte, die sind weit über 70.
Die verdienen sich immer noch so ein Zubrot.
Die verdienen gut, aber die sagen auch eigentlich, ja, was mache ich sonst mit
den Patienten? Ja, man weiß ja nicht.
An wen man sie übergeben soll und so weiter.
Da gibt es bei denen auch noch die Idee, gut, ich kann mir noch ein Auto kaufen,
wenn ich weiter Praxis mache, aber es ist auch wirklich so eine Verantwortung,
dass ich denke, ja, wenn das jetzt hier zu ist, dann ist hier auch nichts mehr.
Da kommt nicht jemand anderes.
Und du sagst gerade, im September 22 ist ein Buch erschienen.
Im September 22 sagte Friedrich Merz, ich hatte es mir extra nochmal rausgeschrieben,
ja, das ist auch alles nicht so richtig mit den Ukrainern.
Die fahren, die machen so einen Tourismus inzwischen, die fahren hin und her,
fahren wieder zurück in die Ukraine, kommen wieder her, ja.
Also diese ganzen Sachen, also seien die so zum Vergnügen, greifen sich also
in Deutschland auch noch so ein bisschen Bürgergeld ab und fahren dann wieder
in die Heimat. Das hat er im September 22 gesagt.
Daraufhin wurde er von allen Parteien extrem angegriffen, von seinen eigenen Leuten.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Und jetzt ist genau das absolut neu. Ich habe damals gesagt,
vielleicht will er so einen Testballon steigen lassen.
Ja, offenbar. Und damals war es noch zu früh.
Und jetzt ist es genau richtig. Jetzt kann man exakt diese These vorbringen
und bekommt Applaus und kann davon ausgehen, dass die nächste Talkshow nach einem gerichtet wird.
Ja, also wer jetzt fünf Jahre alt ist, ist in 20 Jahren, das ist eine absolut
sensationelle Nachricht, die ich
jetzt verkünde, Politiker wissen das noch nicht, der ist in 20 Jahren 25.
Ja.
So, mit 25 steigt man, ich sag mal so, spätestens, klar gibt es noch Nachzüge, ins Berufsleben ein.
Und diese 20 Jahre liegen absolut in der politischen Verantwortung, was dann passiert.
Ich könnte mir jetzt aber auch.
Eins plus eins ist gleich zwei.
Wenn dann Scholz in 20 Jahren gefragt wird, dann wird er wahrscheinlich sagen.
Die Indonesier.
Nee, nee, er wird wahrscheinlich sagen, wir haben damals nicht damit gerechnet,
dass Kinder auch erwachsen werden.
Heute müssen wir das anders sehen.
Ein Kind, das heute geboren wird, geht in sechs Jahren in die Schule.
Völlig überraschende kommunalpolitische Einsichten, dass das wirklich passiert.
Dass die wirklich sechs Jahre alt werden und dann plötzlich in die Schule angemeldet werden.
Aber was ja auch interessant ist, ist, dass wir jetzt sehr viel die etablierten
Medien schelten und das ist mir auch immer sehr recht. Ja, das ist recht.
Bemerkenswert ist, dass wir von all den Twitch-Streamern, all denen,
die die ganze Zeit nur junge Leute adressieren, dies niemals thematisiert bekommen.
Das einzige Mal, das überhaupt Thema
Schule aufkam, war während der Schulschließungen und da haben Rezo und Co.
So eine Zero-Covid-Politik vertreten und haben es dann,
im Zuge von MyLab und so weiter völlig übertreiben wollen, haben aber auch selbst
natürlich nie irgendwelche Lockdown-Repressionen gehabt und sonst kommt das
einfach bei den jungen Leuten auch selbst gar nicht vor.
Also man könnte ja denken, dass man 14-, 15-, 16-Jährige damit anspricht,
dass man dies als großes Thema macht. Es ist aber nicht da.
Du siehst doch auch, wenn wie heißt da der.
Dunkle Parabelritter oder wie diese ganzen Funkformate, die reden einem doch
auch jetzt nur ein Jahr, also wenn keine Wehrpflicht, aber dann doch wenigstens
eine Dienstpflicht oder irgendwie ein freiwilliges, gezwungenes Ja,
das wir alle ableisten müssen.
Also die sind ja auch alle nur im Gemütszustand Rentnerrepublik,
was kann ich den jungen Leuten noch zumuten, während es bei eigentlich ihrem
Publikum ja darum gehen müsste, jetzt Preaching to the Choir zu machen und das findet nicht statt.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, dass man zwar heute jenseits der etablierten Medien
den die jungen Leute besser denn je erreichen, beziehungsweise man erreicht sie nur noch darüber.
Man kann ja nicht eine Fernsehsendung machen und glauben, dass da 14-Jährige davor sitzen.
Man kann sie also nur darüber erreichen. Das Einzige, was man denen aber andrehen
kann, sind E-Zigaretten und Glücksspielangebote.
Ich empfehle auf Instagram Herr Schröder, der Korrekturensohn.
Kennst du ihn? Nein. Ah, ja.
Das ist ein Lehrer, der Comedy macht auf der Bühne. Er hat 686.000 Follower auf Instagram.
Und wenn er in irgendeiner Stadt zu Gast ist, macht er eine Halle voll und am
nächsten Abend nochmal und am nächsten Abend nochmal.
Und auf Instagram kann man dann verfolgen, weil er sehr viel mit dem Publikum
interagiert. Es sitzen nur angehende Lehrer vor ihm.
Wenn ich jetzt Politiker wäre, hätte ich wahnsinnig Angst, dass ich da gerade
eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft zusammenschmiede, der irgendwann der Geduldsfaden
platzt. weil das scheint mir eine der größten sozialen Bewegungen in Deutschland gerade zu sein.
Diese Comedy-Touren vom Herrn Schröder.
Sollte man sich mal echt angucken.
Es ist auffällig, dass alle jungen Formate, die es gibt und da ist vor allem Funk zu nennen.
Die kommen aus der Schule und du willst denen dann zu den Hausaufgaben nochmal
ihre Themen am Nachmittag vorlegen.
Nein, aber man könnte es ja anders politisieren. Man könnte es ja auch mit der
Entertainment aufgreifen. Es findet einfach nicht statt.
Die Jugendformate des öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders sind dazu...
Ich habe einen Vorschlag.
Lass mich ausreden. Die Jugendsender des öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders sind
dazu da, aus den Kindern und Jugendlichen schon Omas und Opas zu machen,
bevor sie volljährig sind.
Ich habe einen Vorschlag. Für dich, ein Plädoyer.
Diese Kinder, ja, die erleben, was in der Schule los ist.
Aber die wissen ja nicht, wie es mal vorher war oder wie es sein könnte oder
so. Für die ist es einfach so eine Fisch-im-Wasser-Realität.
Aber deren Eltern, wenn du die mit einer Wählerstimme ausstattest,
die können diese Besorgnis wirklich politisch transportieren.
Es muss nur für sie wirkungsvoll sein.
Und wenn sie wissen, da geht eine Oma wählen, da geht eine Oma wählen,
da geht eine Oma wählen, ich gehe jetzt für vier wählen, dann gehen die auch wählen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob du damit recht hast, denn ich sehe momentan auch nicht
die große Elternbewegung auf der Straße.
Ja, wir auch. Wenn einer ausgenockt ist, dann doch auch wohl die Eltern.
Was meinst du, was ich mache vor so einem Podcast? Debatte gucken?
Ne, ich schmier Toastbrote, ich mach Brotbüchsen, ich guck, dass jeder halt
in die Schule kommt. Debatte guck ich dann noch nebenbei.
Ja.
Also für die Debatte stell ich mir einen Wecker auf 5.30 Uhr.
Ich sage nur...
Ich glaube, du überschätzt, dass Familien so progressiv denken.
Wie du es tust. Wir warten mal ein Buch ab, was dann zum Thema Familie und zwar
mit Munition, Feuer und so.
Vermutlich musst du sie munitionieren, die Familien, damit sie dann aufgeklärt
sind, um wählen zu können.
Warte mal ab, wie ich die Familien munitioniere und ich glaube,
sehr viele Eltern wissen schon sehr gut, was sie politisch wollen.
Sie haben nur keine Zeit, das auf die Straße zu tragen.
Aber sie haben am Ende auch gewählt. Also diese Eltern, die du da meinst,
davon gehen sehr, sehr viele auch rein. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt,
aber alle Menschen mit Kindern gehen nicht wählen.
Ja, aber wir haben keine Erhebung darüber, wie Eltern wählen.
Und da würde ich sagen, die wählen nicht viel anders. Die wählen vielleicht sogar eher noch.
Okay, okay, okay, dann sollten sie halt anders wählen. Also ich bin ja dran.
Da ich heute nicht zu meinem KI- und Emotionthema komme. Nein.
Naja, es ist ja schon spät.
Ja, wir haben uns heute sehr aufgerieben.
Genau, also kann man ja durchaus vertagen. Es kann auch durchaus auf der nächsten
Bühne oder so. Also dieses Thema lässt uns ja nicht los.
Ich will trotzdem zwei KI-Clips spielen zu diesem Thema. Nachwuchs,
Bildung, Sozialisation und so weiter.
Das eine ist, wir hören Adam Curry, wie er kurz anmoderiert,
weil ich habe den Clip selber nicht gefunden.
Ich habe ihn nur bei Adam Curry im Noah Jenner Podcast gehört.
Und wir hören Larry Fink.
Ah ja.
Also den Blackrock-Chef, von dem wir wissen, dem ist egal, wer im Weißen Haus
regiert, unter ihm. Ja. So ungefähr.
Er äußert sich zum Thema Chancen durch KI für demografisch in Schieflage geratene Volkswirtschaften.
I can argue, in the developed countries, the big winners are countries that
have shrinking populations.
That's something that most people never talked about. You know,
we always used to think shrinking population is a cause for negative growth.
But in my conversations with the leadership of these large developed countries
that have xenophobic immigration policies, Sie erlauben niemandem, zu kommen.
Schreckende Unabhängigkeit, Entschuldigung, schreckende Demografien.
Diese Länder werden schnell Robotik und Technologie und AI entwickeln.
Und wenn die Vermutung, ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es passieren wird,
aber wenn die Vermutung all das transformiert, Produktivität,
die wir meisten denken, es wird,
werden wir die Standard der Lebensweise der Länder und der Lebensweise der Individuen
erhöhen können. Even with shrinking populations.
And so the paradigm of negative population growth is going to be changing.
And the social problems that one will have in substituting humans for machines
is going to be far easier in those countries that have declining populations.
And so for those countries that have rising populations, the answer will be
education and so rapidly developing.
So, jetzt lass, ich frage dich jetzt, was glaubst du, wie ich diesen Clip einschätze?
Du siehst mich als Fanatiker des Claude-Zeitalters, der demografisch aufgeklärt
zum Thema publiziert und viel redet. Und jetzt kommt er mit so einem Umschwung in der Denke.
Was glaubst du, wie ich darüber denke, was er da sagt?
Du bist ja jemand, der sagt, man kann jetzt mit Chet Chippity und Claude alles
Mögliche wegrationalisieren.
Aber du bist ja zugleich jemand, der weiß, dass es eine menschliche Komponente
gibt, die nicht so ersetzbar ist, so sehr man die auch mit Emotionen und allem trainieren möchte. Ja.
Diese menschliche Komponente kann natürlich sehr verstärkt werden und nützlich
eingesetzt werden, ganz neutral gesprochen, indem man viel in Bildung,
Erziehung und all das investiert.
Du hältst ja auch die Familie hoch, weil sonst könntest du auch sagen,
bald können wir die Familie abschaffen, darum kümmern sich nicht mehr Mama und
Papa, sondern das machen zusammen Claude und Chet Chibiti.
Genau.
Und insofern denke ich, dass du auf der Position bist,
dass man eigentlich nur durch massive Bildungsinvestitionen eine sinnvolle AI-Politik machen kann.
Ja, also recht nah dran. Ich halte diesen Clip für das Erschreckendste mit,
was ich zuletzt gehört habe, denn das ist,
also wenn das die Idee ist, wie die ganz superreichen wirklichen Steuere auf
dieser Welt, die die Billionen bewegen, jetzt an die Sache rangehen, in denen sie sagen,
Bildung ist was für diese Länder, die noch wachsen.
Die anderen schicken wir mal in dieses, und da muss man auch das KI-Winter,
muss man umdefinieren, was ist KI-Winter?
Ich denke so an Dolly und sowas, solche Filme.
Das ist wirklich, also mein Interesse an Familie ist, die Familie ist ein Interaktionszusammenhang,
der sich nicht wegorganisieren lässt.
Das ist die große Lehre. Wir können die elementarsten Dinge in unserer Gesellschaft
nicht wegorganisieren, nicht automatisieren, sondern entweder sind da Menschen
in Interaktion, also im Gespräch, oder nicht.
Und er könnte ja hier auch gleich sagen, ja Gefühle, soziale Beziehungen,
das ist sowas für so einfache Völker noch irgendwo, die noch nicht ganz von
Blackrock beherrscht sind.
In der Hinsicht, wir haben jetzt diesen Clip gehört.
Nicht so verwunderlich, wenn du jetzt mal überlegst, was BlackRock vor allem
auszeichnet als Schattenbank,
ist es ja nicht so, dass wir hier das Warren Buffett Prinzip haben,
wir schauen uns die Unternehmensergebnisse an, lesen Berichte und machen dann
Investitionsentscheidungen, sondern sie haben diesen Supercomputer Aladin.
Und Aladdin entscheidet, wo investiert wird und ganz viel, was BlackRock ja
überhaupt verwaltet, ist ja rein passiv verwaltet, also wo gar nicht mehr irgendetwas
anderes geschieht als Index abbilden und das ist das,
worüber er Herr ist und dann muss man nicht mehr den Einzelnen seine Souveränität
und seine Entscheidung hochhalten, Sondern dann kann man sagen,
wir delegieren das ja schon lange an Aladin,
an unseren Supercomputer und jetzt bekommt Aladin noch ganz viele neue Geschwister.
Ja, also die Welt, die ihm hier vorschwebt als erlösend und er sagt ja,
das ist hoffnungsvoll, ist nicht mehr lebenswert.
Das ist im Grunde dieses, wir schützen das Klima für uns, damit es lebenswert bleibt.
Wenn wir das jetzt aufgeben, ist es alles, also wir schützen die Natur nicht
für die Natur, sondern für uns.
Und wenn wir das aus dem Blick verlieren und dann einfach nur wild rumrennen
und irgendwie und so. Und hier auch.
Also wenn wir die Interaktion Menschen begegnen sich, wenn es darum nicht geht,
sondern dann einfach wieder diese japanische, ja der Roboter wird die Pflege schon machen und so.
Und deswegen, wir haben jetzt diesen Clip gehört. Würden wir jetzt noch Zeit
haben und diese Emo-KI-Clips hören, würden unsere Hörer danach weinend auf dem
Boden liegen und wären wirklich betrübt.
Von daher ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn wir das entzerren, das heute nicht mehr hören.
Aber ich will nur darauf hinweisen, dieses Bevölkerungsgröße,
wir haben solche Sachen wie hier.
Also dieses Bildungsthema kommt ja auch unter Druck, weil wir einfach nicht
mehr, ich meine, wir hatten schon mal ökonomischen Druck.
Durch Versorgungskrisen. Nur das war in den 70ern und da hat man gesagt,
ach so viele junge Leute, komm wir bauen die größten Unis der Welt.
Jetzt haben wir wieder einen Versorgungsdruck, einen ökonomischen Druck und
blenden alles aus, was irgendwem weiterhilft.
Also Bildungssystem einfach, ah jetzt ist alles eine Last und so.
Das muss man ja alles mal, also es ist nicht die ökonomischen Zwänge an sich,
sondern es ist so dieses Verhältnis der demografischen Schieflage,
also wenn es mehr Jüngere gewesen wären, hätte man denen eine Zukunft gebaut.
Wenn es mehr Ältere sind, ah das scheiß Pfleger er nervt uns eh und so,
können wir nicht einfach wegsperren.
So ein Tenor. Und diesen Zusammenhang aus KI und Bevölkerungsgröße,
der wird häufiger thematisiert, auch bei anderen, wie zum Beispiel hier internationaler
Kräftekampf und so weiter.
Im Big Technology Podcast, den ich übrigens wirklich sehr empfehle,
also dieser Big Technology Podcast, das ist so von LinkedIn irgendwie finanziert,
aber dieser Alex Kantorowicz, wie er heißt, macht den wirklich sehr gut.
Da diskutieren die auch mal so ein bisschen KI und Demografie.
Some countries wealthier and more powerful than other countries?
Well, it's often because they have more people, right?
So Taiwan would lose a war against China. Why is that? Without the help of the
US. But because China has more people.
If AI substitutes for people can increase the effective population of a country,
then you can imagine that it would just be a huge leverage that a country would
have over other countries in terms of its own economic output or even its ability
to withstand geopolitical competition.
Ich meine, er illustriert das jetzt nur am Kräfteverhältnis,
aber wollen wir wirklich, dass jetzt solche kleinen Organisationen wie hier
die Hisbollah und da irgendwer in Afrika dann denkt,
ich habe gar nicht so viele Leute, aber ich klicke mir jetzt per KI irgendwie
so ein Angriffsszenario zurecht und ziehe das dann durch.
Ich schaffe das auch zu zehnt, also es treibt Blüten, dieses Thema,
es ist alles nicht sehr gut.
Sollen wir noch über etwas auch nicht Erfreuliches, aber vielleicht ein bisschen Heitereres sprechen?
Zum Abschluss haben wir Josef Hader und Heidenreich, Elke Heidenreich.
Das sind so kleine Rausschmeißer-Clips, kannst also gerne noch die Stimmung runterziehen.
Also, wir hatten ein Live-Salon und zuvor haben wir dort auch unsere gemeinsame
Freundin Konstanze getroffen.
Konstanze raucht gelegentlich.
Das hätte uns ja fast süchtig gemacht.
Aber jetzt vaped sie auch.
Hattest du es auch probiert?
Ja. Das ist gruselig, ne? Wir haben es beide probiert.
Es ist nicht...
Es ist merkwürdig, es schmeckt sehr süß.
Eine 15-jährige Unwiderstehlich, würde ich sagen.
Wir hören mal in die Sache rein. Es ist ein Riesenphänomen. Überall wird gevaped.
Wir hören jetzt, im NDR wurde folgendermaßen darüber gesprochen.
Toll ist, dass es nicht stinkt, dass man das zum Teil in der Wohnung rauchen
kann und dass man selbst danach nicht stinkt. Und es schmeckt meistens besser
als normale Zigaretten.
Die 27-Jährige ist vor etwa einem Jahr auf den regelmäßigen Geschmack der Einweg-E-Zigarette gekommen.
Katharina dagegen ist Gelegenheits-Velperin. Kiwi-Passionsfrucht Guave haben sie heute dabei.
Im Vergleich zu den vielen Geschmackssorten der Vapes sieht der traditionelle
Tabak ganz schön alt aus.
Man kann sich ja immer was aussuchen, wo man gerade Lust drauf hat.
Und bei Zigaretten, ja okay, das schmeckt irgendwie immer gleich oder sehr ähnlich.
Wir hatten irgendeinen Himbeer-Geschmack.
Ja, das stimmt. Also wir müssen es echt mal beschreiben, weil es nützt nichts
jetzt zu sagen, nee und so. Weil jeder, der es benutzt, merkt es ja dann auch.
Wir sind ja alle so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach Süßigkeiten,
die uns nicht dick machen.
Ja.
Und mit diesen Waves hat man plötzlich so, man zieht da dran und dann legt sich
auf den Gaumen in, wie so eine Zuckerschicht, die wirklich gut schmeckt.
Alles, was negativ ist an Zigaretten, findet nicht mehr statt.
Und man hat es unendlich den ganzen Tag.
Und man weiß aber, die wissen selber noch nicht genau, was das so ist,
aber es ist irgendwie giftig, es ist so richtig gut und man hat keine Ahnung.
Also es ist, was das Verlockungspotenzial angeht, so crazy, selten ein Produkt
gehabt, das so fesselnd sein kann.
Und sofort funktioniert. Das stimmt auch.
Die meisten Leute, die anfangen zu rauchen, machen das ja oft dann mit 14,
15, 16 aus einem Gruppendruck heraus, aber in Wahrheit schmeckt ihnen das natürlich nicht gleich.
Man muss sich also daran gewöhnen, dass einem dieser Geschmack dann so vertraut
wird, dass man irgendwann sagt, ja, ich bin jetzt Raucher.
Ich muss ja hier zur Transparenz sagen, ich rauche ja, aber sehr, sehr wenig.
Das heißt, ich rauche zwei bis drei Zigaretten am Tag und das aber auch immer nur abends.
Jetzt, wir beide rauchen ja auch schon mal, wenn wir in eine Bar gehen und du
bittest mich darum, dir eine Zigarette zu geben und dann rauchst du.
Auf einer Terrasse, wenn ich an diesem Tisch stehe, rauche ich ab und zu mal eine.
Also das kommt auf alle zwei Wochen zwei Zigaretten oder sowas.
Da müsste ich vielleicht auch noch hinkommen, jedenfalls bist du dann… Es ist
trotzdem nicht gut zu rauchen. Ja, es ist trotzdem nicht gut,
also auch drei Zigaretten sind nicht gut.
Ich mache das aus Gruppendruck.
Ich zwinge dich dazu. In Deutschland rauchen insgesamt 22,7 Prozent der Frauen
und Männer ab 18 Jahren. Bei Männern sind ein bisschen mehr.
Bei Jugendlichen gibt es einen enormen Rückgang, was jetzt klassische Zigaretten anbelangt.
2001 haben noch 27,5 Prozent der Jugendlichen geraucht, also 12 bis 17 Jahren. 27,5 Prozent.
Inzwischen 6,1 Prozent. Könnte man sagen, also ein Riesenerfolg der ganzen Nichtraucherkampagnen.
Überall geht das Rauchen zurück von Zigaretten, aber die E-Zigarette,
die ist etwas, was wirklich boomt.
Wir haben jetzt mal hier einen Auszug aus dem Spiegel.
Deutschlands E-Zigarettenbranche setzt ihren Boom ungebremst fort.
Der Umsatz mit Geräten, Flüssigkeiten und Zubehör wird in diesem Jahr schätzungsweise
bei 810 Millionen Euro liegen und damit 40 Prozent höher sein als 2022 und überall
sind Rekorde zu vermelden.
Nun hören wir mal ein bisschen weiter, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit diesen
Babes, du hast es ja jetzt gerade schon gut beschrieben, also vielleicht noch
muss gesagt werden, man hat also ein Mundstück, meistens aus Kunststoff,
dort wird es eingefüllt,
das ist auch Batterie betrieben und dann nuckelt man daran.
Ich finde es ja im Ganzen völlig unästhetisch und deswegen würde ich es schon nicht tun.
Ich bin, du weißt es ja, Erotiker und da ist ja die Zigarette ein erotisches Beiwerk.
Jetzt, wo du die Zigarette danach wieder hast.
Ist es ja auch. Kann man, kann man, das sowieso, die Zigarette danach,
aber nein, die Zigarette als solches, wir kennen es aus den Hollywood-Filmen
von einst, ist ja etwas, womit erotisch gespielt werden kann.
Es wird ja erstaunlich häufig auch auf der Bühne geraucht. Also dieser eine Zug.
Der kurz symbolisch gezeigt wird. Ja, das ist mit so einem Nuckelding nicht möglich.
Du hast jetzt gerade schon gesagt, man sehnt sich so ein bisschen nach was Süßem
den ganzen Tag, aber bitte etwas, was nicht dick macht.
Damit hast du es schon gut beschrieben. Ich würde aber auch sagen,
E-Zigaretten sind die Schnuller für Erwachsene.
Wir sollten es auf jeden Fall diffamieren.
Dennoch habe jeder Dritte zwischen 14 und 17 im vergangenen Jahr schon E-Zigaretten
konsumiert, so die Deutsche Gesellschaft für Pneumologie und Beatmungsmedizin.
Ärzte befürchten, dass E-Zigaretten eine neue Generation an Nikotin heranführen.
Nikotin ist eigentlich bitter.
Der bittere Geschmack wird damit komplett untergraben. D.h.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, nicht das Gefühl, dass ich etwas Giftiges inhaliere.
Und damit werden insbesondere Kinder und Jugendliche gelockt und mitunter zu langfristigen Kunden.
In Deutschland werde zu häufig an junge Menschen verkauft, so Experten.
Man kann vielleicht sagen, wir sind in einem großen Feldversuch.
Wir lassen als Gesellschaft Kinder und Jugendliche diesen Inhalationsvorgang
machen, um später rauszukriegen, wie schädlich das ist. Das ist im Prinzip ein Unding.
Man macht da einen großen Test. Schauen wir mal, was passiert. Wahnsinn, oder?
Ich denke mir halt, du hast jetzt von der Erotik-Schiene, ich meine so allgemein,
den meisten geht es ja um die Ästhetik.
Und die ist ja nicht gegeben bei so Dingen.
Naja, warte, also ich würde jetzt sagen, eine Cocktailparty,
der Gespräche wegen, was man denn in der Hand hat, ist egal,
also nimmt man halt einen Cocktail.
Cocktail hat Alkohol, könnte man sich das alles auch genauso ohne Alkohol vorstellen?
Ja, es ist nicht so kompliziert, geht durchaus. aus.
Bei diesen Zigaretten kann man nicht einfach die Leute gut duftendes Zeug einatmen
lassen, das sich kurz auf ihren Gaumen legt, ohne dass da noch Nikotin dabei sein muss.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute, denen ist das mit dem Nikotin eigentlich egal.
Ja, die kann man dann nochmal in so eine Sucht reinbringen, aber nur weil Zigaretten
damals Nikotin hatten und so, man kann jetzt auch so Cuts eigentlich mal machen
in der Entwicklung und sagen,
nuckelt doch einfach an Sachen, die dann auch so ein bisschen dampfen und rauchen,
aber ist es jetzt jetzt nicht mehr Nikotin und auch nicht der ganze andere Kram
und überhaupt. Müsste doch irgendwie gehen.
Naja, die Sache ist ja auch die Permanenz, mit der das getan wird.
Ich habe mit einem Bekannten gesprochen, der jetzt auch angefangen hat zu vapen,
der raucht gelegentlich noch eine Zigarette.
Also standen wir draußen, rauchten eine Zigarette.
Dann gingen wir durch die Stadt. Ich hatte ja diese eine Zigarette dann geraucht,
dann war das für mich gut.
Er ging fortwährend neben mir her und vapete.
Das hört gar nicht auf.
Der hört ja gar nicht auf. Das heißt, das kann ja auf Dauer auch nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Sinnvoll sein, wenn wir jetzt eine Gesellschaft sind, die die ganze Zeit was druckt.
Also ich will es jetzt nicht gleich Leuten verbieten, dafür mache ich ja auch
selbst Dinge wie Zigaretten rauchen, die nicht gut sind und will jetzt aber
auch nicht grundsätzlich Verbot bekommen.
Ich finde nur diese Dosierung, die man da vornehmen kann,
also dass man einfach so permanent wie an so einem Tropf fängt,
das finde ich sehr erstaunlich und finde ich kann eigentlich gut zusammengebracht
werden mit einem anderen Gerät, das wir immer mit uns schleppt,
nämlich dem Smartphone.
Also ich würde sagen, dieses ständige nochmal schauen, ob da was ist,
nochmal was aufrufen, gucken, wer hat bei Tinder geschrieben und dieses konstante,
Vapen ist eigentlich etwas, was sehr ähnlich ist und was auch mit Sucht ja beides zu tun hat.
Wir hören mal, was eigentlich mit der Werbung los ist, denn eigentlich kann
es ja keine Tabakwerbung im Fernsehen zum Beispiel geben. Zapp ist dem nachgegangen.
Wir haben einen Hinweis bekommen, Die Tabakindustrie mache trotz Verbot möglicherweise weiterhin Werbung.
Online und in Magazinen. Und das, ohne es als Werbung zu kennzeichnen.
Wir fangen an zu recherchieren, wühlen uns durch diverse Magazine,
Zeitschriften und das Internet.
Zum Thema Rauchen und wie man damit aufhört, finden wir viele Artikel.
Etwa in Zeitschriften wie Echo der Frau, Der Hör zu, der Fernsehzeitung TV Digital
oder auch auf der Nachrichtenseite Wiesbaden lebt.
Dabei fällt eines schnell auf. Zigaretten werden kaum mehr thematisiert.
Anders als Rauchalternativen.
Besonders oft erwähnt der Icos von Philip Morris.
Philip Morris hat schon vor vielen Jahren Interviews gegeben,
in denen es hieß, wir kämpfen nun gegen die Zigarette und man dachte,
was ist da los? Wir hören mal rein.
Nachdem der Tabakkonzern Philip Morris jahrzehntelang Milliarden mit dem Verkauf
von Zigaretten gemacht hat, propagiert das Unternehmen seit einigen Jahren eine neue Strategie.
Alternativen verändern. Die Alternative heißt Icos, ein Tabakerhitzer,
der von Philip Morris entwickelt wurde.
Vermarktet als weniger schädliche Alternative zur Zigarette. Clean und smart.
Statt wilder Westen und Cowboy-Romantik gibt es zu Alcos wissenschaftliche Studien und Erklärvideos.
Das cleane Design erinnert an Technik von Apple und passt in die moderne Produktwelt.
Mich stört ja gar nicht so sehr jetzt, dass man herausgefunden hat,
dass diese E-Zigaretten auch schlecht sind für die Gesundheit,
sondern ich würde vielleicht einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen,
Genüsse haben auch eine Gefahr und sind deshalb auch interessant. Interessant.
Und deshalb muss man sie wohl dosieren.
Und das Versprechen aber jetzt dieser Vapes und all der anderen Geräte,
die es jetzt da gibt, ist, du kannst konstant genießen, aber ohne irgendein Risiko.
Wenn es stimmen würde, wäre es natürlich mega.
Ja, aber dann sind wir wieder in so einem, also das ist ja eigentlich das neue
Ding unseres Kapitalismus, dass wir sagen,
du kannst jetzt, du musst dich nicht mehr selbst zügeln, also musst nicht mehr
selbst dich für einen Genuss oder
gegen einen entscheiden, nimm einfach Osempic, dann wird das erledigt.
Ja genau, aber du musst ja die Dichotomie nicht nur seriell,
also du darfst ab und zu genießen und dann aber lange nicht,
sondern du kannst ja auch das Vergnügen zu unvergnüglichen Sachen.
Also Arbeit ist ungemütlich, aber jetzt, wenn du in der Bibliothek sitzt und
dich auf deinen Staatsexamen vorbereitest, kannst du ja dabei vapen.
Ich glaube in Bibliotheken ist es nicht gestattet, aber ja und das finde ich
aber, da wird es dann wirklich so eine Droge, um zu funktionieren.
Und das ist nicht mehr dieses, wie heißt das Goethe-Wort, Tagesarbeit,
Abendsgäste, saure Wochen, frohe Feste, sondern man will sehen,
dass man die sauren Wochen irgendwie so noch angenehm sich bereitet,
dass man nicht völlig daran zugrunde geht.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist dieses Vapen kein Zeichen dafür,
dass man es mit einer hedonistischen Gesellschaft zu tun hat,
sondern eher mit einer Gesellschaft, die funktionieren muss,
die sich auch nicht erlauben kann, rauszugehen, dort zu rauchen,
irgendetwas zu machen, was nicht so ganz richtig ist, sondern es ist so eine,
die einem erlaubt, zu arbeiten, zu funktionieren.
Auch noch ein bisschen zu vapen. Wir hören mal noch weiter zu diesem Gerät Alkos.
95% weniger Schadstoffe soll die Alkos im Vergleich zu einer Zigarette enthalten,
so der Werbeclaim von Philip Morris. Was ist da dran?
Am Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum in Heidelberg forscht Dr.
Katrin Schaller zum Tabakkonsum und dessen Folgen.
Was sagt sie zu den Werbeversprechen? Es ist so, dass einige Schadstoffe tatsächlich
deutlich reduziert sind.
Andere sind wesentlich weniger stark reduziert.
Und es gibt Substanzen im Aerosol von Tabakerhitzern, die gibt es in Tabakrauch überhaupt nicht.
Also es gibt auch neue Substanzen, von denen man noch gar nicht weiß,
was die im Körper anrichten.
Und diese Erklärung, 95% weniger Schadstoffe, soll natürlich auch suggerieren,
dass es 95% weniger schädlich sei.
Und diesen Schluss kann man nicht ziehen.
Aha. CNBC hat sich mit dem Thema auch beschäftigt und zeigt mal ein bisschen,
wie hoch die Verbreitung ist.
12,9% der Bevölkerung in 2022 gestiegen. Das ist das niedrigste,
das seit den Rekorden begann, im Jahr 2011. Und diese Figuren verändern sich in große Profite.
Das britische-amerikanische Tobak hat von seinen Waproprodukten um 40,3% erhöht
im Jahr 2023, als es im Jahr 2022 war.
Also ist es nicht überraschend, dass das große Tobak auf die Waproprodukte führt.
Aber der große Wachstum im legalen Wapromarkt ist nur eine Seite dieser Geschichte.
In den letzten zehn Jahren haben illegale Wapros große Summen von Geld generiert.
Der Markt kostet zwischen 3 und 4 Billionen. Man könnte estimieren,
und die Intelligenz würde suggerieren, dass der offizielle Markt so viel wie
zwei Drittel davon sein könnte.
Unglaublich großer, illegaler Markt. Da wurde auch dann in Artikeln,
die von Deutschland handelten, immer wieder drauf verwiesen.
Wir hören jetzt noch mal Zahlen zu den Jugendlichen.
In the UK, e-cigarette usage is highest among people aged between 16 and 24,
while one in nine children had experimented with vaping in March 2023,
which is up from one in 13 in the same month in 2022.
So as a fast growing industry both legally and on the black market,
it looks like vaping is here to stay.
Kümmern. Aber wie lange es dauert, dass es wieder in der Popularität steigt, ist noch nicht Die.
Verbreitung ist groß, auch medial. Die BBC hat sich dem Thema angenommen.
Toiletten, und er hat viele von ihnen konfisziert.
Und wir haben sie in einem Laboratorium in Liverpool in der Wissenschaft in
Liverpool genommen, um zu schauen, was in ihnen war.
Nun, wir wissen über Nikotin, und das ist additiv, und einige der Pupillen haben
uns gesagt, dass sie damit effektiv additiv waren, was in dieser Art von Ängsten schlecht genug ist.
But what the lab showed up after testing this batch of products was that in
some of them, levels of metals were very high.
So lead 2.4 times the stipulated safe exposure level, nickel 9.6 times safe
levels, chromium 6.6 times.
And that's based on safety levels generally recognized in the pharmaceutical industry.
Wie kann es sein, dass meine Zigaretten stark reglementiert sind?
Es gab ja früher sehr viel mehr Marken und dann hat man ab einer gewissen Nikotinmenge
gesagt, die dürfen jetzt nicht mehr in Deutschland verkauft werden.
Wie kann es sein, dass man hier eine solche Wildwest-Stimmung noch hat?
Vor allem Nickel, überall wird gewarnt, kaufst du Schmuck, steht dann da,
wie wenig Nickel da drin ist und so und da ist es einfach eine Zigarette.
Da inhaliert man es. Ja.
Also in meiner Lunge habe ich nichts dagegen, aber auf der Haut, nee.
Circa 90 Prozent, wenn die Zahlen stimmen, der E-Zigaretten,
der Vape-Angebote werden in China produziert, also diese kleinen Geräte.
Wir hören jetzt mal, wie das so in China gehandhabt wird. Hier ein ZDF-Bericht.
In Deutschland sind sie der absolute Hype. In China, wo sie millionenfach hergestellt
werden, sind sie verboten.
Vapes, E-Zigaretten mit Fruchtgeschmack. In Deutschland machen sie seit zwei
Jahren nicht nur Erwachsene süchtig.
Ich sehe immer wieder in den Straßen überall, dass Kinder, 12-Jährige,
10-Jährige, sogar unter 10-Jährige, schon da stehen mit den Vapes und rauchen.
Nur in China selbst wollen die Behörden die Fruchtvapes nicht in den Läden sehen,
aus Jugendschutzgründen.
Die Regierung hat den Verkauf verboten wegen des Fruchtgeschmacks,
denn der verführt viele Nichtraucher.
Dazu kommen kistenweise geschmuggelte illegale Vapes aus China und Südostasien.
Der deutsche Zoll hat bereits Hunderttausende sichergestellt,
doch die Bundespolitik scheint bislang hilflos.
Und wir hören weiter. Wie ist das mit diesen Verboten in China?
Ganz anderes Bild in China, dort, wo mehr als 90 Prozent aller E-Zigaretten
weltweit hergestellt werden.
In den Kiosken der Volksrepublik dürfen nur E-Zigaretten mit Tabakgeschmack verkauft werden.
Vapes mit Fruchtaroma sind seit zwei Jahren verboten.
Damals war der größte Teil der Käufer Kinder und junge Leute, Studierende.
Deshalb hat die Regierung den Verkauf verboten, wegen des Fruchtgeschmacks.
Denn der verführt viele Nichtraucher.
Du hast ja hier schon mehrmals über die Zuckersucht gesprochen und wie Cem Özdemir
mal ganz kurz versucht hat, dagegen anzukämpfen und dann hat man das alles sofort wieder einkassiert.
Das haben zuletzt die Nazis gemacht, gegen Zucker zu kämpfen,
Herr Özdemir. Was machen sie da?
So etwa. Und jetzt hat man hier nochmal so ein anderes Zuckerangebot geschaffen,
indem man einfach sagt, das schmeckt ganz süß, nimm es doch.
Ja, aber ich meine, die verordnen ihren Kindern einfach Osempic.
Kein TikTok, wie wir es kennen und keine Vapes.
Die Charité in.
Berlin schlägt Alarm. Zitat, seit 2021 hat sich der Anteil der rauchenden 14-
bis 17-Jährigen fast verdoppelt und rund jedes vierte Schulkind hat schon einmal
Erfahrungen mit E-Zigaretten.
Heißt, bei uns in Deutschland kommen Kinder viel zu leicht an Vapes.
Jetzt hören wir mal den Pressesprecher von Elfbar.
Das ist eines dieser chinesischen Produkte. Er sagt folgendes.
Gemacht. Es gibt eine Whitelist der Befugnisse. Wer auf dieser Liste steht,
dessen E-Zigaretten kommen mit weniger Kontrollen durch den chinesischen Zoll.
Auf Anfrage bestätigt uns Elfbar, Marktführer in Deutschland auf dieser Liste
zu stehen. Als Qualitätsunternehmen.
Auf die Frage, warum Elfbar trotz Verbot im eigenen Land millionenfach Frucht-Flavor-Vapes
nach Deutschland exportiert, sieht man sich nicht in der Verantwortung.
Wir glauben nicht, dass die Aromen Kinder anziehen.
Auch erwachsene Kunden, vor allem die, die versuchen, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören,
brauchen die Geschmacksrichtungen.
Ja, an seiner Stelle würde ich dasselbe sagen. Und es ist aber dann einfach
eine Frage, ob man diese Importe zulässt.
Und das ist nicht das Problem von Elfbar, sondern das ist ein Problem von Deutschland
oder der EU. Wir hören mal weiter.
In jeder Einweg-E-Zigarette ist eine Lithium-Ionen-Batterie verbaut,
die nach dem Dampfen mit der E-Zigarette weggeschmissen wird.
Ziemlich mies für die Umwelt.
Einweg-Vapes senken die Schwelle für Raucher auf ihrem Weg, mit den Zigaretten aufzuhören.
Man kann sie nicht einfach verbieten. Man muss erkennen, dass es dafür einen Bedarf gibt.
In Deutschland gehen jeden Monat rund 5 Millionen Einweg-Vapes über die Ladentheke,
schätzt der Branchenverband Bündnis für Tabakfreien Genuss.
Eine Recyclingpflicht gibt es nicht. Die meisten Tankstellen und Kioske bieten
auch keine Sammelstellen an.
Das ist alles ganz schlecht.
Das ist Wahnsinn, oder?
Ist China eigentlich so ein Büro, wo die so die Zerstörung der Welt organisieren?
Ja, das ist vielleicht die neue Soft-Power-Politik. Ich meine,
wir hatten ja schon diesen Dialog zwischen Biden und Xi,
dass sie beide sich darüber freuten, dass man übereingekommen ist,
dass man jetzt nicht mehr die Menschen abhängig macht von diesen neuen Drogen.
Diese Opiate sind das.
Und jetzt hat man natürlich auf dem Level nicht dasselbe.
Aber was man generell sehen kann, man kann also Menschen heute wieder in neuer
Art und Weise abhängig machen, beziehungsweise diese ganzen extremen Nichtraucherschutzgesetze.
Und ich sage jetzt hier extrem, weil ich es bei manchen Dingen wirklich ein
bisschen albern fand und finde, also wo man sagen kann, hier sind jetzt Erwachsene
unter sich und die können auch Dinge entscheiden,
aber das hat nicht dazu geführt, dass einfach die Sucht aufhört,
sondern die Sucht verlagert sich.
Und jetzt kann ich natürlich auch wieder Dinge hier verbieten und manche Regeln
sind wohl dringend nötig.
Aber man muss ja auch hier immer fragen, warum setzt sich so etwas gerade so durch?
Wir wissen, dass gerade junge Leute unter sehr viel Stress leiden,
Mental Health und all das.
Greift man dann eher zu einem Ersatz, wenn man das andere nicht bekommt?
Dürfen doch jetzt alle kiffen.
Sind diese, ja, sind diese, ja, das ist auch die Frage. Also sind diese, ähm,
Phänomene, die wir jetzt hier beobachten, natürlich politisch so lösbar,
dass man jetzt Verbote ausspricht.
Ich bin auch grundsätzlich nicht dagegen, einige Sachen dazu verbieten oder
stärker zu reglementieren, aber die Sache ist auch, dass natürlich erst ein
gewisser Umstand, auch ein ökonomischer Umstand dazu führen kann,
dass man dies oder das macht.
Jetzt will die EU auch da das strenger regeln.
Sie will zum Beispiel jetzt, dass man diese Einwegprodukte weiterhin zwar kaufen
kann, aber dass man den Akku rausnehmen kann und separiert dann entsorgen kann.
Aber wer wird das schon tun, fragt man sich. Wir hören jetzt mal ganz kurz in
eine Bundestagsdebatte rein.
Wir springen also ein bisschen und könnten da mal gerade hören,
was Hans-Jürgen Thies von der CDU-CSU sagt, denn die Ampel hätte jetzt die Chance
gehabt, viel stärker das zu regulieren.
Mit der vorliegenden Änderung des Tabakerzeugnisgesetzes wurde leider die Chance
vertan, Einweg-E-Zigaretten zu verbieten.
Der Bundesrat forderte bereits in seinem Beschluss vom 03.03.2023,
dass die Bundesregierung sich für ein nationales und ein EU-weites Verbot von
Einweg-E-Zigaretten einsetzen solle.
Nun, dreieinhalb Monate sind vergangen und man hört und liest aus den Reihen
der Bundesregierung in dieser Richtung überhaupt nichts.
Dabei werden aktuell, meine Damen und Herren, in Deutschland jeden Monat mit
deutlich steigender Tendenz circa drei Millionen Einweg-E-Zigaretten gekauft,
geraucht und letztlich achtlos weggeworfen.
Wir hören ihn noch weiter.
Letztlich vertan wurde mit diesem Gesetzentwurf leider auch die Chance,
den Rechtsstatus von Nikotin- und Tabakbeuteln, also von Snooze und von Pouches, zu klären.
Snooze sind Tabakerzeugnisse zum oralen Gebrauch. Sie sind daher in Deutschland verboten.
Pouches sind tabakfreie Nikotinbeutel, die nach lebensmittelrechtlichen Vorschriften
zu behandeln wären und damit eigentlich in Deutschland auch nicht gehandelt werden dürfen.
Tatsache ist dennoch, dass beide Arten von Beuteln leider sehr leicht im Online-Handel
zu erlangen sind und auch in manchen Tabakgeschäften leider erworben werden können.
Hast du von Snooze schon gehört? Ein Riesenphänomen, kommen wir gleich nochmal in einem Clip drauf.
Jetzt können wir uns überlegen in der Ampel, wie werden da so die Einzelnen
eingestellt sein zu dem Thema oder wer könnte möglicherweise verhindert haben,
also ich weiß es natürlich nicht, aber wer könnte verhindert haben,
dass es da Verschärfungen gibt.
Nun machen wir uns selbst ein Bild, wir hören Gero Hocker von der FDP.
Der Ausstieg aus der Nikotinsucht, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren,
der ist für viele allerdings nicht trivial und gelingt trotz zahlreicher Anläufe
vielen Menschen nicht ohne weiteres.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass wir gehalten sind als Gesetzgeber,
Wege aufzuzeigen, die es ermöglichen, Menschen,
die von der konventionellen Zigarette abhängig sind, Wege aufzuzeigen,
die es ihnen ermöglichen, von den besonders gesundheitsschädlichen Folgen des
Konsums von Zigaretten, nämlich Kohlenmonoxid, was beim Verbrennungsprozess freigesetzt wird,
wegzukommen und ihnen andere Alternativen an die Hand zu geben.
Das ist unsere Verantwortung, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, als Gesetzgeber.
Ohnehin schon süchtigen Menschen wie Rauchern von konventionellen Zigaretten,
sie auch noch der maximalen Gefahr bei der der Befriedigung dieser Sucht auszusetzen,
das kann und darf nicht der Weg dieses Parlaments und auch nicht der Bundesregierung
sein, meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren.
Das ist also Gesundheitsschutz, ja. Das ist eine Ausstiegsdroge,
keine Einstiegsdroge, eine Ausstiegsdroge.
Und wenn du jetzt die verbietest, dann führst du die Leute ja näher an die Zigaretten an.
Und ich sage es ausdrücklich, ich weiß, dass das etwas zugespitzt ist,
aber niemand hier im Saal würde Süchtigen das Methadon verweigern,
weil das zweifellos mit Nebenwirkungen und die Einnahme zweifellos mit Nebenwirkungen
verbunden ist. Und deswegen...
Also Methadon bekommen ja wirklich Leute, wo man sagt, die muss man irgendwie
von der Heroinabhängigkeit losbekommen. Wir sprechen ja hier doch noch von was anderem.
Muss eben auch für alternative...
Alternative Möglichkeiten tatsächlich auch geworben werden.
Deswegen müssen möglichst viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen auch möglich
sein, damit eben der Umstieg möglichst leicht gemacht wird.
Und deswegen, und das ist das Zentrale, meine Damen und Herren,
müssen wir tatsächlich solche Technologien auch aus der Illegalität in die Legalität,
herüberholen, gerade um die Abgabe tatsächlich auch regulatorisch erfassen zu
können, um gerade tatsächlich dafür zu sorgen, dass nicht in irgendwelchen osteuropäischen
Laboren, Ingredienten sozusagen,
zusammengepanscht werden und die Menschen sich noch viel größeren,
Gefahren aussetzen würde.
Technologieoffenheit.
Diese FDP ist wirklich...
Man hält es nicht mehr aus. Ja, und die Sache ist, wir müssen also möglichst
viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen anbieten.
Dann erst werden die konventionellen Raucher sagen, das ist ja super,
aber es kommen keine neuen nach.
Also um die, das wird ja nicht passieren. Es geht jetzt nur um so eine Ausstiegsbrücke.
Die Leute weisen auch nach, wenn sie zur Tanke gehen, dass sie Raucher sind.
Und dann bekommen sie ihr Methadon, ja. Nun, wir springen jetzt noch ganz kurz
zu einem SWR-Bericht, nämlich nur fragt man sich ja, wie kann sich das so sehr verbreiten?
Ich habe da mal so ein bisschen mir Twitch-Streams angesehen.
Da sitzen die ja alle und vapen.
Und Hip-Hopper haben ja ihre eigenen Marken. Die verkaufen millionenfach Einfach diese Vapes.
Also wir können eigentlich, ich finde es so interessant, dass diese ganzen Montana
Black, Sido und diese ganzen, also aus diesem ganzen Bereich Hip-Hop, Twitch-Stream,
Glücksspiel-Universum, ja, also diese ganzen schrecklichen Leute,
so will ich sie jetzt mal nennen.
Ich glaube, man sagt dann auch Real Talk bei Twitch, bevor man sowas dann anfängt
zu sagen, wie ich das hier vorhabe.
Diese Leute sitzen da und sind immens reich geworden, nicht durch Talent,
sondern das Einzige, was ihnen geglückt ist, ist das, was immer wieder in der
Menschheitsgeschichte passiert ist.
Was kann man am besten tun, um an das Geld anderer Leute zu kommen?
Man macht sie in irgendeiner Weise abhängig von Glücksspielen,
man füttert sie mit Eistee,
man füttert sie mit schlechter Pizza und jetzt jubelt man ihnen noch Vapes unter
und dann kann man sich selbst immens daran bereichern und ist aber gleichzeitig
bei diesen jungen Leuten auch noch so eine Art Hero und Gallionsfigur.
Also die Zahlen sind da unheimlich in die Höhe gegangen im Jahr 2023,
haben tatsächlich fast 38 Prozent der 14- bis 17-Jährigen angegeben,
in dem Jahr schon mal eine E-Zigarette gedampft zu haben. Und das sind wirklich bedenkliche Zahlen.
Ja, wie kommt das? Liegt es daran, dass die Tabakindustrie andere Wege gefunden
hat, außerhalb der Werbung an die Kinder und Jugendlichen ranzukommen?
Nein, das ist schon vor allen Dingen auch die Werbung, die ja eigentlich verboten ist.
Aber sie wird natürlich vor allen Dingen stark beworben in den sozialen Medien,
in denen ja Jugendliche ständig unterwegs sind, eigentlich sozusagen den ganzen Tag.
Dann gibt es viele Idole, viele Vorbilder, die eben für E-Zigaretten werben.
Auf TikTok, auf Instagram, sonst überall kann man die durchaus noch finden.
Und natürlich auch an den Verkaufsorten. Also gehen Sie mal in eine Tankstelle
zum Beispiel, da sehen Sie reihenweise die buntesten Vapes, die man sich nur vorstellen kann.
Ja, extrem bunt. Das ist fast wie so ein kleines Toys R Us, wenn du da reingehst.
Nun ist das hier gar nicht das Einzige, was so verbreitet ist bei jungen Leuten.
Anderes Phänomen hören wir jetzt hier beim Länderspiegel.
Überreste von Lachgas-Partys in der Kölner Innenstadt.
Der Park am Kaiser Wilhelmring ist regelmäßig vollgemüllt mit benutzten Luftballons, leeren Kartuschen.
Zu kaufen ist der kurze Kick am Kiosk um die Ecke, ohne Altersbeschränkung,
bunt, aromatisiert, in immer größeren Flaschen.
Kaum ein Jugendlicher, der Lachgas nicht kennt.
Ja, in der Schule ist es eher so etwas Temporäres, was die Leute dann nehmen.
Was sie dann für einen kurzen Moment glücklich macht oder in dem Fall benommen. Aber sonst ...
Ich nehme es nicht, nein. Ich kenne halt Leute, die das auch schon konsumiert
haben. Was hältst du davon?
Schwachsinn. Schwachsinn. Man hört ja von genug Leuten, die da irgendwie negative Folgen mitnehmen.
Also für die paar Sekunden, die man da erlebt, finde ich völligen Schwachsinn.
Die mehr oder weniger spontanen Lachgas-Partys sind völlig legal.
Das Gas wird in Ballons gefüllt und eingeatmet, verursacht Lachanfälle und einen kurzen Rausch.
Nach 30 Sekunden fühlst du dich wie der Pate von Frankfurt.
Ein zweifelhaftes Vergnügen, das Folgen haben kann. Wenn man zu viel nimmt,
dann könnte man ohnmächtig werden.
Dann fällt man halt um. Die Gefahr ist, dass man mit dem Kopf gegen die Kante
stößt und dass man dann nicht mehr aufsteht danach.
In Wuppertal hat der Lachgas-Trend so stark zugenommen, dass die Stadt Ende
April die Bundesregierung aufgefordert
hat, das Rauschmittel als Droge im Jugendschutzgesetz aufzunehmen.
Experten warnen schon länger vor neurologischen Schäden.
War dir das auch klar, dass das so ein Phänomen ist?
Ja, ich wusste, dass es riesig ist und ich weiß, dass es in keinem anderen Land
der Welt einfach so verfügbar ist.
Und ich habe auch schon private Sicherheitskamera-Aufnahmen so gesehen,
wo einfach Leute stehend umfallen und dann wirklich mit dem Kopf so knapp an
der Kante vorbei. Das ist crazy.
Kommen wir noch zu einem letzten Clip. Snooze wurde eben schon erwähnt.
Wir hören einen Beitrag von Bloomberg.
Lippe geschnitten, um einen Nikotin-Buzz zu bekommen. Und, abhängig von wem
du fragst, ist Snooze der Grund, weshalb Schweden fast aus dem Smoken-Takt ist.
Nur 5,6% der Schweden haben im Jahr 2022 gesmokt.
Das ist das niedrigste Prozent in Europa und in der Tatsache des 5%-Takts,
wo ein Land sich smokefrei bezeichnen kann. Swedish smoking rates have fallen
by over half in the past 15 years.
Today, only 5% of men and about 6% of women smoke.
But about 15% of the population uses snus. Mostly men, but women are a fast-growing market.
Women tend to use nicotine pouches, a relatively new product that appeared less than a decade ago.
Think of them like snus, but with no tobacco.
Stattdessen sind sie aus Pflanzenfibern mit Nikotin kombiniert.
Ich bin in Nikoteket. Das ist eine Nikotinstore.
In einer Store wie dieser kann man eine gewöhnliche Plethora von Nikotinprodukten finden.
Vapes, Nikotinpouches und traditionelle
Snus. Das eine, was man hier nicht finden kann, sind Zigaretten.
Ja, es ist ein wunderschöner Laden, wo man auch sicherlich prima Parfum verkaufen
könnte, aber es gibt dort alle Sorten an Zigarettenersatz.
Nur Zigaretten gibt es nicht mehr dort zu kaufen.
Ich habe davon noch nie gehört.
Es ist ein so großes...
Jetzt legt man sich unter die Oberlippe.
Ja, es ist Kautabak, so wie man das früher hatte.
Kautabak wurde ja auch nicht gekaut die ganze Zeit, sondern den schob man sich
dann da unter das Zahnfleisch quasi und dann wirkt das und gibt dann einen Wirkstoff ab.
Und das ist etwas, was so verbreitet ist, dass auch die Politiker dort Werbung
für Snooze machen und damit kokettieren, dass sie alle Snooze nehmen.
Es gab dazu einen sehr interessanten Artikel im Spiegel von Jan Petter,
der hat das mal aufgedrückt, wie dieser schwedische Wahlkampf da verlaufen ist
und wie eng das gekoppelt war mit Snooze.
Was man glaube ich festhalten kann ist, dass wir es mit einer Gesellschaft zu tun haben,
die die wirkliche Rauschhafte im Sinne von ein Festerleben,
dass diese Gesellschaft eigentlich immer mehr ausstirbt.
Also wirklich die Gesellschaft, die feiert, die Gesellschaft,
die genießt und sicherlich auch da den einen oder anderen Grenzübertritt wagt,
aber die quasi das Außeralltägliche,
Im Fest und im Rausch sieht. Was hier eigentlich stattfindet ist,
Suchtstoffe in den Alltag zu integrieren, damit der Alltag und das Funktionieren
im System weiterlaufen kann.
Das heißt, es ist genau das Gegenteil. Es ist nicht, wenn wir sagen,
wir nehmen den Salon auf und gehen danach noch in die Oper und dann in der Bar trinken wir dann noch.
Aber wir könnten das mit dem Salon verbinden. Wir sitzen hier,
trinken Frankfurt Sauer und rauchen.
Das geht ja zum Beispiel nicht. Also die Sache ist ja die, wenn ich jetzt wirklich
diesen kleinen Rausch haben will, dann kann ich dann nicht arbeiten.
Also ich kann nicht Cocktail trinken und Podcast machen.
Aber das hier sind alles Produkte, die sagen, du kannst weiter hustlen und noch
so ein bisschen deine Sucht befriedigen, damit es weitergeht.
Also es ist genau das, was eigentlich gebraucht wird, damit die Leute weiterarbeiten.
Eigentlich kann man es ein bisschen verbinden mit dem, was der Kaffee tat im 19.
Jahrhundert. Es gibt ja Fälle, von denen auch Marx im Kapital berichtet,
dass man Arbeiter, vor allem auch Arbeiterinnen, immer wieder mit Kaffee abgefüllt
hat, damit die länger arbeiten können.
Und wir gehen ein bisschen in diese Richtung gerade.
Und dann gibt es, glaube ich, generell eine Industrie, die darauf aus ist, Sucht herzustellen.
Und das ist dann einmal eine solche Industrie mit Vapes und Snooze und all dem.
Und dann haben wir die große Smartphone-Industrie, will ich sie nennen.
Und wir hatten mal diesen wunderbaren Text im Salon, wo es darum ging, ja …,
Also Kulturindustrie und Kunst, das hat man immer so als Differenz gedacht,
aber beides wird jetzt eigentlich geschluckt von einer süchtig machenden Industrie
und das ist TikTok, sind all die anderen Apps.
Short Videos und Rapes.
Machen einen dann so nervös, dass man, um wieder runterzukommen,
wahrscheinlich dann Kautabak braucht.
Und in dieser Konstellation sind wir gerade, und hier würde ich das nochmal
anschließen an dein Bildungsthema, je mehr Menschen auf sich alleine gestellt
sind und irgendwie sich durchwurschteln müssen,
desto eher werden sie auch darauf zurückgreifen, auf irgendwelche Mittel,
die ihnen dabei helfen, das Alltägliche zu bewältigen.
Denn es sind Alltagsbewältigungsdrogen, es sind nicht die Drogen,
die den rauschhaften Moment, an den man sich erinnert, kreieren,
sondern es sind Drogen, die dafür sorgen, dass man funktioniert,
dass man weiter arbeitsam ist und dass man in gewisser Weise auch brav ist.
Das stimmt. Nicht zu unterschätzen. Nicht nur ordentlich arbeiten,
sondern die Arbeit auch brav erledigen.
Ja.
Okay, Abschlussthema, die Boomer.
Ich schleppe ja seit einer Weile hier Clips von Josef Harder mit mir.
Wir kennen ihn, hier ist so ein kurzer Kulturzeitbeitrag in typischer Form,
nur damit man kurz versteht, falls man ihn nicht kennt, vielleicht erkennt man ihn an der Stimmlage.
Scharfzüngig, selbstironisch. So präsentiert sich Harder zuverlässig bei seinen Solos.
Also scharfzünig und selbstironisch. Oder auch, man könnte sagen,
bei dem, was wir gleich hören, einfach mal ehrlich und direkt.
Er hat jedenfalls ein Bühnenprogramm, wo er solo auf der Bühne sitzt und einen Boomer spielt.
Zufälle gibt es hier keine. Dafür trefft sich ihre Pointen auch bei Hader on Ice.
Aber Vorsicht beim Lachen. Was mich wirklich, muss ich sagen,
ein bisschen kränkt persönlich bei diesen Bettlern ist, ich gebe ihnen auch
oft was, ich gebe ihnen gern was, dann gehe ich weiter, erledige fünf Minuten
was, komme wieder zurück, was passiert?
Er bettelt dich sofort wieder an. Er kann sich nicht erinnern an dich,
das ist ein liebloser Umgang.
Das mag ich ja gar nicht auf der Bühne stehen und eins zu eins sagen,
was ich denke. Erstens finde ich das urlangweilig, künstlerisch.
Zweitens will ich gar nicht genau, dass alle so ganz genau wissen,
was ich denke, weil da lehnen sie sich zurück und denken sich,
das ist ja ein zuverlässiger Kabarettist.
Wir sind auch im Großen und Ganzen seiner Meinung. Ist ja im Kabarett so,
das Publikum ist ja immer derselben Meinung, circa, wie der Kabarettist.
Ich habe mir immer gedacht, so richtig, wenn es im Kabarett so bequem wird,
ist der Unterschied zum Bierzelt gar nicht mehr so weit, weil alle einer Meinung
sind und sich gegenseitig vergewissern, dass eh alles passt.
So, er will also auf der Bühne sitzen, über Boomer reden, im Monolog,
wie wir es eben auch schnitzweise gesehen haben.
Und es soll nicht zu sehr bierzeltartig werden, weil wenn einfach nur alle dieselbe
Meinung teilen und einer wird gefeiert, weil er sie besonders gut vorträgt, dann wäre das blöd.
Jetzt hören wir Elke Heidenreich, wie sie in dieser 3 nach 9 oder welcher auch
immer Talkshow im rechtlichen Rundfunk sitzt.
Und dort auch als recht ältere Frau über ihre Generation so spricht.
Heißt es ja, Alte sind nicht mehr interessant und leisten nichts mehr.
Und auch dagegen schreibe ich an, wir sind schon sehr wohlwichtig.
Und gerade meine Generation, unsere Generation, die ja angeblich jetzt an allem
schuld ist, die ja von den Jungen sehr beschimpft wird.
Gerade unsere Generation hat nicht nur die 68er hervorgebracht,
Die verdruckste Moral befreit, den Paragraphen 175, schwulen Paragraph abgeschafft, 218 geknackt.
Wir haben Greenpeace gegründet, Amnesty International, Ärzte ohne Grenzen, die Grünen gegründet.
Das sollen die uns erstmal nachmachen, diese nächste Generation.
Eine ganze Menge, ja. Wir waren gut.
Gabriel hat schon mitgeschrieben. To-do-List? Nein, ich habe da ein großes Selbstbewusstsein,
weil wir Alten sind jetzt angeblich an allem schuld. Wir haben ja die Entwertung
der Welt, wie sie jetzt gerade ist, nicht ahnen können.
Die Entwertung durch Pandemien, durch Kriege, durch Nationalismus, durch den Klimawandel.
Wenn wir ein paar Mal nach Palermo in die Oper geflogen sind,
haben wir nicht gewusst, dass das was mit Klimawandel zu tun hat. Das lernen wir ja jetzt.
Aber ich finde, das, was meine Generation konnte, hat sie gemacht.
Wir haben die Sache nicht so in die Scheiße gefahren. Und jetzt muss man sehen,
wie man mit dem fertig wird, was jetzt gerade die Probleme sind.
Wir hatten die Nazi-Eltern, ihr habt den Nationalismus.
Also sehr viele Sachen, die sie so sagt.
Ausgründen, den Zeitgeist einfangen. Und der Anlass ist, wir werden ja hier
aus dem Spiel genommen und für alles verantwortlich gemacht.
Und jetzt würde ich sagen, naja, typischerweise sind einfach diejenigen verantwortlich,
die dann und dann gelebt haben, als ein Zeitgeist herrschte und so weiter, was eben auch bedeutet.
Und deswegen auch dieser interessante Clip, den wir noch nie gespielt haben, aber als in,
Weimar dieses Museum eröffnet wurde, über Bauhaus im Nationalsozialismus und,
ach nee, nicht Bauhaus sondern in Weimar gibt es jetzt ein Museum zur Zwangsarbeit.
20 Millionen Betroffene und die hatten einen Betroffenen noch da,
der sich heute dann vor den Fernsehkameras die Frage stellte,
was wäre, wenn ich damals Hitlerjugend gewesen wäre und nicht Jude?
Und dieses, ich nehme mich mal selber raus aus dem Bild und sehe das große Ganze.
Da könnte man ja jetzt von der jungen Generation verlangen, einfach so eine Einsicht.
Wenn ihr damals wir gewesen wärt, hättet ihr dasselbe gemacht.
Und dann hätten wir alle gesagt, ja, genau.
Wir wären auch immer nach Palermo geflogen in die Oper. So mehrfach auch, ne?
Da sieht man auch so ein bisschen, nee, vor 40 Jahren sind nicht Leute mehrfach
in die Oper nach Palermo, sondern das war schon, es gab hier Leute,
die haben es ein bisschen übertrieben.
Schicht, ja.
So, was aber jetzt im Gegenzug dann wieder bedeutet, wenn man auf der einen
Seite aufzählt, Ärzte ohne Grenzen,
Amnesty International und so weiter und den Schwulenparagrafen abgeschafft und
dafür reklamiert man eine Verantwortung, das haben wir gemacht.
Und dann kommen aber die negativen Sachen, die unausgesprochen im Raum stehen,
weshalb sie ja diesen Debate Prep hier, den sie gut gemacht hat,
umsetzt und dann aber sagt, wir werden jetzt immer verantwortlich gemacht.
Ja, du hast dich selber gerade verantwortlich gemacht für die positiven Sachen.
Was ist jetzt mit den negativen Sachen?
Und dann würde man auch unterstellen, dass man um den Klimawandel schon ein
bisschen früher als gestern wusste.
Ja, also die Nobelpreise, die jetzt vergeben wurden zum Thema Klimawandelforschung,
sind alle in den 70ern erbracht worden.
Ja, ich meine, Sie erwähnt ja die Grünen. Die Grünen haben ja niemals in ihrem
Programm stehen gehabt, bitte fliegt oft in die Oper nach Palermo.
Genau. So, worauf ich jetzt hinaus will ist…,
Es gibt Vergangenheit für uns nur relevant im Gegenwärtigen.
Die Frage ist jetzt kulturell, politisch vor allem, wie ziehen wir denn aus
den Erfahrungen, die wir gemacht haben, Erwartungen an die Zukunft?
Müssen wir jetzt etwas ändern? Und wir stellen ja fest, ja, wir müssen etwas ändern.
Sonst würde Elke Heltenreich jetzt nicht sagen, bis jetzt war schon ganz gut
oder wir wissen auch, das ist jetzt und so weiter.
Aber das muss jetzt die nächste Generation machen. Joseph Hader ist jetzt nicht als Bühnenrolle,
sondern in der Sternstunde Philosophie, um dort aber dieselben Themen zu besprechen,
also ein Selbstgespräch des Boomers, vielleicht sogar mit einem Boomer,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt der Dings ist, wir hören ihn gleich.
Und er entscheidet sich für einen anderen Umgang mit ich werde damit verantwortlich
gemacht, ja, so verhalte ich mich auch dazu, wie sie hier verhalten wurde und verhalten wird.
Und das hören wir mal in zwei Abschnitten, weil ich finde, Josef Hader macht
das wirklich dafür, dass ich das Bühnenprogramm, ich habe ein bisschen mehr
da gesehen als jetzt nur dieser eine Ausschnitt,
das würde ich mir jetzt nicht angucken, weil da redet wirklich ein Boomer für
die Boomer und es ist mir auch erstmal unglaublich, ob er das ironisch meint
oder nicht, sondern da kommt so diese Diese falsche Selbstgewissheit,
wie von Elke Heidenreich, als Bühnenprogramm in Länge.
Das ist aber ganz anders in dieser Sternstunde Philosophie, weshalb wir uns
das in zwei Clips anhören.
Ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich eine Sache, die sehr besonders ist und noch nie war.
Nämlich, dass die Leute, die
60 und 70 sind, die Bevölkerungsmehrheit stellen in einer Gesellschaft.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemals in der Weltgeschichte schon mal passiert ist. Was schon mal bedeutet.
Demokratien entscheiden die Mehrheiten. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach sagen,
die Jüngeren müssen es jetzt irgendwie besser machen.
Eine Generation, die ist so angetreten in den 60ern und 70ern,
die wollten alles anders machen.
Die haben gesagt, Regeln akzeptieren wir nicht.
Das Althergebrachte. Die 68er, wie man so sagt. Genau.
Und jetzt ist diese Generation, glaube ich, kann man sagen, hat so krachend
versagt wie kaum eine andere.
Man kann es immer gut festmachen an dem Unterschied zwischen Helmut Schmidt
oder Willy Brandt und Gerhard Schröder.
Das beschreibt eigentlich, welche Art von Anständigkeit in der Generation vorher war.
In Österreich gibt es auch Beispiele, die kennt hier niemand.
Also unseren sozialdemokratischen ehemaligen Kanzler und Parteichef,
der im Aufsichtsrat sitzt in diesem Konzern, der krachend runtergegangen ist,
der Millionen kassiert.
Also es hat diese Generation wirklich versagt. Das kann man, glaube ich, sagen.
Und jetzt, aber sie hat unglaublich profitiert. Sie hat in diesem Erdteil wahnsinnig
profitiert. Denen ging es richtig gut.
Fast allen, nicht allen, ist klar. Und jetzt stehen sie sozusagen vor dem Tod
in den nächsten 20 Jahren.
Das betrifft mich ja auch. Und das
Spannende ist jetzt, dass die ihre Deutungshoheit nicht abgeben wollen.
Dass die nicht diese Rolle für sich annehmen wollen, die sie den alten Leuten
in den 60er- und 70er-Jahren zugemutet haben.
Da sind sie mit Glockenhosen und langen Haaren da gestanden,
haben eine Sprache gesprochen,
wo sie sich gefreut haben, dass die alten Leute das nicht verstehen,
die durchsetzt waren mit irgendwelchen englischen Vokabeln und haben die alten
Leute fertig gemacht, haben Universitätsprofessoren mit Megafonen angeschrien.
Das war cool. Und jetzt sitzt dieselbe Generation wehleidig in ihren Ohrsesseln
und sagt, das darf man nicht mehr sagen. und ich bin so arm,
weil ich mit 75 jetzt bei der großen Fernsehshow abtreten muss.
Das ist eine Generation, die hat nie Regeln beachtet und möchte Deutungshoheit bis ins Grab.
Und die unangenehme Wahrheit, glaube ich, ist, dass Donald Trump ein Kind dieser Zeit ist.
So, er kriegt jetzt die Nachfrage, ist denn gar nichts Positives übrig geblieben?
Aber es ist sehr schön, das Thema Gottschalk nochmal aufgetroffen.
Es gab doch auch viele große Aufbrüche innerhalb dieser Zeit.
Es gab einen ganz linken sozialdemokratischen Aufbruch von der Neuen Linken
mit Tony Blair, mit Bill Clinton, mit Gerhard Schröder.
Das war ein riesen Aufbruchsversprechen.
Und man würde ja nicht unbedingt sagen, dass die nichts bewirkt haben.
Sie würden sagen, das war zwar ein wichtiger Schritt, aber in die falsche Richtung.
Was hat denn Gerhard Schröder, Clinton, was ist denn geblieben? Was war denn?
Was haben die denn wirklich weitergebracht? Also ich will jetzt nicht streiten über Politiker, aber,
Es ist doch sonnenklar, dass vorher eine anständigere Politikergeneration war
und jetzt eine, die sich bereichert.
Früher sind Politiker, der Bundeskanzler Sinovac, ein österreichischer Bundeskanzler,
den habe ich getroffen im Südburgenland auf der Straße. Als kleiner Bauer ist
er dahergekommen und hat von seiner Rente gelebt in seinem kleinen Haus.
Und jetzt sitzen die alle in Aufsichtsräten. Kann mir doch keiner einreden,
dass das System sich nicht verschlechtert hat.
Wir sollten doch nicht so tun, als wäre das.
Alles selbstverständlich. Ist es so selbstverständlich, dass Politiker,
die eine gute Rente bekommen, in die Industrie und in die Wirtschaft gehen und sich dort bereichern?
Ist das so? Das war früher in Amerika.
Und das ist kein System, das man so eins zu eins übernehmen sollte in der Demokratie.
Die sind ein Beispiel, wie eine Demokratie sich nicht gut entwickelt.
In der Hinsicht, wir haben mit der Debatte begonnen. Das sehen wir dann in 15
Jahren auch in Deutschland so.
Ja, was er da über die Politik sagt, ist richtig und auch gerade was er über
die Leute sagt, die einfach damit berühmt wurden,
dass sie Regeln brechen und die anderen von ihren Positionen vertreiben,
sind es natürlich jetzt genau diejenigen, die auf keinen Fall bereit sind,
irgendetwas abzugeben.
Das kann man auch gerade im Hochkulturbereich gut sehen.
Ich würde aber auch immer sagen, die danach kommen, sind dann auch wieder nicht besser.
Also man hat ja so gewisse MeToo-Wellen jetzt oder so gehabt im hochkulturellen Bereich auch.
Naja, also oder man hat zum Beispiel sich sehr abgearbeitet in Deutschland an
den autoritären Theatermachern,
die einfach sechs Wochen Probe machen und permanent schreien. Nein.
Ja, kann man machen, aber ich höre dann ja interessanterweise so von den jungen
Wilden, die so Mitte 30 sind und jetzt in diesem System sind,
dass die sich natürlich genauso verhalten, sobald sie auf den Posten sind.
Und wir sehen ja gerade auch an den Jungen, deswegen bin ich halt auch sehr
gegen eine Chlorifizierung der Jungen.
Wir haben ja jetzt Albrecht von Lucke noch im Ohr, für die, die den Salon nicht abonniert haben.
Albrecht von Lucke haben wir gecancelt und zwar lang und ausführlich in der
Live-Show und er ist ja dann derjenige, der sagt, ja die jungen Leute sollen
einfach in die Politik gehen.
Wir haben wahnsinnig viele junge Leute in der Politik und sie haben sogar auch
Chancen bekommen, sie haben nämlich wahnsinnig gute Listenplätze bekommen,
sodass wenn man dreieinhalb Semester pädagogisch studiert hat und man schon
mal Kasperl der Theater gespielt hat, jetzt Bundestagsmandat bekommen hat.
Ich will das gar nicht abwertend sagen, es klingt aber so, vielleicht meine ich es auch so.
Aber von diesen jedenfalls könnte man ja dann noch erwarten,
dass sie wenigstens aus Dankbarkeit über dieses große Glück sich so verhalten,
wie junge Leute sich verhalten könnten,
wenn sie die Anliegen ihrer jungen Altersgenossen ernst nehmen. Tun sie aber nicht. Mhm.
Ich will mich auf niemanden mehr verlassen.
Du sagst es polemisch, aber meinst es voll Herzen, wie Albrecht von Lucke sagte.
Okay, dann sonst weiter mit der Cancel Culture. Wir haben ja Albrecht von Lucke gecancelt.
Josef Harder sagt ja auch was zum Thema Cancel Culture. Es ist eine,
finde ich, sehr gute Einschätzung.
Meiner Meinung nach, man kann alles machen in der Satire, aber man muss ein
bisschen genauer sein und klüger sich überlegen, wo man was platziert Und wie man,
weil ohne Provokation, ohne Ambivalenz, macht es ja keinen Spaß.
Und Sie glauben, diese ganze Rede von den neuen Grenzen des Humors,
das ist einfach Quatsch und letztlich eine handwerkliche Frage.
Ich glaube, es gibt diesen alten Satz, der auch von Karl Kraus sein könnte,
aber in Wirklichkeit von Nestor ist, Witze, die der Zensor versteht, sind eh schlecht.
Das heißt, wer so banal seine Witze macht, dass er nach den Regeln der Wokeness
irgendwie nicht ganz entspricht, Der ist einfach zu dumm, dass er das gescheit macht.
Aber damit haben doch viele ihrer Kollegen offenbar Probleme.
Also wenn wir Sachen canceln, dann nur, weil sie zu dumm sind.
Dann gehören sie aussortiert.
Wir vertagen uns auf den Salon, weisen nochmal darauf hin, wir werden uns mit
den Gebrüdern Semsrott auseinandersetzen.
Hane Semsrott hat das Buch Machtübernahme geschrieben.
Was passiert, wenn Rechtsextremisten regieren? Eine Anleitung zum Widerstand,
wir sind sehr gespannt darauf, er ist ja von Frag den Staat,
das heißt er hat Einblicke in die institutionellen und politischen Zusammenhänge.
Sein Bruder hat die Praxis versucht im Europaparlament, Nico Semsrott,
sein Buch Brüssel sehen und sterben lesen wir auch.
Außerdem werde ich noch ein Buch vorstellen des Philosophen Gunnar Hindrichs,
der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Abseits des Krieges und versucht eine
philosophische Antwort darauf zu geben, wie wir uns jetzt eigentlich dazu verhalten,
dass Krieg stattfindet, dass Aufrüstung stattfindet, dass die Geopolitik komplizierter wird.
Wir versuchen also eine philosophische Antwort darauf zu finden.
Alles andere will ich mir noch offen lassen.
Gut. Ich bringe das Buch von Christian Drosten mit.
Er hat sich mit Hilfe von Georg Maskolo, der ihm schon sehr kritische Fragen
stellt, aber eben auch kritisch zum Thema eingestellt ist, Sachen erzählen lassen
zur Corona-Pandemie. Pandemie, insbesondere zum Verhältnis Sachentscheidung.
Wie war das jetzt mit den Schulschließungen?
Dann Politiker. Sind die eigentlich alle doof oder gibt es noch einen,
wo man, wenn man einmal im politischen Kontext drin ist, Bevölkerung?
Und den Teil habe ich noch nicht gelesen, Medien. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Also bisher sehr gute Lektüre, da stecken ein paar interessante Sachen drin.
Außerdem ist unser Hörer Klaus Badenhagen Taiwanese, zumindest im Kopfe.
Er lebt auf Taiwan und hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben, die wichtigste Insel
der Welt, was sie wissen müssen, um Taiwan zu verstehen.
Da wir alle Taiwan verstehen müssen und mich vor allem interessiert,
wie bei ihm jetzt so die politischen Konnotationen, sofern sie drinstecken,
ich nehme mal an, vorkommen, schauen wir da rein,
denn er ist ja als Weltreporter oder wie diese Orga da heißt,
auch ein großer Verfechter immer mal wieder Fokus auf Taiwan zu legen.
Im Sinne der großen geopolitischen Gemengelage, die hier zu diskutieren ist.
Gut.
Und dann mal gucken.
Also man findet uns im Salon und wir sagen noch mal ganz kurz,
wie man da reinkommt, Stefan.
Wir gehen auf neue20er.de, ein Podcast, der eine Webseite hat.
Jeder Podcast braucht eine Webseite. Man ist nicht nur bei Spotify und Apple
und so, sondern man hat eine Webseite, liebe Podcaster.
Und da ist ein goldener Button, da steht Salon drauf.
Klickt man einfach. Und schickt uns in dieser Liste, unten ist die E-Mail,
eine E-Mail, die geht automatisch an uns beide zu den diskutierten Themen,
Familienwahlrecht vor allem.
Ja, wir sind gespannt. Wer das nicht über Steady tun will, kann auch uns über
Patreon abonnieren oder für wen das praktischer ist, der mit dem iPhone unterwegs
ist, kann das auch für 50 Cent mehr,
dann über den Euro sogar mehr.
Apple will ja doch ein bisschen mehr von uns haben, kann das also auch darüber
sehr praktisch hören und auch sehr viel danach hören.
Wir verweisen nochmal auf diesen Live-Salon, in dem wir uns nicht nur mit Albrecht
von Lucke auseinandergesetzt haben, sondern wir sprechen da auch über… Kristallisieren.
Wir finden neue Grundbegriffe für politische Diskussionen, damit sie besser gelingen.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel.
Und wir deuten an, dass Emotionen doch eine Relevanz haben, aber wir werden
dieses Emotionen-Thema nochmal größer spielen, denke ich.
Wir werden es tief und scharf, wir haben es im Salon schon so ein bisschen angesprochen,
mit Fragen, die wir uns für uns stellen oder gemeinsam mal beantworten.
Und wir verraten, wie man reich wird. Wir haben uns nämlich mit dem passiven
Einkommen auseinandergesetzt.
Wir können aber schon mal spoilern, also um reich zu werden,
hilft es schon reich zu sein.
So viel können wir festhalten. Dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche im Salon.
Bis denn!